Untertitelung des ZDF, 2020
Bis zum nächsten Mal.
So, da bin ich.
Ich war die Woche nicht on.
Wisst ihr auch warum?
Ich hatte einen Teambuilding-Workshop auf der Arbeit.
Drei Tage.
Montag, Dienstag, Mittwoch.
Beziehungsweise, also,
dieser Workshop, der war eigentlich nur Dienstag und Mittwoch.
Aber ich bin Montagabend schon hingefahren,
weil das am Arsch der Welt war.
Und ihr könnt euch vorstellen,
Das war letztendlich die übliche Geschichte.
Merkwürdige Spielchen und viel zu fressen.
Richtig viel zu fressen.
Also massive gefressen habe ich wieder.
Huge.
Ich habe zweieinhalb Kilo zugenommen, nur an diesen zwei Tagen.
Drei Tagen.
Ja, massive Pipo-Fett.
Aber eineinhalb Kilo sind schon wieder weg.
Das ist ja nur im Umlauf.
Das ist ja nicht reines Fett, was man dazu nimmt.
Man kann in zwei Tagen nicht zweieinhalb Kilo Fett zunehmen.
Ja, die vom letzten Mal mache ich auch noch.
Die vom letzten Mal mache ich auch noch.
Ich habe aber zwei Stück.
Die habe ich die letzten zwei Tage gesehen.
Die muss ich euch zeigen.
Die sind total abgedrehter Kram.
Ist das Team jetzt gebildet?
Tja, keine Ahnung.
Also was auf jeden Fall gebildet ist, ist das Konto vom Trainer.
Das ist gebildet.
das wurde ordentlich gebildet ich will nicht wissen was es kostet so zwei tage workshop
also ich war ein ich mach mal kurz hier die linux kiste an das war montag auf dienstag dienstag auf
mittwoch und mittwoch noch den tagsüber leute ich glaube wir waren 15 jahren wir waren 15 leute und
Ich glaube, wir haben bestimmt im mittleren vierstelligen Bereich gefressen.
Allein schon am ersten Tag.
Wisst ihr, was ich am ersten Tag gefordert habe?
Also, lass mal überlegen, ob ich das noch zusammenkriege.
Also, ich hätte mir das im Leben nicht privat gekauft.
Das sage ich euch gleich, weil...
Dort hat eine Currywurst...
Okay, warte mal.
Chat, geh mal raten.
Also, das war jetzt kein irgendwie Sterne-Restaurant oder sowas.
Aber das war so ein bisschen schicker, könnte man sagen.
Ja, also etwas gehobener.
Ähm, oder konnte man unter anderem Currywurst bestellen.
Man hat dann so zwei Currywurststücke gekriegt mit Pommes frites dabei.
Ratet mal, was die Currywurst gekostet hat.
20 Euro, ziemlich gut geraten.
Ziemlich gut geraten, 19 Euro.
19 Euro Currywurst mit Pommes frites.
Hätte ich mir im Leben nicht gekauft normalerweise.
Hast du gut geraten?
oder was heißt geraten?
Gut gewusst.
19 Euro.
19 Euro Currywurst mit Pommes frites.
Yep.
Yep, Clock.
Und es ging noch weiter.
Schnitzel.
Oh.
Wann habe ich verbunden?
Warte mal.
Geht das jetzt?
Logitech.
Hallo?
Okay.
Schnitzel.
Das war ganz dünn.
geklopfte schnitzel paniert mit wahrscheinlich auch pommes frites oder
so ich weiß nicht genau so gab es gab so 22 runde schnitzel dinge ganz dünn 32
euro für 32 euro kriege ich bei uns hier um die ecke schnitzel platte für zwei
personen 32 euro also das war das war schon echt teuer
dann habe ich ich habe so ein bisschen rindfleisch gefordert das waren zwei
kleine stücke 33 euro naja was machst du bei der hitze dass der das ist bei dem pc im raum
kühl bleibt du meinst hier bei mir im arbeitszimmer ich habe die klimaanlage die mann lages an ich
kann nicht erkennen wie viel grad wir haben aber ich würde mal drauf tippen dass wir 24 grad oder
so gerade haben die mann lage steht auf 23 grad ist ja immer so ein zwei grad wärmer als was auf
der auf der fernbedienung steht ja 24 grad so haben wir gerade das habe ich mir vor ein paar
jahren gegönnt die klimaanlage übrigens denkt denkt mal please wieder dran wenn er sellout
modus startet mir bescheid zu sagen im stream dass ich den sellout machen kann und ich muss
mal einen Moment, Moment, Moment. Und ich muss
mein Sellout,
Sellout TXT
öffnen,
dass ich
reinschreiben kann, wann ich Sellout gemacht hab.
Ja. Also, also es war wirklich
teuer. Also, pass mal auf, am ersten Tag,
lass mal gucken, ob ich das zusammenkriege.
Ersten Tag hab ich gefressen,
Vorspeise, so,
so italienischen Kram
mit Mozzarella,
wie, wie hieß das?
Warte, da muss ich mal kurz gucken.
Burrata hieß das, glaube ich.
Sowas hier, ja, genau.
Ja, so ein bisschen in die Richtung sah das aus, ja.
Ja, ungefähr so.
Das, das, das, nein, nicht wirklich so.
So, keine Ahnung.
Letztendlich war es Mozzarella mit Tomate und ein bisschen Grünzeug und so.
sagen wir mal, es hat ungefähr
sagen wir mal, es hat
ungefähr so ausgesehen. Nicht ganz, nicht ganz.
Übrigens, übrigens, hier.
17 Euro.
Also das habe ich gefuttert.
Flammenkuchen
oder Flammenkuchen, wie auch immer man das
genau ausspricht, habe ich gefuttert
als Vorspeise. Allein schon das
zusammen hat wahrscheinlich
35 Euro
oder so gekostet.
Dann habe ich ein bisschen Rindfleisch
gefuttert. Das hat nochmal
33 Euro gekostet.
Und dann habe ich
als Nachtisch
ein Stück Apfeltorte,
ein Stück Schokoladenkuchen
mit Sahne gefressen.
Das war massive, Leute. Ich sage euch, ich habe so
krass gefressen wieder.
So habe ich da abends im Bett gelegen,
ungefähr. So hat es geschwabbelt.
Also ich habe ultra viel
gefressen wieder.
Peak Performance.
Ja.
High Performance Mindset.
Crimeset.
Ja. So und wenn ich mir vorstelle,
die anderen Leute bei uns,
die haben nicht nur so viel gefressen,
Die haben dann auch noch Wein gesoffen, auf Kosten der Firma.
Und der eine hat sich irgendwie, keine Ahnung, laufend Gläser nachbestellt.
Ohne Mist, mit den 15 Leuten über die drei Tage.
Wir haben bestimmt im mittleren vierstelligen Bereich einfach nur gefressen.
Und da waren noch nicht die Zimmer mit drin, noch nicht der Trainer mit drin und noch nicht alles andere mit drin.
Also ich gehe davon aus, das ist jetzt mal meine Schätzung, so ungefähr würde ich sagen.
Also ich würde sagen, die Firma hat wahrscheinlich so knapp fünfstellig bezahlt oder so für den drei Tage Workshop. Man darf ja nicht vergessen, was die Leute fressen, was die Leute trinken, die Unterkunft der Leute, der Trainer wird auch nicht billig sein, ja, quasi zwei Tage Programm.
an dem Tag, und das musst du ja auch noch einrechnen,
an dem Tag musst du deine
Leute weiter bezahlen, plus
sie arbeiten für das Geld ja eigentlich
nix. Also ich denke mal,
im niedrigen
5-stelligen Bereich wird das gekostet haben.
Aber ganz ehrlich,
die haben ja die Kohle.
Ich glaube nicht, dass sie das bereuen
werden. Die wollen das doch haben.
Die machen das seit Jahren schon und finden das
toll. Ich muss sagen,
Ich habe auch schon viel, viel schlimmere Workshops machen müssen.
Ja, also das war gar nicht schlecht.
Was wurde trainiert?
Wie man am besten Twitch-Emotes in den Alltagssprachgebrauch einbringt.
Hä, das war so ein Teambuilding-Event.
Was haben wir denn gemacht?
Also wir haben am ersten Tag Ikea-Regale zusammengebaut.
Ist jetzt kein Witz.
Ikea Regale im Team zusammengebaut, wo es darum ging, wer es am schnellsten aufgebaut kriegt mit fünf Leuten.
Und am zweiten Tag haben wir so eine Rennbahn gebaut für Murmeln.
Also stellt euch vor, ihr habt ein Rohr, das schneidet ihr in der Mitte durch, da habt ihr so eine Rutsche, so ein Stück von einer Rutsche.
Und wir mussten da eine Rutsche bauen
Wo man eine Murmel
Auf der hinten rein wirft
Und auf der anderen Seite sie in so eine Kiste fällt
Ja
Und ich war der Murmel reinschmeißer
Also das Ding war so
Man hatte nur so viele Teile
Wie man Leute hatte
Nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, Alter
Nerv nicht, Windows
Also wir hatten nur so viele Teile, wie wir Leute hatten.
Also 15 Teile für diese Rutsche und der Weg war zu lang.
Das heißt, Leute, die hinten standen, mussten dann vorrennen und die Rutsche verlängern.
Kann man sich das vorstellen?
So, und ich war, weil ich mit am besten, oder was heißt nicht mit am besten?
Also wir haben ein paar Leute, die sind ganz gut trainiert und ich gehe ja regelmäßig rennen.
Das heißt, ich habe den Murmel-Reinwerfer gespielt, ich habe die Murmel reingeworfen und bin dann so schnell wie es geht ans andere Ende geflitzt, dass die anderen ein bisschen mehr Zeit haben, sich da zu organisieren und loszulaufen.
Und die ersten 7-8 Mal bin ich quasi immer umsonst gerannt, weil sie die Murmel längst verloren haben, bevor die bei mir angekommen ist.
Ah ja. Hat sich mal gelohnt, dass ich regelmäßig rennen gehe.
Apropos, apropos regelmäßig rennen
Heute Leute, ey, ich bin fertig
Ich musste heute
Lass mal hier gucken
47, ich bin langsam gelaufen
Ich bin richtig langsam gelaufen
47 Minuten
Hat mein Plan gesagt, muss ich heute ran
Base Ausdauer soll ich trainieren
Da bin ich gerannt
Abgerundet 7 Kilometer
7,05 Kilometer
145 Puls im Durchschnitt
und durchschnittlicher Pace 640
also wirklich sehr gemütlich
und
genau 47 Minuten, wie das der Trainingsplan
sagt und Leute, ich sag euch
ich bin so im
Arsch, es waren 33
Grad und ich bin extra durch den Wald
gelaufen, ich halt
sagen wir mal so, dieses letzte Drittel musste ich halt
durch die Sonne laufen, ey ich war
so fertig. Ich glaube, ich habe 5 Liter
oder so rausgeschwitzt.
Nein, gar zu viel wird es
realistisch betrachtet nicht gewesen sein.
Moment, ich gucke mal kurz in meine
Garmin, was das meint.
Okay, die Garmin-App
meint, ich habe 783,
wie auch immer die das wissen will,
783 Milliliter rausgeschwitzt.
Über 47 Minuten.
Na, wenn die das meint.
Ich bin echt fertig gewesen. Es war brutal.
Bei 33 Grad und dann
das letzte Drittel durch die Sonne.
Also die letzten zweieinhalb Kilometer
Komplett durch die Sonne
In der Sonne war es wahrscheinlich 40 Grad
Ich habe noch eine halbe Stunde geschwitzt
Nachdem ich daheim war
Das hat aber nicht aufgehört
Also das hat wirklich reingehauen
Generell muss ich sagen
Also die letzten paar Tage ist wirklich eklig
Gestern auch, gestern waren plus 32 Minuten
Angesagt
Und das war aber halt abends
und da war es auch schon 35, 36 Grad.
Und eben Schatten.
Ey, da ist man einfach
komplett kaputt danach.
Um 23 Uhr
habe ich schon gepennt.
Dafür wird ein Trainer bezahlt, ja.
Jaja.
Für so etwas
zahlt die Firma.
Ah ja.
Diese ganzen
Teambuilding-Events sind immer so ein bisschen
wie soll man sagen, so ein bisschen
abgedrehtes
Zeug halt. So ein bisschen Kindergarten,
ein bisschen
Social-Event,
blödes Geschwätze.
Diese Events sind immer
kann man schwer beschreiben, Leute.
Wie kann man das Gefühl
auf solchen Teambuilding-Events beschreiben?
Das ist so eine Mischung aus
Kindergarten
und
und Social
Kram. Das ist schwierig.
Erzwungen. Ne, so schlimm
würde ich mal gar nicht sagen.
So schlimm war das gar nicht.
Ich fand das gar nicht so schlimm.
Das war eigentlich ganz lustig.
Vor allem, weil man halt so viel
fressen konnte.
Und die lassen sich da immer
nicht lumpen, was
die Unterkunft und das Essen angeht.
Ja, ja,
hab ich auch gesehen.
Ja, ich, ich,
mir ging es das letzte Jahr über
nicht gut. Da hatte ich keinen Bock
mich um YouTube zu kümmern.
Aber jetzt ist es wieder ein bisschen besser.
Nein, was heißt ein bisschen?
Es ist schon, im Vergleich zu noch vor einem Jahr ist es deutlich besser.
Klassenfahrt-Vibes.
Ja, das trifft es ganz gut.
So ein bisschen, so ein bisschen.
Kindergarten mit Klassenfahrt-Vibes.
So ungefähr fühlt sich das an, so ein Teambuilding-Workshop.
Meinst du, es bringt was, um das Team miteinander zu stärken?
auch später dann im normalen Arbeitsleben wieder...
Ja, glaube ich schon.
Ich glaube jetzt allerdings weniger, dass dieses Teambuilding da wirklich was bringt,
sondern einfach, dass man zwei Tage mal außerhalb der Arbeit mit den Leuten zusammen ist
und ein bisschen schwätzen kann und ein bisschen rumlaufen kann und sowas.
Also man versteht sich danach eventuell besser, wenn man sich in der Ehe schon gut verstanden hat.
Plus, was auch witzig ist, diese Spiele...
Ich glaube, diese Spiele sind gar nicht so sehr dafür da,
das ist meine Vermutung jetzt, ja.
Also, wir haben keinen Tower of Power gemacht diesmal, ne.
Ich glaube, diese Spiele sind gar nicht so sehr da,
dass die Spiele selbst was bringen,
sondern dass man im Nachhinein was hat,
wo das ganze Team drüber lachen kann.
So nach dem Motto,
kannst du dich noch dran erinnern,
als wir das und das gemacht haben?
Ja, lul, Alter.
Digga, ich kann mich noch dran erinnern.
I remember.
Ich meine, ich erzähle mir heute noch mit alten Kollegen
diesen diesen komischen dieses komische team building event was ich in meiner
firma hatte wo ich die ausbildung gemacht habe da hatten wir ein team
building event da hatten die den schauspiel trainer aus ulm nach
frankfurt fragt mich nicht warum es so gelaufen ist schauspiel trainer aus ulm
nach frankfurt gekarrt und er hat mit unserer team building workshop gemacht
wir haben dort sprachübungen gemacht das war so affig das war so dämlich alter
peinlich und dämlich. Wir mussten
dann so komische Sprachübungen
machen, wie man das wahrscheinlich im Schauspielerkurs
lernt oder so. Da haben wir dann
uns mit dem Gesicht zur Wand stellen
müssen und sowas hier machen.
Jetzt brauche ich meine Kamera, um das
zu zeigen. Wir mussten uns gegen die Wand
stellen und immer so machen. Mal gucken, ob man das
jetzt hört. So, gegen die Wand
mussten wir so machen. Guck.
Ich hoffe, das hat es jetzt nicht rausgefiltert.
Wir müssen immer
gegen die Wand machen.
Das war einfach nur richtig hängen geblieben.
Da erzählen wir uns heute noch was drüber,
weil es so dumm war.
Max, wie fandest du eigentlich deine Stellenanzeige damals bei deinem Arbeitgeber?
Also gibt es was, du noch weißt, was du kritisiert hast?
Oh, ich weiß es nicht mehr genau.
Ganz ehrlich, die Stellenanzeige war mir komplett egal.
Ne, zeig mal, zeig mal, schick mal einen Link, gucken wir uns gleich an.
Ähm, die Stellenanzeige weiß ich gar nicht, die war mir komplett egal.
Ich bin ja da nur darauf gekommen, weil ein ehemaliger Kollege, mit dem ich schon früher mal bei einem alten Arbeitgeber zusammengearbeitet habe,
mich angerufen hat und hat gesagt, hier Max, bei uns ist nice, willst du nicht zu uns kommen?
Da war mir der Inhalt der Stellenanzeige ziemlich egal, ich weiß gar nicht, was da eigentlich drinne stand.
Zumindest war das jetzt nicht, zumindest eins kann ich mir noch erinnern, das war jetzt sicherlich nicht die, nicht die, wie soll man sagen, inspirierendste Stellenanzeige.
Wo ich sage, boah geil, da muss ich unbedingt hin
Das war eigentlich nur noch 15 Stellen Anzeige
Aber nachdem mich mein Kollege
Quasi abgeworben hat da
Hab ich mir gedacht, okay, da kann es nicht schlecht sein
Wenn der es da gut findet
Wir wollen uns die neuen Serverpreise bei Hetzner angucken
Und Gehaltsdinger
Ach doch, das hab ich gesehen
100k, 105k oder sowas stand da doch, oder?
Ah ne, 156k
Ja, das habe ich glaube ich auf Reddit schon gesehen.
Also was will Google haben?
Staff Software Engineer, Site Reliability Engineer.
Oh, Leute, so heißt mein Job jetzt auch auf der Arbeit.
Ich bin jetzt auch Senior Site Reliability Engineer.
Warum? Keine Ahnung, weil die sich gedacht haben, Linux Engineer ist zu old school.
Das muss jetzt umbenannt werden.
Hat dein Kollege Vermittlungsprovisionen bekommen?
Ja.
Ich auch.
Ich habe ja auch einen Kollege noch direkt vermittelt.
Ich habe auch Vermittlungsprovisionen gekriegt.
Oh, da gibt es aber ordentlich Kohle.
Guck mal hier.
156k plus 20% Zielbonus.
Und irgendwelche Unternehmensaktienanteile oder sowas.
Das ist ordentlich. Aber ich kann euch sagen, die suchen auch nicht irgendeinen dahergelaufenen Kack-Noob.
Also musst du schon Ahnung haben, dass du das bei Google kriegst.
Und wahrscheinlich fünf Bewerbungsrunden mit Brainteaser-Fragen und live an der Tafel besprechen und so machen.
Ja, gibt schon ordentlich Kohle.
Also was suchen die denn? Sie suchen einen...
Okay, letztendlich studiert oder Ausbildung.
acht jahre experience in software development in einer oder mehrerer programmier sprach java cc
plus plus okay das war ja lass mal kurz abklopfen ob ich ob ich das ich will ich sage euch gleich
ich habe keine ich habe keine ambitionen zu wechseln nur mal so ob ich es theoretisch
erfüllen würde also ja ich habe acht jahre experience in software development in einer
und mehrerer programmier sprache das ding ist nur ich habe keine acht jahre erfahrung in software
entwicklung im enterprise umfeld ich habe nie als hauptberufliche anwendungsentwickler gearbeitet
ich programmiere schon lange und jetzt auch aber sie sehen die komplexe sachen in allen möglichen
gebieten ja wir haben vom micro controller bis web anwendungen und frontend sachen schon alles
desktop anwendung alles mögliche schon gemacht programmier sprachen kriege ich ganz gut hin dort
.NET kriege ich ganz gut hin.
Ruby kriege ich ganz gut hin.
Bash Descriptor kriege ich gut hin.
C Sharp kriege ich, äh, habe ich das nicht
schon, gar schon gesagt? Ja doch, .NET kriege ich schon hin.
Ja, also das, das würde hier wahrscheinlich
schon failen.
Fünf Jahre of Experiment
Networking, Warn Edge Routing
Protokolls. Also ganz ehrlich, das
in Kombination ist schon
relativ selten.
Weil das muss ja jemand sein, der
wirklich auch ordentlich, also wenn du hiermit
gerade das da, ne,
oder Routing-Produkte. Also wenn du hiermit
Erfahrung hast, dann musst du schon
eigentlich im Netzwerkbereich unterwegs
gewesen sein und
dann hast du nicht acht Jahre Software-Entwicklungssache.
Vier Jahre
Experience Designing, Analyzing, Trouble-Tooling,
Distributed Systems. Okay, das würde ich mal
sagen. Habe ich? Experience Leading
Projects involving Multiple Teams. Habe ich
nicht. Habe ich nicht.
Bam. So, komplett
könnte ich im Leben nicht,
ne? Also hier komme ich
zwar auch auf 8 Jahre, aber
bestimmt nicht auf Enterprise Experience.
5 Jahre Networking. Ja, ich
kenne mich da ganz brauchbar aus,
aber ich habe mich nicht 5 Jahre hauptsächlich um
Netzwerksachen gekümmert.
Das ist schon sehr anspruchsvoll,
muss man sagen.
Das kenne ich! Das wollte ich euch zeigen, die Stellenanzeige!
Ich habe mir 2 Stellenanzeigen
rausgesucht, die wollte ich euch zeigen.
Eine ist
die hier.
und redet ja genau ich habe aber noch eine andere noch eine andere dies noch
abgedreht ich habe noch eine andere dies noch abgedreht als die so aber wir
wollen uns erstmal herzner preise angucken
ach so chat kam schon erst laut habe ich überlesen sehr laut war schon erst laut
da egal wir machen mal kurz ich war ich träge ich träge mal kurz sind sellout
Moment, ich triggere den Sellout, zack, Bäm, Leute, ja man sieht's.
Leute, wenn ihr auf der Suche seid nach günstigem Storage, dann gebt doch jetzt mal Ausrufezeichen
Screen Ausrufezeichen Seagate
im Chat ein oder
guckt bei mir im
Twitch Profil
hier nach.
Könnt ihr da draufklicken. Dann kommt ihr
in einem Custom Alternate Shop bei raus.
Und wohlgemerkt, die Preise, die es
hier über den RevLink gibt, könnt ihr euch
ja mal angucken. Die Preise, die es hier über den RevLink
gibt, gibt es nur im Alternate
Shop über den RevLink.
Also jetzt nicht bei Alternate selbst, sondern nur, wenn ihr
über den Reflekt geht. Sonst ist es teurer.
Ihr findet es relativ günstig.
Seagate-Festplatten und Ukraine-Nasses.
Ukraine-Nasses haben wir hier auch
so schon im Stream gehabt. Oder wie sagt
der, wie sagt da der
Online-Marketing-Mensch
zu?
Max hatte schon Ukraine-Produkte
organisch im Stream,
Leute. Also wir hatten schon Ukraine organisch
im Stream bisher. Ein paar Mal
sogar. Ich habe ja hier zwei Ukraine-Nasses
rumstehen.
Und die finde ich auch ganz gut.
Das sind ein bisschen kleinere. Ich habe hier zwei Vorbay-NASes. Hier gibt es zwei Bay-NAS-Geräte. Einmal die Einsteiger-Variante mit, ich glaube auf Arm-Basis, wenn ich es jetzt nicht ganz verkehrt im Kopf habe.
auf Armbasis,
das heißt, es ist sehr sparsam,
hat aber vielleicht jetzt nicht die
Power, wie die ein bisschen größere
NAS ist. Das Ding ist aber, wenn
ihr reinen NAS sucht,
was schrumpfsparend ist,
und ihr mit zwei Festplatten-Slots
auskommt, ist das nicht verkehrt.
Und es ist ein relativ günstiges
Bundle. Ihr kriegt zwei 6TB-Platten
dabei und das NAS.
Plus, da ist schon, wohlgemerkt,
da ist schon RAM dabei. Müsst keinen RAM
mehr kaufen.
so oder ihr könnt euch auch das hier mal angucken
das ist das bisschen schneller das ist auf x86 basis leider schon mal 919 euro
ist trotzdem immer noch sehr günstig gibt es 26 terabyte platten dabei in
zwei bernas allerdings diesmal auf x86 basis und hier ist das gute wir haben
uns das nämlich letzten schon mal zusammen angeguckt
ihr bekommt einmal 8 gigabyte ram und der und die cpu also das ist eine
4-Kern-CPU
mit Crypto-Extensions.
Das heißt, wenn ihr jetzt da zum Beispiel
eure Festplatten voll verschlüsseln wollt
oder ZFS-Verschlüsselung benutzen wollt,
Lux unter Linux benutzen wollt,
sodass quasi die Daten verschlüsselt werden,
bevor sie auf der Festplatte landen, was ich euch ja immer
empfehle, weil dann die Platten einfach in den Müll schmeißen kannst,
dann geht das damit
ziemlich schnell. Und ihr habt
einen 2,5-Gig-Link,
also 2,5-Gig-Netzwerkkarte.
Und meine
vermutung ist ich habe es nicht ausprobiert ich habe das nass nicht hier
aber ich gehe ganz stark davon aus ihr kriegt den 2,5 gig link ausgelastet
saturated selbst mit entwicklten platten dadurch dass die cpu crypto extensions
hat und dadurch dass das in x86 cpu ist könnte da beispielsweise auch box mox
drauf installieren ob media wall drauf installieren ihr könnt schon als drauf
installieren ihr könnt euch in dem jahr an ubuntu drauf haben was ihr wollt die
Android drauf in 10. Ihr könnt natürlich auch
das Ugreen NAS OS benutzen, was
drauf ist. Da kann ich dir nichts zu
sagen. Ich hab das gleich runter
geschmissen bei meinen Ugreen Kisten.
Ich hab aktuell Proxmox bei mir
drauf, weil ich hauptsächlich auch Richtung, also
weil ich da vieles drauf virtualisieren will.
NAS ist quasi nur so ein
Nebending, was das mitmacht.
Also die Kisten eignen sich auch für
Virtualisierung und sowas. Und
letztendlich ist das Ding auch sehr
energiesparend.
Das heißt, wenn euch das interessiert
Geht auf mein Raffling, guckt euch das an
Guckt euch das hier im Shop an
Und letztendlich kaufen ist natürlich super easy
Klickt da hier drauf, zack, bam
In den Warenkorb, zack, speichern und auf geht's
Und wie gesagt, die Preise gelten nur, wenn ihr über mein Raffling kauft
Sonst ist es teurer
Excellent
So
Jetzt wollte ich mit euch Hetzner Preise angucken
aber vorher muss ich was machen ich muss meinen sellout aufschreiben sellout nach 28 minuten am
20.6 stellen anzeigen stream weil ich muss immer einmal pro stream sellout machen richtig hardcore
kostet ja laut.
Können wir uns auch mal angucken.
Die Produkte von
Synology sind
erstmal eine Sache. Und das sage ich jetzt
wirklich, das habe ich schon vorher gesagt, bevor ich jetzt hier irgendwie
Ugreen oder so gesponsert habe.
Die Produkte von Synology sind zwei Sachen.
Die sind teuer as fuck und die sind
outdated as fuck von der Hardware.
Das ist so.
Könnt ihr mal gucken,
was da drin ist und was sie sich für alte hartware bezahlen lassen was bei
seiner leute gut ist wenn man es haben will ist das gesamte software paket
das kann man was trinken
so lass uns mal gucken was sie wo sich die wie die preise sich hier entwickelt
haben jetzt cloud pricing beim das und so mal gucken und eigentlich zitter
nicht das ist die diese remote maus software die tut immer so als wird die
maus zittern
diese übrigens schon über das arbeitet das macht nichts alfred das macht nichts
Ich habe einen Link zu der Stellenanzeige noch auf StepStone, wo sie original drin ist mit Windows ME und 98.
War da nicht das Problem, dass nur bestimmte Festplatten funktionieren?
Das ist ein gutes Beispiel für, wie sehr sich die Hersteller ins eigene Fleisch schneiden können.
Synology hat nämlich angekündigt, und ich weiß, dass es nicht mehr so ist, bevor jetzt gleich einer kommt,
aber Max, die haben doch ein Rückzieher gemacht. Ich weiß, ich weiß, ich weiß, worauf ich raus will ist,
Synology hat gesagt, demnächst werden sie nur noch zertifizierte Festplatten unterstützen in ihren Lastgeräten.
Da war der Aufschrei riesengroß und sie haben wieder einen Rückzieher gemacht.
Aber bei den Leuten im Kopf ist hängen geblieben, Synology geht demnächst nur mit zertifizierten Festplatten.
Da seht ihr mal, wie die sich selbst gebummst haben mit so einem Geschwätz.
Also es ist gar nicht so.
Aber jeder hat es noch im Kopf.
Aber da sind die selbst dran schuld.
Wie sehr würdest du eine Ausbildung in der IT mit Blick auf Hardware aktuell empfehlen?
Hä?
Wie jetzt?
Den Zusammen...
Du meinst die aktuellen Hardwarepreise oder was?
Was haben denn aktuelle Hardwarepreise mit der Ausbildung in der IT zu tun?
Das musst du etwas konkreter schreiben.
Das verstehe ich nicht.
Wie sehr würdest du eine Ausbildung in der IT mit Blick auf Hardware...
Achso! Ne! Ach, ich bin dumm. Vergiss es.
Du meinst, wie sehr würde...
Ob ich eine Ausbildung in der IT machen würde, wenn ich mich hauptsächlich mit Hardware beschäftigen will.
So meinst du das, oder?
Ja, klar.
Ich meine, das ist das Einzige, was du machen kannst, wenn du dich sinnvoll mit Hardware beschäftigen willst.
Lernst du Fachinformatik oder Systemintegration?
die ersten paar Jahre
während der Ausbildung und nach der Ausbildung
war ich
sehr viel Turnschuh-Admin-mäßig
unterwegs. Also ich war an unterschiedlichen
Standorten in Frankfurt, unterschiedlichen Rechenzentren,
hab täglich Rundgang gemacht,
mir das Ganze angeguckt,
wenn irgendwelche Fehler waren, Festplatten, Netzteile,
Netzwerkkarten, Gedöns ausgetauscht,
neue Sachen gepatcht, eingebaut,
also so was man sich so unter
Hardware vorstellt.
Als du
meinst du willst dich mit consumer hardware beschäftigen also desktop pc ist
oder sowas da habe ich keine ahnung aber ich vermute mal stark dass deine
physioausbildung auch das beste ist
ich hatte mal glasfaser glasfaser splitter in den fingern
während in der zeit wo ich da öfters im rechenzentrum war das juckt das juckt
und sticht.
Und wir haben damals Server noch eingebaut, von Hand.
Ohne elektronischen
Hebewagen und ohne
Akkuschrauber.
Da wurde Schienen
eingebaut, das
8HE Playcenter reingehievt,
reingeschraubt,
angeschlossen.
Nicht so wie heute.
Ihr habt da einen Hebewagen.
Ja, die
Meine letzten zwei Azubis haben mir jeweils erzählt, dass bei uns auf der Arbeit, also da wo ich jetzt arbeite, im Rechenzentrum, wenn dort Server eingebaut werden, dann haben die so einen elektronischen Hebewagen und eine Akkuschraube, um das Zeug einzubauen.
Darum habe ich auch noch gesagt, Jungs, das hätte es bei mir früher nicht gegeben.
So, Opa Max hat wieder vom Krieg erzählt.
Ihr solltet euch auch mal so einen elektronischen Hebelwagen, Hebel, wie auch immer man das Ding nennt, kaufen.
So, aber jetzt gucken wir uns mal die Preise bei Hetzner an, was ich eigentlich fordere.
Hatten die hier nicht, hatten die hier nicht so einen Pricing-Chart? Wo ist denn das hin?
Achtung, Achtung Leute, Flashbang.
Bäm.
Okay, so ist besser.
Äh, wo haben die denn ihre Pricing-Übersicht?
Die hatten ja doch immer so eine schöne Pricing.
Haben die keine Pricing-Seite mehr?
Na gut, hier kann man es ja auch anklicken.
Also, Share, Cost Optimized, Regular, Dedicated, General Purpose
Hier, das da, Shared, Cost Optimized
Wir wollen
Ach, drei gibt es gar nicht mehr
Das war früher, das war früher meine Lieblingskiste
Drei, drei CPUs für, für, für
4,50 Euro oder sowas
Okay, ich mein, zwei V-CPUs reicht
Für Kleinkram auch raus, aber sag mal so
Vier wär schon nicht verkehrt
Sind das jetzt schon die neuen Preise?
Das erscheint mir immer noch zu günstig für neue Preise.
Das sind die...
Was kosten die Armkisten?
Warum...
Chat, warum sind die Armkisten teurer als die x86-Kisten?
Was nutzt sie denn als Virtualisierer?
virtualisieren
ich tippe mal ganz stark auf für bei linux auf kvm
könnte natürlich auch vor immer sein im enterprise umfeld ist vor allem sehr beliebt wobei ich keine ahnung aber petzner bock hat
lizenzgebühren großartig wird zu bezahlen
Also also ich tippe mal auf irgendwas kvm basiertem
Können wir nachgucken könnten wir nachgucken wenn wir eine kiste bei hätten
Chat, falls einer
von euch die Niedlungskiste gerade bei Hetzner hat,
gebt doch mal, beziehungsweise installiert
mal WirtWatt
und führt das mal aus.
Da sollte dann da... Okay, guck mal,
dass das vor allem bei Workstation ist, er kennt das gar nicht.
Cool.
So, neue Preise
bei Hetzner.
Äh,
Cloud-Servers.
Na geil.
Ich würde das gerne...
Ah, hier, 799.
Naja.
CX-33.
Gucken wir mal hier.
Ne, Moment.
Moment.
Ich wollte gerade sagen.
What the fuck, Alter.
Hier.
849.
Das ist schon der neue Preis.
Aber ganz ehrlich.
Ganz ehrlich.
Ich finde das ist immer noch okay.
899.
Für eine Vierkernkiste.
Mit wie viel Speicher hat denn das Ding?
20 Gig oder so.
Steht gar nicht mehr dabei.
früher hatten die so eine schöne übersicht wo man das direkt erkannt hat wie viel speicher und so
gibt es immer
Schau mal dedicate ja gut das sind ja auch echte hardware kisten oder
Oder oder ist es das
Oder sind das...
Ah, ne.
Ne, ne, das sind auch 4Ms wahrscheinlich.
Vermutlich.
Also hier sind schon die Preise teilweise echt ganz ordentlich.
Guck mal, die gehen hoch von 15,99 Euro auf 42 Euro.
Das haut rein, das haut rein, Leute.
Von 16 Euro auf 42 Euro.
Und jetzt gucken wir mal was bisschen dickeres an, hier sowas zum Beispiel.
Von 62 Euro auf 138 Euro.
Das ist schon wirklich ordentlich.
Das sind schon mal richtig brutale Erhöhungen.
Aber ganz ehrlich, was sollen die auch machen?
Was sollen die machen?
RAM kostet, ist teuer as fuck.
Und vor allem Speicher ist teuer as fuck.
Was sollen die machen?
Also denen bleibt ja nicht wirklich viel übrig.
Freiwillig.
So nach dem Motto, oh wir wollen ein bisschen extra Geld machen.
machen die das bestimmt nicht.
Das kann ich mir nicht vorstellen, weil
die verkaufen garantiert weniger.
Also für die wäre es deutlich besser,
die Hardwarepreise wären günstiger
und sie könnten es günstiger anbieten.
Aber das sind doch die Maschinen im Bestand.
Wieso, die müssen sich permanent neue Hardware kaufen,
permanent neuen Storage kaufen,
permanent neuen RAM kaufen.
Was meinst du, was da kaputt geht
bei der Menge, was die da haben?
Da wird am Tag so und so viel ausgetauscht im Durchschnitt
Ja, jetzt mal ganz
Wir machen jetzt mal eine Rechnung, die wahrscheinlich mit der Realität nichts zu tun hat
Aber guck mal
Wenn du 100 Server betreibst
Und Headseter betreibt das ja nicht mit, zum größten Teil zumindest
Nicht auf echter Server-Hardware
sondern das sind relativ niedrigpreisige Consumer-Dinger, die quasi bis zum letzten Bit ausgenutzt werden, bis sie auseinanderfallen.
Und jetzt überleg mal, wenn du nur 100 Server hostest, so mit Consumer-Hardware und allem, und du nur eine Fehlerrate von 1% hast pro Tag,
Dann geht am Tag ein Server kaputt.
Und die haben deutlich mehr als 100.
Da gehen, weiß was ich, da gehen am Tag wahrscheinlich eine Hand voll oder zwei Hände voll Server kaputt, die ausgetauscht werden müssen.
Oder mehr. Ich weiß gar nicht, wie viele insgesamt. Die haben wahrscheinlich noch viel, viel mehr.
Die gehen da kaputt. Es geht Rammriegel kaputt, Platten kaputt.
Die müssen ausgetauscht werden.
Denen bleibt gar nichts anderes übrig, als das teurer zu machen.
Also, die machen das bestimmt nicht freiwillig.
Weil das viele Leute davon abschreckt.
Ich meine, überlegt euch mal.
15,99 im Monat für eine...
Ja, guckt mal.
15,99 für eine Kiste mit zwei Kors.
Was will ich, wie viel RAM? Das sieht man ja hier irgendwie nicht mehr.
Keine Ahnung.
Das kannst du, das ist in Ordnung. Das kannst du machen.
42 Euro.
Das werden sich viele überlegen, ob sie das machen.
Ich meine, 42,99 Euro
für eine
Zweikernkiste.
Das ist schon brutal.
Was ist denn da
an RAM dabei?
Ach, hier ist ja die Übersicht.
die habe ich doch gesucht.
Ja,
8 Gig. Du bezahlst,
guck mal, also das hält sicherlich einige
Leute davon ab. Guck mal, du bezahlst
43 Euro im Monat
für zwei Kerne
8 Gig RAM,
80 Gig SSD.
Das ist halt der Witz. Aber die können
das nicht. Die können nichts dagegen machen.
Die müssen den Kram hier kaufen und das kostet halt.
Das ist teuer.
Ganz ehrlich.
Chat, Chat.
Hände hoch, Hände hoch.
Wer für so eine Kiste bereit gewesen wäre, wie gesagt, wir reden hier von einer Dedicated-Kiste,
beziehungsweise keine wirklich, also nein, keine Dedicated-Kiste,
eine VM mit für dich reservierten Ressourcen.
Also fast eine Dedicated-Kiste.
Für 15,99 Euro im Chat.
Wer sowas braucht, wer würde es für 15,99 im Chat,
wer würde es für 15,99 im Monat mieten?
15,99.
Also ich würde es mieten, wenn ich sowas brauche.
Ganz klar.
Klar, würde ich machen.
Wenn ich es brauche, wenn ich wirklich ordentliche Performance bräuchte,
zwei Kerne, ich keine Sherrits-Infrastruktur haben will,
würde ich mir das holen.
So.
Aber noch viel eher ist die Frage, Chat,
wer würde es sich für 42,99 holen?
wahrscheinlich keiner mehr
ach für 42 wärst du dabei
logisch, logisch, wär nicht, ja
du willst ja auch, dass es Hetzer gut geht
also wahrscheinlich holt sich da kaum noch einer dafür
deswegen, die werden deutlich weniger verkaufen
aber denen bleibt dann nichts anderes übrig
Wollen wir mal in der Serverauktion gucken, was man da aktuell gerade so bekommt.
Gucken wir mal, Preis, maximal 50 Euro.
Da sind wir so ungefähr in der Preisrange.
Gucken wir mal, was wir dafür kriegen.
AMD, Intel nehme ich bei, das ist kein Problem.
RAM nehme ich auch alles, was es gibt.
Trials ist mir ein Wurscht.
Äh, was ist denn eine iNIC?
NIC ist eine Netzwerkkarte, aber was ist eine iNIC?
Ach, Integrated Network.
Aber die haben doch alle eine Integrated Netzwerkkarte.
Wie soll das sonst so funktionieren?
Keine Ahnung
Also was kriegst du denn hier
Guck mal
Hier kriegst du
Einen Core i7 6700
Eine Vierkernkiste oder
Aus dem Jahr 2015
Vierkerne
Für 46 Euro
32 Giga Gramm
Aber das ist wahrscheinlich auch DDR3
Also das ist auf jeden Fall schon ein bisschen
Das ist auf jeden Fall schon ein bisschen ältere Kiste
Aber ganz ehrlich
Es hat sich die letzten 10 Jahre
Zwar sehr viel getan bei Hardware
Aber nicht zu vergleichen mit den 10 Jahren davor
Also du kommst heute auch mit einer 10 Jahre alten Serverkiste
Mit einer Vierkern CPU und 32 Giga Gramm
für vieles sehr gut aus.
Ach, Intel-Netzwerkkarte
soll das heißen.
Guck mal, hier gibt es sogar noch
ein bisschen neuere.
Oh, das ist gut.
Das ist ein guter Preis.
Also, sage ich jetzt einfach mal so aus dem Bauch raus.
Guck mal, hier gibt's
Von 2017
Hier kriegst du für 51 Euro im Monat
Kriegst du
Ne 4 Kern CPU
Mit 64 GB RAM
Und 2x 512 GB SSD
Wohlgemerkt, wahrscheinlich ist das alles
Auch schon 9 Jahre alt, ne
Wir können mal kurz gucken, was das hier für ein Speicher ist
DDR4 Speicher ist das auch
Na wobei, haha
Ja, das kann DDR4 und DDR3.
Wahrscheinlich ist es Lowdings und es ist noch DDR4 oder so.
Nee, es ist tatsächlich DDR4 ECC.
Also ich finde, das ist jetzt mal gar kein schlechtes Angebot.
Hier, 51 Euro.
64 Gramm.
Bam.
1 Terabyte SSD.
Was sagt ihr?
Also ich, ganz ehrlich, wenn ich sowas bräuchte, würde ich mir das gönnen.
Aber brauche ich nicht.
By the way, lasst uns mal was gucken.
Erinnert ihr euch noch dran?
Wir haben mal vor 2-3 Jahren, ist schon eine ganze Weile her,
haben wir mal eine ganz fette Kiste bei Hetzner gemietet.
Mit, ich glaube, 32 CPU-Kernen oder sowas.
Dass ich Open Street View Maps preprocessen konnte.
Ich bin mir nicht mehr sicher, was wir uns da gekauft haben.
Lass uns mal kurz gucken, was das jetzt kosten würde.
Ich hab das bloß ein paar Stunden laufen gehabt.
Ja, das hat mich am Ende auch noch ein paar Euro gekostet.
Gibt's hier gar nicht.
Die sind zu klein hier.
Das ist...
Da muss ich Dedicated Resources gucken.
Hier.
Ja, irgend so eine Kiste hier hatten wir hier laufen.
533 Euro im Monat würde die jetzt kosten.
So eine Kiste hatten wir da laufen, glaube ich.
So eine oder so eine.
Ich bin mir da gar nicht mehr sicher, welche das gewesen ist.
Ich glaube fast, wir hatten die hier laufen.
Ich glaube, wir hatten sogar die fetteste laufen.
Weil wir viel RAM gebraucht haben.
Aber wie gesagt, das kostet 853 Euro jetzt im Monat.
Damals hat das vielleicht die Hälfte gekostet.
Und ich hatte das auch nur für ein paar Stunden laufen.
Guck, es kostet hier 1,4.
Ich habe das irgendwie 2-3 Stunden laufen gehabt.
Dann war gut.
Also ich habe da nur ein paar Euro für bezahlt.
Aber das ist schon ordentlich.
Gut.
Hätten wir das.
Hetzner wird weiterverkaufen, aber ich glaube trotzdem, dass insgesamt weniger was kaufen werden.
Die sagen sich, dafür ist es mir das nicht wert.
Es hat ja nicht jeder was, was er unbedingt für jeden Preis weiterlaufen lassen will.
Werbung kam gerade.
Kam gerade Banner-Einblendung.
Ja dann Leute, Ausrufezeichen, Ukraine Ausrufezeichen, Seagate Ausrufezeichen, Alternate im Chat.
Könnt ihr euch günstig Storages, Storages Alter.
Könnt ihr euch günstig in Nassus und günstigen Storage kaufen.
Wohlgemerkt nur über meinen Revlink.
Ist das Ganze gültig.
Dass viele Stellanzeige gerade nur aus Marketinggründen online sind.
Das weiß ich nicht.
Aber.
Könnte ich mir vorstellen, dass das manche machen, ja.
Okay.
So.
Dann.
Hier rüber.
Müssen wir noch irgendwas machen, bevor wir uns anfangen können, Stellenanzeigen anzugucken?
Nee, ich glaube nicht.
Übrigens, Chat, wer von euch benutzt öfters Reddit? Ich vermute mal die meisten. Aber wahrscheinlich benutzen relativ viele Reddit.
Bekommt ihr da auch regelmäßig Werbung für neue Spiele?
So zwischen den Posts.
Und wisst ihr, was mich da voll abfuckt?
Also ich bekomme ganz viel Werbung für neue Spiele auf Steam.
Siehst du immer den Link auf Steam.
Und ich klicke den Link an.
Ich denke mir, ey, das klingt ja gar nicht so schlecht.
Und ohne Mist, 95% der Links auf Reddit, die auf Steam führen, sind Spiele, die erst noch erscheinen.
Die teilweise noch nicht mal ein Datum haben, wann sie erscheinen.
Und welche, die schon erschienen sind, sind Early Access.
Wirklich in 5% der Fällen.
ist es vielleicht ein fertiges Spiel, was schon erschienen ist.
Ich verstehe den Sinn von dieser Werbung nicht.
Was ist der Sinn davon?
Meinen die ernsthaft, ich denke 2027 noch dran,
dass ich jetzt Mitte 2026 mal eine Werbung für irgendein Game auf Reddit gesehen habe?
Wishlist? Ich bin überhaupt nicht eingeloggt bei Steam in meiner Twitter-App.
In meiner Reddit-App.
Bin ich überhaupt nicht auf Steam eingeloggt?
Also den Sinn verstehe ich nicht.
Das macht überhaupt...
Null, null check ich das gar nicht.
Ich glaube, ich habe noch nicht ein Spiel darüber empfohlen bekommen, was ich mir dann letztendlich gekauft habe.
Die Wishlist soll wichtig sein.
Ja, aber...
Ja, ist da jemand in der Reddit-App in Steam eingeloggt?
Das sind doch die wenigsten.
Das glaube ich nicht.
Auf dem Desktop, okay.
geht da normalerweise die steam app auf also bei mir geht wenn ich werde den link anklicken geht
bei mir geht bei mir der browser auf in der reddit app die reddit app sagt übrigens auch
aber glücklicherweise sagte nicht mehr so krass wie vor ein paar jahren noch
So Leute, auf geht's
Also
Ich wollte euch jetzt zwei Stellenanzeigen zeigen
Die wirklich sehr keck W sind
Ich muss erstmal hier danach suchen
Der Apollo Reader gibt es nicht mehr
Systemadministrator
Slash
Programmierer
So, und das ist bei Stepstone
Hier
Das da
Wie, das ist weg?
Ah, da ist es doch
Ne, passt
Also, ich hab zwei Stellenanzeigen gefunden
wo ich mir gedacht habe, Leute, die muss ich euch mal zeigen.
Die sind etwas...
...etwas merkwürdig.
Die Old Version von Reddit,
das ist die aber immer noch.
Die wurde noch nicht angepasst. Hier, guck.
Aber wir können uns auch die alte Version
auf Reddit angucken.
Äh.
Tja.
Wenn ich die auf Reddit finde.
Ah, du hast den Reddit.
Post.
Ja, da ist es doch.
Okay, also.
Das war die Stellenanzeige, die ursprünglich gepostet wurde.
Also, sie suchen
Profnet. Übrigens die Webseite, by the way,
by the way,
die Webseite sieht übrigens so aus.
Also,
hat angerufen.
Profnet.
Professor Dr. Uwe.
Der hat die bestimmt selbst gemacht.
Tagebuch.
Okay.
Also, die ursprüngliche
Stellenanzeige von denen
war, wir gucken uns das einfach mal
von oben nach unten an. Kann man das
hier irgendwie ausblenden?
Das ist jetzt vielleicht ein bisschen fett, oder?
Egal, das passt so, dann sieht man es.
Also, das ProfNet-Institut für Internet-Marketing
in Münster ist seit 27
Jahren der Maschinenraum
des ProfNet Professoren-Netzwerks.
Habe ich noch nie gehört, aber okay, meinen muss ich ja auch nicht,
ich bin ja auch nicht in diesem Gebiet irgendwie aktiv.
Wir unterstützen Professoren, Professorinnen,
Insti... Ups.
Institute und Hochschulen bei ihren Forschungsprojekten mit internen Dienstleistungen
und unter anderem betreuen wir mit 2,3 Millionen wissenschaftlichen Publikationen
die größte deutschsprachige Digitalbibliothek.
Sie suchen dafür einen Systemadministrator-Programmierer.
Also allein schon das ist eine seltene Mischung, nennen wir es mal so.
Das ist schon eher ungewöhnlich.
heutzutage wird er nach full stack developer gesucht oder der fox engineers oder sowas wenn
es irgendwas sein soll was ein bisschen ahnung von allem haben soll aber so in der variante
sieht man das sieht man es selten wobei man auch sagen muss denn full stack entwickler
ist auch keine IT-Abteilung in einem.
Auch wenn das oftmals in Stellenanzeigen so wirkt.
Naja, also ihr Aufgabenfeld
geht schon gut los. Microsoft
Windows Server administrieren, sowie
die vorhandenen MySQL Datenbanken
pflegen und weiterentwickeln.
Und jetzt
kommt der Hit. Circa 30
vorhandene Programme
HTML, Java, JavaScript,
PHP pflegen
und gegebenenfalls weiterentwickeln.
30.
Also du bist Windows-Admin, Datenbank-Admin und fuddlest noch in abartigster Legacy-Software wahrscheinlich rum.
Wisst ihr, was ich glaube? Also meine Vermutung ist, ja, der, keine Ahnung, Hans Günther ist in Rente gegangen.
Und jetzt suchen sie halt jemand, der das macht, was vorher der Hans Günther gemacht hat.
Okay, es geht aber noch weiter.
Das ist noch nicht alles.
Du administrierst Windows-Server, du administrierst Datenbanken,
du kümmerst dich um 30 Oldschool-Legacy-Programme.
Du kümmerst dich aber auch noch um die Arbeitsplatzrechner
sowie die IT-Technik installieren, pflegen und warten.
Also du kümmerst dich auch noch um Arbeitsplatzrechner
und so Sachen wie vielleicht Telefonanlage
oder Drucker,
IT-Technik, ja,
Drucker,
Telefone,
Videoprojektoren
und alles mögliche.
Faxgeräte,
um das WLAN,
um Netzwerk.
Das gibt hoffentlich
eine Menge Kohle.
Ja, ganz bestimmt.
Das Schöne ist, die haben tatsächlich
Gehalt dran stehen.
So, Deutsch kennt er gut.
Einschläge, Berufserfahrung im Aufgabenfeld.
Programmierkenntnisse in den
internetbezogenen Programmiersprachen.
Das verstehe ich nicht.
Was soll das überhaupt bedeuten, Chat?
Der meint das HTML?
Also, du musst ja auch Ahnung von Java haben.
Die könnten bestimmt noch Silverlight.
Die haben bestimmt noch Silverlight-Anwendungen.
Das passt da richtig gut dazu.
Und Flash-Anwendungen und sowas.
Java Applets.
Only im Internet Explorer.
So, dann geht's weiter.
Bereitschaft, sich in vorhandene Altprogramme
einzuarbeiten, vorteilhaft.
Nein, mir bleibt ja nichts anderes da übrig.
wenn ich dafür verantwortlich bin.
Du musst dich dafür einarbeiten.
Vor allem ITIL-Expertise.
Das ist irgendwie
ein bisschen random.
Testerzertifizierung.
Was genau?
Als würde da irgendwas mit
ITIL laufen.
Die haben eine IT-Person
für alles. Als würde da irgendwas
mit ITIL laufen.
Was ist
eine Testerzertifizierung?
Ich weiß es wirklich nicht.
Was ist eine Testerzertifizierung?
Gibt es sowas?
Ich habe wirklich keine Ahnung, was das sein soll.
ISTQB.
Was ist denn das?
Ich hoffe, das ist jetzt keine Abkürzung für irgendwas Perverses.
Und ich suche da jetzt danach.
International Software Testing Qualification Board.
What?
Es gibt eine Zertifizierung für Software Tester.
Was es nicht alles gibt.
Gibt es jemanden, der das hat?
Also gibt es wirklich Leute, die sowas haben?
Na gut, das hätten sie.
Das hätten sie zumindest gerne.
Du willst das machen?
Echt? Und was meinst du?
Okay, okay, das interessiert mich jetzt.
Oh Gott, ich muss die Webseite wegmachen.
Was versprichst du dir davon?
Oder vielleicht, was, sag mal so, von was weißt du, dass es die, also, du musst ja irgendwelche Vorteile davon versprechen.
Und was sagt, also, von welchen Vorteilen weißt du denn, die du damit hättest?
Oder willst du nicht da bewerben?
Das gibt es ja wahrscheinlich.
Ah, das würde mich wirklich interessieren.
Ich wusste bis heute nicht, dass das überhaupt existiert.
Okay, gucken wir mal weiter.
Also ich meine, ich will das nicht schlechtreden.
Mich würde wirklich interessieren, was du dir denkst, was das bringt.
Also vielleicht hast du ja auch schon von einem Arbeitgeber gehört.
Ah, viele renommierte, jedoch konservative Unternehmen fragen danach oder merken das positive...
Okay, tschüss zu mir.
Ich habe davon noch nie gehört.
Also ich habe vorher bei einer Bank gearbeitet, jetzt arbeite ich bei einer Versicherung.
Ich glaube viel konservativer und bestimmt auch renommiert kann man ja kaum sein.
Also, das habe ich noch nirgendwo gesehen, dass das bei uns jemand gerne hätte.
Aber vielleicht ist es ja sowas, wenn man das im Vorstellungsgespräch droppt, dass man das hat, sagen sie alle, boah geil, Testerzertifizierung.
Könnte ja sein.
Ich mach das mal.
Chat, ich frage am Dienstag mal auf der Arbeit einen von unseren Entwicklern, ob der eine Ahnung hat, dass es eine Testerzertifizierung gibt.
und was er davon hält.
So, also gucken wir mal weiter.
Kenntnisse in Java, Java Enterprise.
Bild da mal nach QA-Engineer-Stellenausschreibung.
Also sowas wie Qualitätssicherung auf Deutsch.
Da siehst du IST-QB öfters.
Aha, siehste?
Habe ich noch nie mit dem Gedanken gespielt, sowas zu machen.
Deswegen habe ich mir das auch nie angeguckt.
Deswegen habe ich es wahrscheinlich auch noch nie gesehen.
Das wird es wahrscheinlich sein.
Also, Kenntnisse in Java, Java Enterprise,
Java Spring.
Ah, sehr hübsche, sehr hübsche Gui
gibt es dann. Guck mal, die Spring Guis
sehen immer so toll aus. Die sind so richtig...
Ach nee, sorry, sorry, nicht Spring.
Swing. Ich habe mich
vertan. Ich meinte
Swing Guis, nicht Spring. Spring haben wir ja auch
schon gemacht. Spring ist tatsächlich
ganz nice. Wobei, Moment, Moment,
Moment. Ist Spring
und Spring Boot das gleiche.
Chat.
Ich kenne mich im Java-Ökosystem nicht so aus.
HiIQ-Java-Devs.
Spring Boot.
Okay, das ist das gleiche anscheinend.
Spring versus Spring Boot.
Okay.
Spring Boot ist quasi die Spring Extension
für Web
Framework Geschichten
Okay, okay
Das ist, okay
Davon hätte ich sogar ein bisschen Ahnung mittlerweile
Kenntnis und Aufgeschlossenheit
War mit Kenntnis und Aufgeschlossenheit
Im Umgang mit neuen Medien, IOS Geräten
und den gängigen Kollaborationssystem.
Ah, den gängigen.
Also heißt Teams.
Oder wie?
Ich wette mit euch, Leute.
Die haben irgend so ein super
oldschool, obskures
Web-Kollaborationsystem,
was
wahrscheinlich nur noch eine Handvoll auf der Welt einsetzen.
Das wird bei denen nicht Teams sein.
Das wird irgendwie so was wie
Webex oder so.
Was gab es denn da früher noch?
Link!
Kennt das noch jemand?
Die haben bestimmt Microsoft Link.
Skype for Business gab es dann später.
Ja.
Das haben die bestimmt noch.
Vielleicht haben die auch noch Lotus Notes.
Domino. Ja, das kann sein.
Selbstständige und präzise Arbeitsweise
Analytische Kommunikation
Hochschul... Moment
Seriously
Hochschulabschluss in Informatik
Alter
Na gut, ey, ich mein
Du arbeitest hier immerhin für Professoren
Da geht das natürlich nicht, ja
So, und jetzt kommt der Hit übrigens
Jetzt kommt der Hit gleich
Ja.
Zwingend erforderlich.
Betriebssystem Windows 3.x, Windows 95, Windows 98, Windows ME.
Da kannst du dir vorstellen, auf was diese 30 vorhandenen Anwendungen laufen, Alter.
Was ist das?
PHP?
PHP 1.4 oder was ist das?
PHP Versions.
Ja.
Wahrscheinlich.
Wahrscheinlich PHP 3 oder sowas noch am Start.
Ach, die Anzeige selbst ist neu.
Vielleicht ist es...
Copy-Paste.
So und jetzt kommt der Hit. Also das ist ja schon eine umfangreiche, anspruchsvolle Aufgabe. Windows Server, Datenbanken, uralte Legacy-Anwendungen in uralten Frameworks wahrscheinlich.
Du musst dich um Arbeitsplatzrechner kümmern, Drucker, Faxgeräte, Videokonferenzen, was auch immer.
Und du sollst dich auch noch mit Windows 3.11 und 3.1 und 95, 98 mehr auskennen.
Jetzt gucken wir mal, ob die auch bereit sind, dafür ordentlich was zu bezahlen.
Postchamp.
49k.
Schon geil, oder?
Zahlendreher.
Ah, 94k.
Okay, da kann man bei sowas drüber reden.
Wahrscheinlich auch noch Proto...
Ja klar.
Das ist halt...
Nix...
Für sowas. Das ist wirklich gar nix.
Das ist bei anderen Stellen schon nicht viel.
Pro Monat könnten wir drüber reden.
Chat schlägt vor, wir sollten uns alle mal da bewerben, so als Trollaktion.
Davon, davon, äh, Chat.
Ich muss euch davon abraten, das zu machen.
Ich will hier nicht dafür verantwortlich sein, wenn die irgendwelche Probleme kriegen durch diese Stellenanzeige.
Ich meine, was ihr privat macht, kann ich euch eh nicht vorschreiben, aber ich rate euch davon ab, das zu machen.
Moin Möppi.
Die haben wahrscheinlich schon genug Probleme, ja.
Flexible und familienfreundliche Arbeitszeiten
sowie 30 Tage Urlaub pro Jahr bei einer 5-Tage-Woche.
Hybride Arbeitsplatz, Münster und Homeoffice.
Homeoffice-Unfang nach Vereinbarung.
Das ist, wette, ich wette mit euch, das ist irgendein Trick wieder.
So nach dem Motto, wir schreiben mal Homeoffice rein,
weil sich dann mehr Leute bewerben und dann sagen sie am Ende doch,
Du musst so viel vor Ort machen.
Homeoffice ist leider nicht möglich.
Guck, der hat die gleiche Vermutung hier.
Also das ist schon echt
eines der abgedrehtesten Stellenanzeigen,
die ich bisher gesehen habe.
Und wir hatten schon ein paar.
Aber Chat, die nächste Stellenanzeige,
da kann ich noch einen oben draufsetzen.
Die wird noch abgedrehter.
Die hat mir nämlich eine auf Twitter geschickt.
Ja.
Head of IT.
Ich meine, immerhin, immerhin wollen die hier ein bisschen was bezahlen.
Ob es dann am Ende auch so wird, weiß man nicht.
Head of IT Europe.
Männlich, weiß, deutsch, was sonst?
Also, wir reden hier wirklich von, also zumindest sieht das vom Titel so aus, von einer, also von einem...
so Bereichsleiter-mäßig,
ja, also,
also quasi eine Stufe
unterm Chef
reden wir hier.
Vice President,
sowas in der Richtung, ja, also ist schon,
schon ordentlich, ja.
So.
Aber fangen wir mal an.
Was soll man sagen?
Business Enterprise Führungskräfte mäßig, ne?
Dabei verbinden sie strategische Steuerung mit operativer Nähe und treiben insbesondere die internationale Einführung von SAP Business One sowie die Digitalisierung und Standardisierung unserer Geschäftsprozesse maßgeblich voran.
Wenn Sie Freude daran haben, IT als zentralen Enabler für effiziente Prozesse zu gestalten, Verantwortung zu übernehmen und die technologische Weiterentwicklung als international aufgestellten Unternehmens aktiv mitzugestalten, freuen wir uns, Sie kennenzulernen.
So, also man würde mal sagen, ey, guck mal hier, Head of IT Europe und okay, 70 Mitarbeiter, ist jetzt nicht der größte Laden, aber scheint ein paar Niederlassungen zu haben, aber jetzt, jetzt kommt's, jetzt, jetzt kommt's.
Okay, noch nicht, aber gleich so, also sie übernehmen Verantwortung für, okay, bla bla bla, pass, pass mal auf.
Führung eines aktuell kleinen, schlagfertigen IT-Teams mit zwei Mitarbeitern.
Head of IT Europe mit zwei Mitarbeitern.
Easy.
wahrscheinlich zweimal Claude Cote, ja, zwei Mitarbeiter, ey, du denkst dir, wunderbar, was jetzt gleich kommt,
und dann kommen zwei Mitarbeiter, nur mal, nur mal, dass ich das richtig verstehe, wenn der Typ dann da ist,
dann sind das drei Leute in der IT, das heißt, die machen mit drei Leuten die gesamte IT für Europa,
Was zum Teufel geht da ab?
Was ist da los?
Für 70 Personen?
Ah ja, je nachdem, was sie machen,
kann da auch viel auf einen zukommen.
So, also.
Gesamtverantwortung für die IT in Europa.
Führung eines aktuellen kleinen, schlagkräftigen IT-Teams mit zwei Mitarbeitern.
Das finde ich krass.
Ja, das sind nur 70.
Okay, die haben nur 70 Mitarbeiter.
Aber trotzdem, je nachdem, was die machen,
fallen auch bei 70...
Ich meine, 70 Mitarbeiter brauchen allein schon
die Arbeitsplätze, die die brauchen.
Je nachdem, was die da machen, ja?
Allein schon die Arbeitsplätze
kriegst du mit zwei Leuten nicht ordentlich gehandelt.
Und by the way, in Deutschland beschäftigen
wir rund 70 Mitarbeiter.
Es geht ja hier um ganz Europa.
Vielleicht sind es ja noch deutlich mehr.
Und gerade mal, was
bei zwei Leuten auch problematisch ist.
Was auch noch problematisch ist.
Was machen die denn, wenn
mal wieder Corona-Welle ist oder sowas?
Da passiert einfach gar nichts.
Das ist einfach viel zu wenig.
Das ist keine funktionierende IT.
Das funzt so nett.
Das funzt mit zwei
Leuten. Ja, vielleicht bei
irgendeiner kleinen Marketing-Klitsche oder so.
Mit zehn Leuten.
Oder bei einem Autohaus
oder sowas. Okay.
Urlaub gibt's auch nicht.
Also,
vielleicht übersehe ich jetzt hier auch irgendwas,
aber das ist schon irgendwie etwas
merkwürdig.
Wo sieht man hier, was die...
Wisst ihr, was aber auch sein kann?
Dass die mit Head of IT Europe einfach viel, viel zu dick auftragen.
Und letztendlich ist es halt ein kleinerer Laden mit einem Standort in Deutschland.
Und sehr viel gebastelt und Turnschuh-Admin-Kram.
Kann auch sein. Aber dann ist Head of IT Europe
maßlos übertrieben vom Titel her.
Weil das klingt eindeutig danach...
Ey, guck mal. Wir haben hier
was weiß ich, in fünf Ländern
Standorte und machen da
was auch immer Zeug, was die
Zusammenarbeit notwendig macht.
Gucken wir mal weiter.
Guck mal, also das fand ich super abgedreht.
So, was als nächstes kommt.
Du musst ja selbst noch mitmachen.
Operative Unterstützung des Teams im Tagesgeschäft sowie strategische Weiterentwicklung der IT.
Also die suchen im Endeffekt einen Teamleiter, der aber normal mitarbeitet.
Der aber trotzdem Head of IT Europe ist.
Mit zwei Mitarbeitern.
Also im Endeffekt brauchen die einen dritten Admin, weil sie mit zwei Leuten nicht hinkommen.
Sie brauchen aber auch einen Teamleiter.
Und der Teamleiter ist halt, wahrscheinlich weil es die gesamte IT des gesamten Unternehmens ist, halt dann Head of IT Europe.
Steuerung des internationalen SAP Business One Rollouts, MonkaS SAP.
Weiterentwicklung von Cloud- und Infrastrukturträgen
Sicherstellung von IT-Sicherheit und Systemstabilität
Enge Zusammenarbeit in den Fachbereichen und internationalen Standorten
Steuerung externer Dienstleister und Projekte
Jetzt mal, das ist ja alles schön und gut, ja
Sagen wir mal realistischer betrachtet, das ist der Teamleiter von der IT
Also er ist der Teamleiter und Admin in einer Person mit zwei Mitarbeitern, okay
Aber wie soll der denn bitte schön sich wirklich um Operativunterstützung und Tagesgeschäft kümmern, wenn er das Zeug hier noch alles machen muss?
Wie soll das funktionieren?
Hat der 18-Stunden-Tage oder was? Oder 36-Stunden-Tage?
Ich meine, immerhin, immerhin muss man sagen, sind sie schon mal bereit, ganz okay zu bezahlen.
Wobei ich vermute, dass es wahrscheinlich eher Richtung 80k als 140k gehen wird.
Ihr Profil.
Stimmt, einfach diagonal skalieren.
Das haben wir hier im Stream gelernt, das ist so.
Warum sollte man auch vertikal und horizontal skalieren, wenn man diagonal skalieren kann?
Das ist halt einfach das High-Performer-Mindset.
Man muss out of the box denken, Leute.
So, ihr Profil.
Mehrjährige Erfahrung im IT-Umfeld mit Führungserfahrung.
Erfahrung in der Führung kleiner Teams oder in einer Schlüsselrolle.
Erfahrung mit ERP-Systemen, idealerweise SAP Business One.
Gute Kenntnisse in Microsoft 365 und IT-Infrastruktur.
strategisches Denken und Hands-on-Mentalität.
Ja, das schreiben sie immer gerne.
Bereitschaft zu gelegentlichen Dienstreisen innerhalb Europas.
By the way, wir reden hier von jemand,
der operative Unterstützung des Teams im Tagesgeschäft machen soll.
Also das sind so Dinger, wie sie...
Das passt irgendwie alles nicht so richtig zusammen.
Entweder ist es einfach maßlos,
massive, zu dick aufgetragen für das, was es ist.
Oder sie suchen einfach doch mehr als eine Person.
Okay, was bieten sie denn?
zusammenarbeit wir gucken gerade mal ich will das jetzt gar nicht verteufeln oder so ich glaube die
stellen also der laden kann super sein das kann man ja immer anhand von stellenanzeigen nicht
erkennen wahrscheinlich vielleicht keine ahnung vielleicht ist der beste aber gebe aber ich kann
sie nur anhand von der stellenanzeige werden ich kenne ja nicht und ich stelle anzeige finde ich
jetzt nicht so überzeugend.
Wir gucken aber mal,
was die bei...
Ähm.
Was gibt's hier?
Wenn man das eingibt, was passiert dann?
Was?
habe ich vertippt, Leute.
P-K-D-C-V-V.
Oder?
Ach so.
Ich dachte, da sieht man noch ein bisschen mehr.
Das ist einfach nur,
wo man seine Bewerbung hinstecken kann.
Ah, was haben die denn sonst noch so zu bieten?
Nur den da.
Okay.
Wir gucken mal kurz,
was da Kununu zu sagt.
Übrigens, Kununu.
Ich habe letztens von denen eine Mail gekriegt.
Ich soll jetzt Kununu Pro oder sowas abschließen.
Da habe ich auch wieder den Kopf gegriffen.
WTF, Leute.
Alle wollen sie mir irgendein dummes Abo verkaufen.
Vor allem dafür.
Was will ich denn?
Okay.
Schauen wir mal.
Okay, die Bewertungen sind jetzt...
Sagen wir mal ganz okay.
Weil hauptsächlich, und das darf man ja immer nicht unterschätzen, hier bewerten ja hauptsächlich Leute, die abgefuckt sind.
Ach, du hast das auf Twitter geschickt? Ja, das war eine gute Stellenanzeige.
Okay, wo kann man hier? Hier, Bewertung. Können wir mal gucken.
mehr schein als sein gut klingende worte aber die realität ist eine andere gut
das also also gefühlt wie bei fast jedem zweiten unternehmen
schlechter arbeitgeber also gutes home office und spannendes umfeld schlechtes fatale
hierarchie strukturen naja gut die haben ja auch noch kein head of it europe da kann ja
nichts funktioniert ohne große empathie und wenig gehör schwache führungskräfte
ja wie gesagt der head of it europe fehlt ja noch so viel kontrolle bei
wenig kompetenz und fehlende emotionale intelligenz
es wird von respekt in meetings geredet aber der kleine arbeiter mit nicht
gewürdigt für vorschläge wird überhört leere worte
oft keine konkreten aussagen und vorschlägen wundert sich wenig wie die
mit einer Erdgut. Atmosphäre.
Sehr viel Verärgerung und
Unmut. Image.
Sieht das nicht so geil aus.
Eine nicht authentische Bewertung.
Tja.
Also
Durchwachsen, sagen wir mal, durchwachsen
Gibt aber auch genug
Na gut, da sind ja schon zwei Jahre dazwischen
Also eher durchwachsen
Würde ich mal sagen
So
Jetzt haben wir uns die zwei
Premium-Stellenanzeigen für heute angeguckt
Jetzt schauen wir uns mal die
An, die ich das letzte Mal
Nicht gepackt habe
Wo habe ich mir die denn gespeichert?
Hier irgendwo?
Ja, exzellent
Ja
Also Chat, achso, Moment, Moment
wollen wir machen jetzt erst mal dass wir das heute abgeschlossen
abgeschlossen bekommen irgendjemand gemeint der hier gestalter für im
immersive mit dazu kann ich nichts sagen außer dass es so eine ziemlich 08 15
image ist finde ich diese dinge sehen aus wie auf ganz vielen webseiten habe
ich die gefühle gesehen aber dazu kann ich dazu kann ich gar nichts sagen
wirklich nett aber sehr umfangreiche stellenanzeige
Vielleicht haben in deren IT-Abteilung auch schon der Großteil gekündigt, deswegen sind es nur noch zwei Leute.
Das kann sein.
Möglich, möglich.
Also Chat, wenn ihr noch irgendwas habt,
wo wir uns zusammen angucken wollen,
dann schreibt es einfach in den Chat.
Natürlich bevorzugt irgendwas,
wo ich auch sinnvoll was zu sagen kann.
Ja, zu Mediengestalter kann ich einfach nichts sagen.
hier nochmal ganze abteilung okay
chat moment muss chat arena und auch starten dass ich hier den chat haben
Das da und das da.
Ah ne Moment, jetzt habe ich den Falschraum angeklickt.
Und wir brauchen unbedingt Dark Reader.
Okay, excellent.
Viel besser gleich.
Okay, hier nochmal
ganze IT-Abteilung in einem.
Ein IT-Systemadministrator.
Bei wem?
Äh.
Wo ist die Firma?
Ach da.
Dömer GmbH. An der Karlshütte.
Hab ich noch nie gehört.
Du warst der...
War ich beim alten Arbeitgeber.
Jetzt bin ich...
War ich Linux-Engineer.
Und jetzt bin ich
Site-Reliability-Engineer.
Warum? Weiß ich nicht.
Weil es besser klingt.
Weil die sich gedacht haben,
Senior Linux-Engineer ist zu outdated,
overrated, cheap-baited.
Das müssen jetzt Side-Reliability-Engineers sein.
Ja, wahrscheinlich, weil das gerade im Trend ist und fancy klingt.
Geändert hat sich an meinem Job absolut gar nichts.
Gleiches Team, gleicher Job.
Kein Unterschied.
Spickel. Ne, Spickel. Sorry. Spickel. Moin.
Also, was haben wir denn hier?
Als führendes und... Das schreibt doch gefühlt auch jeder in seine Stellenanzeigen, oder?
Als Marktführer im Bereich XY.
Wir sind führend in so und so.
Als führendes Unternehmen.
Führend im Bereich irgendwas.
Das schreiben sie alle irgendwie rein.
Laut Vertrag bist du IT-Mobility-Support.
Was ist denn Mobility-Support?
Ich würde mir hier sowas darunter vorstellen,
wie Rollstühle schieben,
aber was hat das mit IT zu tun?
Laut Chat-GPT bist du aber
IT-Operation-Specialist.
Ach, ist doch wurscht, wie das heißt.
Übrigens, Chat.
Bam, sehr laut.
Wundert mich, dass es nicht automatisch eingeblendet wurde
Hätte eigentlich noch eine halbe Stunde automatisch
Oder war das mittlerweile schon mal wieder zu sehen?
Weil ich hab das eigentlich alles richtig eingestellt
Vorhin kam es nochmal
Ah ja, gut, dann ist ja gut
Wenn es vorhin schon mal gekommen ist, dann ist ja alles gut
Ja Leute, wenn ihr noch günstig im Storage sucht
Ausrufezeichen, Ukraine, Ausrufezeichen, Alternate, Ausrufezeichen
Sie geht im Chat und ein Link anklicken
Denn die Preise gelten nur über meinen Link.
Mit Mobility ist Handy-Tablet gemeint.
Also sowas wie Mobile Device Management oder sowas.
Sowas die coolen Leute MDM abkürzen.
Okay, dann lassen wir uns das mal durchlesen.
Also.
Als Führer...
Okay, das lesen wir uns jetzt nicht durch.
Das ist typische Selbstbeweihräucherung.
Hochwertige Verbindungs-, Beschlags- und Sicherheitskomponenten.
Blablabla.
Sie sind 85 qualifizierte Mitarbeiter.
Haben die denn auch einen Head of IT Europe?
Wie viele Mitarbeiter ist bei euch ein ITler zuständig?
Im Maschinenbau baden wir uns,
da steht etwas über 50.
Keine Ahnung, weiß ich nicht.
Ich habe mit Endusern, PCs und Arbeitsplätzen
und sowas absolut gar nichts zu tun.
Keine Ahnung.
Ich hatte letztens so einen Austauschtermin,
da waren ein paar Leute von unserem Support
und von der Hotline.
Aber ich habe keine Ahnung, wie viele das jetzt
insgesamt sind und wie viele da auf
einen Mitarbeiter...
Ich habe keine Ahnung.
Keine Ahnung.
Aber bei uns ist halt sehr viel automatisch.
Software-Verteilung läuft automatisch.
Wenn die Probleme haben, können sie eine
Hotline anrufen, zentral.
Keine Ahnung. Ich habe wirklich
keinen Schimmer.
Wie viele
so kleinen Support-Leute, die wir pro Mitarbeiter haben.
Kein Schimmer.
Das Wir steht im Mittelpunkt.
Leidenschaft, Verlässlichkeit, Respekt und Nachhaltigkeit
sind die Werte, die für uns...
Wundert mich, dass nicht noch Diversity oder sowas drinsteht.
Das haben sie doch heute auch einfach so für...
Ich muss sagen, zum Zeigen, dass sie modern sind, die für uns täglich zählen dabei sind,
Kundenorientierung, höchste Qualität und Kosteneffizienz immer im Fokus.
Alles klar.
Verstärken Sie unser Team als IT-Systemadministrator.
Aber trotzdem, ne, wieder männlich-weiß-deutsch.
Ist gerade was, was soll.
Also, was wollen die denn haben?
Administration der IT-Infrastruktur
Ja, Moment mal
Das ist jetzt, also
Wie breit möchte man bitte schön einen Job
Einen Job
Bewerben, ja
Administration der IT-Infrastruktur
Das ist einfach alles und nichts
Das ist alles
IT-Infrastruktur ist alles
Vom Telefon bis zum
Faxgerät, bis zum Desktop-Rechner
Bis zum Server im Rechner
bis der telefonanlage switch router video konferenzsysteme alles overhead projektoren
first and second level support okay dass das schon das ist schon abfakt also fast
leistet das ist schon da hört auf aber administration der it infrage das ist
wirklich so zu bäumen alles einfach administration von windows server windows
clients das ist auch wieder super breit gewählt
aber zum glück steht nicht nur linux dabei administration von active directory
dns dhcp gpu leute ich kenne mich zwar mit active directory ist nicht aus den
Group Policies, oder?
So nach dem Motto,
dieser Registry Key soll gesetzt sein
bei diesem User.
Exchange.
Datensicherung.
Administration,
Aufbau, Erweiterung der Datenbanken,
Datenbankserver. Virtualisierung
mit VMware.
Projektarbeit.
Ticketsystem.
Isms.
T-Sax.
Die tun immer so, als weiß sofort jeder, was das ist.
Ah ja, alles klar.
Und ist es?
Information Security Management System.
Aha.
Entwicklung interner Software.
Ja, Alter, ist ja gut.
Übertreibt es mal wieder.
Patchmanagement von Windows.
EDI. Was ist EDI?
EDI?
EDI Management.
Was ist EDI Management?
Eierlegende Vollmacht.
Electronic Data Interchange.
Verwaltung, Beschaffung, Implementierung von IT-Komponenten und Lizenzen.
Optimierung der...
Ah, das ist auch noch. Ja, klar.
Zusammenarbeit. Firewall.
So steht random einfach nochmal unten drunter.
Label und Etikettenmanagement.
Moment.
Moment, Leute.
Leute, jetzt mal ganz langsam.
Jetzt bremst ihr euch mal ein bisschen.
Also es fehlt ja eigentlich jetzt nur noch Linux dabei.
Dann hast du mal wieder komplett alles, was in der IT so anfällt, bei einem Typ abgeladen.
Du kümmerst dich um das Lager, genau.
Also du kümmerst dich um die gesamte IT-Infrastruktur.
machst First- und Second-Level-Support,
kümmerst dich um alle Windows-Server
und Windows-Clients, machst nebenbei noch Active Directory,
DNS, DHCP,
gut, das könnte man alles so unter
Windows-Administration ziehen. Exchange-Server,
ohne Scheiß, alleine schon Exchange-Server
ist ein Job für sich.
Das ist super krasser Abfuck.
Weil wer hätte das gedacht, ne?
Mails, Sachen von Microsoft,
natürlich ist das ein krasser Abfuck.
das ist keine firma mit das ist keine firma mit zehn leuten das ist eine firma
mit 85 leuten also haben nicht nur zwei desktop rechner und einer der alles
macht
dann machst kümmerst dich um backup restore
den fehlt eindeutig der head of europe
administration auf meiner weiteren datenbank was du noch virtualisierung mit vmware das ist
halt schon sehr so sehr viel durcheinander also was ich mir gefallen lassen würde ja was ich
mir gefallen lassen würde ist dass du sagst okay du brauchst halt wenn die eine kleine
it abteilung haben ja so viele werden die sicherlich nicht haben was ich mir gefallen
lassen würde ist dass du sagst okay was das jetzt zusammen ja okay das hier vielleicht auch das
budget microsoft sql gedönst ja also kümmerst dich du kümmerst dich um windows gedönst klein
active directory exchange guckst dass es backups gibt und kürzer sich um sql daten ich denke mal
das ist an sich schon noch okay das ist zwar extrem breit geschrieben hier dann auch noch
first level support aber wenn es eine kleine abteilung ist da macht jeder irgendwo alles
ein bisschen. Das heißt ja nicht,
dass jeder alles in der Tiefe kann. Das nächste
muss man mal sagen, Virtualisierung
mit VMware, das ist eine Wissenschaft
für sich.
Also die letzten
drei Unternehmen, bei denen ich war, also ich zähle
jetzt mal ein aktuelles mit, ja.
Also wohlgemerkt, die letzten drei und auch die
drei einzigen, bei denen ich war,
da gab es immer ein komplett eigenes
Team sogar für VMware.
Das wird natürlich mit einer kleinen IT-Abteilung schwierig,
aber das alles dann auch
noch zu checken, ist gar nicht so einfach.
Also VMware selbst ist auch ein Fass ohne Boden.
Dass du dann nebenbei noch irgendwie bei Projekten mitmachen sollst, naja.
Und das hier, finde ich, passt halt überhaupt nicht dazu.
Entwicklung interner Softwareanwendungen.
Ich mache das auch.
Ich bastel auch ganz gern bei uns auf der Arbeit irgendwelche Tools und Automatisierung.
In letzter Zeit hauptsächlich in Go.
Das mache ich auch.
Aber ich würde trotzdem nicht sagen, dass das Bestandteil von dem Job in der Bewerbung oder beziehungsweise der Stellenanzeige sein sollte.
Ja, hätten die hier Scripting-Automatisierung geschrieben, wäre ich ja noch mitgegangen.
Aber hier soll ja wohl wirklich an Business-Anwendungen, die für die wichtig sind, mitentwickelt werden.
Da weiß ich nicht, das gehört da eigentlich nicht rein.
patch management für windows das passt die management habe ich keine ahnung was es ist
optimierung der it prozesse zusammen ein firewall das ist auch so ein thema wo man
sich darüber streiten kann ob das nicht auch ein eigener job ist wobei ich da halt denke
so viel wird es wahrscheinlich nicht sein und am ende kommt dann noch ganz random dazu label
und Etikettenmanagement.
Bam.
Also das ist wahrscheinlich so ein Fünfer-Team,
wo jeder
alles macht.
Und dementsprechend
war der Chat gar nicht so verkehrt
mit
hier wird eine ganze IT-Abteilung gesucht.
Wird es im Endeffekt auch.
Es wird eine ganze IT-Abteilung gesucht.
Einer, der an allem rumbasteln kann.
Wer soll die Stellenanzeigen erstellen?
Die Personalabteilung wahrscheinlich.
Die Personalabteilung sagt, ey, was braucht ihr denn?
Dann kriegen die ein paar Stichworte und bauen eine Stellenanzeige raus zusammen.
Da kommt dann halt sowas bei raus.
Timchoo, Dankeschön für den Sub.
Pog Subscription.
Und der Linux Magician hat auch subscribt.
Schon ein bisschen her, habe ich aber noch gar nicht gesehen bis jetzt.
Pog.
Aber selbst dann schreckt sowas doch eher ab.
Ja.
Ja, ja.
Das schreckt.
Also ich kann es mir nicht vorstellen, dass es jemand anspricht.
Sagen wir mal so.
Ich würde auch sagen, es schreckt eher ab.
Okay, E-Profil.
Eine geschlossene Ausbildung.
Gerne vertiefende Bereichprogrammierung.
VBA.
Ninox.
Was ist das?
Was ist Linux?
AI-Native-Plattform
for Business Teams.
Nee, oder? Das meinen die nicht.
Programming Language.
Die Musik ist ein bisschen laut, oder?
Nee, die Musik geht eigentlich klar.
Ich mach mal eins leiser.
introduction to ninox script was soll denn das sein das habe ich ja noch nie gehört low code
language
Geil.
Okay.
Kein Schimmer.
Was ist das?
Irgendeine Low-Code, No-Code-Plattform?
Ja.
Okay.
Hab ich noch nie gehört.
Hat ein bisschen was von Bash.
Oder von Ruby.
Ne, ich finde, Python-Ribes hat es überhaupt nicht.
Ah ja, gut.
ninox keine ahnung gehört gerne software kenntnissen abas tisowear babtec und ninox
alles auch noch nie gehört heißt aber nichts ich bin ja auch nicht in dieser branche aktiv
verantwortungsbewusstsein sorgfältig arbeitsweise der möglichkeit erfahrungen softwareprojekten
technisches verständnis unser angebot wie viel geld gibt es denn steht das auch dabei
eine motivierende arbeitsatmosphäre eine fundierte und zielorientierte einarbeitung
ja ich verstehe dass das also ich verstehe dass sie denken dass das ein gutes also das steht ja
bei vielen bei vielen stellanzeigen drin und ich verstehe dass sie denken dass es ein guter
Pluspunkt ist und irgendwie
ist es auch ein Pluspunkt, aber ich bin ja der Meinung,
dass eine fundierte und zielorientierte
Ordnung, also eine ordentliche
Einarbeitung, ja, sollte
so im ureigensten Interesse
des Arbeitgebers
liegen, dass
die Leute, für die er bezahlt, auch
ordentlich was schaffen können.
Eine tariflich geregelte Vergütung inklusive Sonderzahlung.
Ja, wie wäre es denn dann mal mit Tarifstufe und welchem Tarifvertrag?
Ein langfristig sicherer Firmen-Events, Corporate-Bank, Bike-Leasing, E-Ladestation, Bezuschussungs-Fitnessstudio.
Also, ganz ehrlich, es könnte durchaus sein, dass das wieder die geilste Firma überhaupt ist.
Wir wissen es ja letztendlich nicht.
Und eine schlechte Stellenanzeige, oder was heißt das?
Das ist ja noch nicht mal eine richtig schlechte Stellenanzeige.
Eine Stellenanzeige, die jetzt vielleicht nicht so direkt Bock macht, sich da zu bewerben,
heißt jetzt ja nicht automatisch, dass die Firma schlecht ist.
Wir können allerdings nur nach der Stellenanzeige gehen.
Und das ist halt wieder so eines dieser typischen, wir suchen eine gesamte IT-Abteilung.
Was bei denen vielleicht durchaus Sinn macht, weil es halt, keine Ahnung, fünf Leute sind in der IT.
Trotzdem ist das aus meiner Sicht zu bunt durcheinandergewürfelt, die Aufgaben.
Da ist Netzwerk, Virtualisierung und Windows und Windows Client und Mail und alles.
Also wieder die ersten Dinge würde ich mir noch gefallen lassen.
Zusammen, plus hier vielleicht die Sachen hier unten und sowas.
Aber spätestens bei Softwareentwicklung, interner Softwareanwendung, da wäre ich jetzt an der Stelle mal raus.
weil es ja wohl nicht um automatisierung in welches verskripten geht von windows
sachen sondern wirklich um das mit entwickeln in den ihrer business
anwendungen das sollte nicht wirklich da bestandteil von sein
es könnte natürlich auch sein dass sie in wirklichkeit drei verschiedene leute
suchen und das alles in einem machen das wäre aber sehr weird champ
Was bringt einem denn eine motivierende Arbeitsatmosphäre?
Ja, da haben sie irgendeine Phrase wieder rausgehauen.
Die feuern dich an.
Ja, das wär's doch.
Du kriegst quasi einmal am Tag,
müssen alle wie bei Walmart auf so ein Motivationsmeeting
und dann wird eine Runde zusammen geklatscht.
Das ist bestimmt krasse Motivation.
Motivationsschub.
Jobvektor.
Ja, wir akzeptieren das alles.
Okay, dann kommen wir mal
das nächste an.
IT-System-Engineer.
IT-System-Administrator.
Mit dir gemeinsam
die Zukunft bewegen.
Aha.
Bei
Ecotel Cloud und Fiber.
Aha, aha.
Du bringst Praxiserfahrung in der Administration von Windows- und oder Linux-Servern sowie virtuellen Maschinen mit.
Naja, nachdem in virtuellen Maschinen meistens Linux und oder Windows läuft...
Aber das ist ja schon mal passend, ja?
Ich hoffe, sie wollen keinen, der Windows und Linux zusammen macht, weil das ist oftmals in Kombinationen selten.
Selten.
Aber, Chat, wie seht ihr das?
Also meiner Erfahrung nach gibt es gefühlt mehr Windows-Admins, die sich auch gerne mit Linux beschäftigen, weil Linux einfach nice ist, als umgedreht.
Also es gibt mehr Windows-Admins, die sich auch gerne in ihrer Freizeit mal mit Linux beschäftigen, als Linux-Admins, die sich auch gerne mal nebenbei mit Windows-Servern beschäftigen.
Das mag aber vielleicht einfach daran liegen, dass Linux für Server das deutlich bessere System ist.
Und warum soll ich mich mit Windows-Servern beschäftigen, wenn ich mich schon mit Linux-Servern beschäftigt habe?
Im Laufe deiner Berufsbahn
konntest du dir profunde Kenntnisse
im Netzwerkbereich aneignen.
Okay.
Kommt noch dabei.
Ja, weil Windows
genutzt werden muss, aber Linux genutzt werden will.
Ja, ich glaube, das trifft es ganz gut.
The Nell schreibt,
also ich bin Physiensucher aktuell aus Gründen,
Arbeit und ich habe über 20 Jahre
Windows-Erfahrung nutze seit drei Jahren Linux, dann würde ich
das so nicht ausschließen, aber für
den Host-Server...
Was? Für den Host-Server
ist Windows eigentlich heute keine valide
Option für den Host-Server?
Du meinst kein IBM
Mainframe, oder?
Hehehe.
Ja, ist es.
Okay, gucken wir mal weiter.
Also.
Ein bisschen Netzwerk,
ein bisschen Netzwerk spricht da überhaupt nichts
dagegen bei einem Server-Admin oder bei einem
System-Administrator.
Netzwerksachen kenne ich mich ja auch
ganz brauchbar aus aber was ich halt nicht kann sind die ganzen enterprise netzwerk sachen also
ich kann mich da mit ein bisschen bisschen googeln kann ich so basic sachen auf dem cisco switch auch
konfigurieren ja ich kann portoren runterfahren ich kann wieder ans anlegen und so was ich krieg
wahrscheinlich über das ist gut dingen auch noch uspf oder sowas eingerichtet ein bisschen ein
bisschen googeln dabei aber ich kann das nicht aus dem ff sowie die ganzen netzwerke bei uns
Aber so wie ich halt Linux Command Line kann, können die halt Cisco Command Line und was gibt es da sonst noch? Palo Alto und hast du nicht gesehen.
Zockst du auch auf dem Linux?
Ne, das ist ein Mini-PC
Hier, guck mal
Das ist ein Mini-PC
Mit
8 CPU-Kernen
Das ist 16, das ist mit Hyper-Threading
8 CPU-Kerne, 8 GIG-RAM
Und
Einen ganz guten CPU
Aber halt nur
einer integrated graphics also da spiele ich nichts drauf
die erstellung und pflege von skripten beziehungsweise prozessen in daten
sicherungssystem sind für dich kein neuland
ja gut also automatisierungs skriptor und so ist da würde ich sagen schon
standard sollte man ein bisschen von ahnung haben wobei es da wahrscheinlich bei denen auch also
vermute ich jetzt einfach mal so in richtung ansible und vielleicht terraform geht je nachdem
was die da genau für infrastruktur haben also jetzt riesen berge von manuellen dash skripten
vielleicht nicht mehr ganz zeitgemäß wobei manche da kommst du auch nicht drum herum ja aber für
server konfiguration größten ganzen ist eigentlich so das was ich mittlerweile durchgesetzt hat
gemeinsam mit deinem team stellst du unseren reibungslosen rechenzentrums betriebssicher
aha sondern auch ein bisschen turnschuhe admin dabei ja aber passt also bis jetzt passt das alles
alles nur windows und linux zusammen weiß ich nicht ob die das auch wirklich wollen ok
moment das ist dazu bist du
ach so ach so das ist einfach ein bisschen komisch geschrieben im anschluss an eine
ausbildung im it-bereich bzw studium bereich informationstechnik konntest du bereits erste
erfahrung in den umgang bereichen sammeln aktiv konntest du dir das gewünschte berufserfahrung
aneignen job okay gute kenntnisse deutsch du arbeitslos organisiert behältst auch komplexe
projekte und vorgänge entsteht ein kühlen kopf die offenheit für neue technologien grunde dein
profil ab okay dudes kultur auf allen ebenen wertschätzung statt wort hülsen eine offen oder
nehmen das konto flache hier schreibend wie alle beschreiben wir alle und echte zusammenarbeit sind
bei uns nicht nur buzzwords sondern tägliche realität flexibilität die zu deinem leben passt
vertrauens arbeitszeit home office oder flexible arbeitszeiten du stimmst dich einfach innovator
mit einem team ab pakete lieber ins büro kein problem wir bieten dir einen eigenen paket service
für deine private online bestellung okay das ist tatsächlich ganz cool du hast ideen immer her
damit kreativ in eigeninitiative feiern gehört bei uns dazu monka es karnevalsommer fest oder
Wir feiern gemeinsam und gerne.
Das ist für mich kein Pluspunkt.
Ich mache immer einen großen Bogen um solche Feiern.
Aber für Leute, die das mögen,
ist das ja schön.
Chat, ist sowas für euch
eher ein Pluspunkt oder ein Minuspunkt?
So Firmen-Events und sowas.
Plus oder Minus?
Neutral ist auch okay.
Ah, das war ich gar nicht jetzt.
Das kommt zufällig gerade, während ich
U-Mail geswitcht habe.
Chatgear, günstiger Storage, nur über
meinen Link.
Und Ukraine-Nassus.
Günstiger Storage und Ukraine-Nassus.
gibt es bei dir auch günstige klimaanlagen das wäre geil wenn es auch günstige klimaanlagen
gebe zum glück habe ich mir vor paar jahren klimaanlage einbauen lassen ich bin da sehr
happy drüber erstens war damals noch alles nicht so ultra teuer und jetzt die klimaanlage zu haben
ist halt auch sehr prog grüße aus dem krankenhaus krankenhaus
das hast du gemacht
so viel face rollt über die tastatur zu viel windows administration
Was war dein Einstiegsgehalt damals und welchen Job hast du gemacht?
Ja gut, 2007.
Ähm, die Ausbildung.
Und danach habe ich angefangen.
Für 33.500 im Jahr.
Als?
Top Server Admin war das damals auch noch.
Aber das war schon eine Weile her.
Wir haben das letztens mal ausgerechnet mit Inflations und allem.
Ich glaube mittlerweile ist quasi, um auf mein Einstiegsgehalt von damals zu kommen, muss man glaube ich 45k verdienen.
Oder 48k oder ich glaube 48k.
Sonntag, oh.
Sergeant Silver hat einen Unfall mit einem E-Scooter Kniescheibe gebrochen.
Ah, das ist aber eklig.
Dann hoffen wir mal, dass das schnell wieder heilt
Und die deine Kniescheibe
Ordentlich gefixt kriegen
Katze offiziell sagt
Unter 3,2k brutto kein Einstellungsrechnung
Das machen wir auch
3x12
Boah, das ist aber echt auch schon wenig
Ja, mal 14 ist okay.
Also 38k
kommst du halt heute echt auch nicht weit mit.
Mehr für dich
trainieren Mitarbeiterangebote, gute
Anbindungen, kostenlose Parkplätze.
Das finde ich gut.
wir reden von nach der ausbildung ja ich habe das nur mit meinem einstiegsgehalt
damals verglichen 33 33 1500 euro im jahr direkt nach der ausbildung aber wie gesagt
schon 20 jahre her was waren für dich die größten gehaltssprünge jobwechsel oder auch
interne positionswechsel jobwechsel
aber was auch geholfen hat ist regelmäßig seinem chef auf den keks zu
gehen dass man mehr geld will weil realistisch betrachtet ist es ja so
wenn ihr jeden wenn ihr jedes jahr mehrfach fragt ja und auch immer erzählt
was ihr für tolle Sachen macht, dann kann euch euer Chef ab und zu mal immer ein paar Prozente mehr geben.
Das wird deutlich einfacher durchzusetzen und auch von eurem Chef quasi sich abnicken zu lassen,
als wenn ihr, sagen wir mal, fünf Jahre nicht gefragt habt oder zehn Jahre nicht gefragt habt
und dann einen hohen zweistelligen Betrag, also hohe zweistellige Prozent mehr wollt.
Das kommt dann so in einem Strich aufs Gleiche raus.
Aber dann sagen sie wieder,
der Typ will 25, 30% mehr.
Nee, das gibt's nicht.
Wenn ihr allerdings das laufend macht
und ihr immer mal wieder ein paar Prozent kriegt,
habt ihr das vielleicht auch nach 10 Jahren.
Aber es ist einfacher durchzuwinken.
Jährliche Mitarbeitergespräche
und dann die Erfolge vorbereiten.
Nee, ich würde gar nicht
auf die
auf die Mitarbeitergespräche warten,
ich würde regelmäßig deinem Chef aufs Auge drücken,
was du für geile Sachen machst.
Und beim Mitarbeitergespräch ruhig,
kannst du das ja auch nochmal alles aufwärmen.
Aber du musst bei deinem Chef regelmäßig erzählen,
was du für geile Sachen machst.
Und wenn du die Möglichkeit hast,
auch über dein Team und deinen Chef hinaus,
erzählen, was du für geile Sachen machst.
Also wenn es bei euch beispielsweise irgendwelche Abteilungsrunden gibt
oder irgendwelche übergreifende Abstimmungsrunden oder sowas.
Geh da hin, lass dir einen Zeitslot von einer Viertelstunde reservieren
und lobpreise dich selbst ein bisschen.
Aber ohne, dass es so wirkt, als würdest du dich selbst lobpreisen.
Kannst dann beispielsweise darüber berichten,
was du in dem Projekt für tolle Sachen gemacht hast
und wie das ganze Unternehmen weit benutzt werden könnte
und das super Arbeitserleichterung ist, bla bla bla.
Aber so, dass das alle mitkriegen, weil wenn das alle mitkriegen, dann kriegt es auch der Chef von deinem Chef mit.
Und wenn dann dein Chef zu dem geht und sagt, hier, der finden will mehr Geld haben, dann hat er schon mal gehört, dass es dich gibt und was du so machst.
Und dann ist das viel einfacher. Man glaubt das gar nicht, ja.
Also alleine, dass man gute Arbeit macht, reicht nicht dafür aus, gut Geld damit zu verdienen.
So doof das klingt und so kacke ich das persönlich auch finde, ja, reicht das nicht.
Es ist besser, du machst weniger gute Arbeit, also nee, das muss ich anders formulieren,
also du machst nicht so viel, du machst nicht so viel gute Arbeit und benutzt einen Teil der Zeit,
dafür Werbung zu machen für das, was du gemacht hast.
Also wenn du die Auswahl hast zwischen, du powerst 100% durch und machst immer geile Sachen,
versus du machst 50% geile Sachen und 50% trittst du das ein bisschen breit,
dass du geile Sachen gemacht hast,
dann wird dir das am Ende gehaltstechnisch mehr bringen, als 100% durchzupauen.
Das ist leider so.
Du musst immer ein bisschen Werbung für deinen Kram machen.
Und das geht ja auch.
Guck mal, du findest doch immer irgendwas.
Ja, zum Beispiel, also was die ganz toll finden ist, wenn du irgendwas hast, was man theoretisch auch in anderen Bereichen in dem Unternehmen verwenden könnte.
Ich nehme das immer als Beispiel, weil das das letzte Mal das Thema gewesen ist, wo ich ein bisschen hier größere Runde mit gedreht habe.
ich habe für eine unserer Anwendungen, die in dem
Kubernetes Cluster läuft, habe ich in Go
einen
Prometheus Exporter programmiert
der lokal
dort vom Pod über die API
Sachen abgreift und als Metriken
bereitstellt
der macht dann sowas wie
wie lang ist
die Zeit zwischen zwei Blöcken, wie viel Transaktionen
war in einem Block, welche
Block ID, wie alt ist der letzte Block
und solche Geschichten, also es geht hier
und Blockchain-Software. Und das
fragt er ab. Das bietet die Software selbst
nämlich nicht an. Und das
collecten wir bei Google mit dem
Google Managed Prometheus und dann haben wir ein schönes
Dashboard, wo das alles drin ist.
So. Und das habe ich auf
einem unserer Abteilungsversammlungen, das ist jetzt aber
auch schon wieder ein Jahr her,
eineinhalb Jahre her,
habe ich das bei uns auf der
Abteilungsversammlung
20 Minuten
vorgestellt. Und halt auch so,
dass man das ja auch bei
vielen anderen Projekten verwenden kann, wenn die
Software das selbst nicht anbietet.
Dass solche Custom-Exporter ganz toll sind
und sowieso.
Und dann habe ich das halt ein bisschen breit getreten.
Das muss man manchmal machen.
Und du wirst
immer irgendwas finden,
was du Tolles gemacht hast.
Und ich sage regelmäßig,
ich habe regelmäßig Rücksprache mit meinem Chef,
der kriegt regelmäßig erzählt,
was ich Tolles
gemacht habe oder was ich für toll
halte und was auch gut ist wenn du leuten hilfst auf der arbeit
Sofern ihr das nicht so blöd ist aber falls du leuten hilfst auf der arbeit zum beispiel irgendeinem entwickler ja
letztens letztens hatten wir es zum beispiel wir hatten entwickler bei uns der benutzt
mirrored kennt das jemand von euch zufällig
mirrored oder mirrored muss man da wahrscheinlich sagen
das ist eine software die kammer in den kubanä das cluster installieren und das baut so eine
art tunnel auf da können entwickler quasi von ich zeige euch das mal die webseite ist aber
kackes nicht mehr die mir und die hier so wie mir die google suche was neu wieder los
Hier RAW?
The fuck?
Google-Suche!
Hier, das da. Da ist es doch.
Mein Auge, Alter!
Monk HS!
Die haben natürlich überhaupt kein Bild
oder sowas in der Richtung. Also das ist eine Software,
die kannst du in deinem Kubernetes-Cluster installieren
und das baut dann so eine Art Tunnel auf.
Da kann dann quasi ein Entwickler von seinem Entwicklungs-Desktop
auf Services im Kubernetes-Cluster relativ easy zugreifen,
ohne dass der sich selbst großartig mit Port-Weiterleitungen,
SSH, CubeCTL, Tunnel und sonst was beschäftigen muss.
Das ist eigentlich ganz nice.
Und das ging letztens nicht.
Und irgendwie hat es keinen interessiert, dass der Entwickler nicht entwickeln konnte und ihm hat keiner geholfen.
Also habe ich mir gedacht, weißt du was, hilfst du ihm mal.
Letztendlich lag es da dran, dass MirrorD nicht gestartet ist, weil...
Äh, warte mal, lass mal in mich gehen, was war das? Irgendwas mit IP-Tables war das.
Genau, weil man die IP-Tables-Usage in der MirrorD-Config auf Legacy stellen musste.
Ja.
Port Forward ist auch mit Cube CTL easy.
Ich weiß auch nicht, warum sie das unbedingt haben wollen.
Wahrscheinlich kann das noch ein bisschen mehr.
Fragt mich nicht. Ich habe das selbst noch nicht verwendet.
Aber unsere Entwickler haben das sogar gekauft und finden das ganz toll.
Guck hier, das tunnelt irgendwie sowas.
So, und da habe ich das gefixt und der Entwickler war mega happy.
Und das ist dann ein guter Zeitpunkt zu sagen, ey, weißt du was?
Wenn dich das so freut, ich helfe dir ja gerne, aber falls du bei meinem Chef über den Weg läufst, kannst du ihm ruhig sagen, wie toll du das alles findest.
Wenn dir das nicht zu blöd ist.
Das hat schon mal dazu geführt, dass Leute tatsächlich an meinen Chef eine E-Mail geschrieben haben
und haben sich für die tolle Unterstützung bedankt.
Ja, das ist erstmal innerlich so ein bisschen cringe, weil Selbstlob.
Aber ganz ehrlich, letztendlich ist das, was dir was bringt.
Ja, also 50% geile Sachen machen und 50% irgendwie Werbung dafür machen, bringt dir einfach mehr.
Was?
Chico als Easter Egg irgendwo reinzumachen?
Du meinst, du meinst
in einem Kommandozeilentool
auf der Arbeit oder so, dass
Chico als Ascii-Art reinkommt?
Eigentlich eine gute Idee.
Achso, und eine Sache, die auch nicht karriereförderlich ist, wo wir gerade dabei sind, die viele Techniker gerne machen, ich auch, und das ist meckern.
Also ein bisschen meckern ist nicht verkehrt und wenn was kacke ist, zu sagen, dass du es kacke findest und du denkst, das ist nicht der richtige Weg, ist auch okay.
Aber es hat keinen Sinn, wenn sich irgendjemand sagt, okay, machen wir mal ein aktuelles Beispiel.
Gehen wir mal von aus...
Okay.
Gehen wir mal von aus, irgendjemand, der Chef von deinem Chef, hat Besuch bekommen von einem Red Hat Marketing Mensch.
und
der Red Hat Marketing Mensch
hat ihn überzeugt davon,
dass er jetzt unbedingt
Red Hat einsetzen will.
Aktuell habt ihr Debian.
So.
Dann kommt dann, dann geht der Chef
zu deinem Chef, der Chef von deinem Chef
geht zu deinem Chef und sagt, ey,
weißt du was,
sorg mal dafür, dass wir
unsere Server umstellen
auf Red Hat.
Dann sagst du, Alter, was ein Kack.
Warum Red Hat?
Warum sollen wir unnötig viel Geld bezahlen?
Unsere Automatisierung ist auf Debian
zugeschnitten. Debian läuft, Stable ist
überhaupt kein Problem. Es ist rausgeschmissenes Geld.
Sagst du dann?
Sagst vielleicht noch
deine Bedenkungen. Das braucht
seine Bedenken. Neuen Entwicklungsaufwand
für Ansible Playbooks, neues hier, neues
da und bla und neue Softwareverteilungen.
Neue Deploymentsachen.
die man dafür vielleicht braucht, neue Paketierungszeug, neue Serveraufbausysteme.
Sagst du alles deinem Chef?
Dein Chef ist ein guter Chef und gibt es sogar weiter, sagt hier.
Das bedeutet die und die Aufwände.
Und dann sagt der Chef von deinem Chef, das ist egal, Red Hat beste, ich will das trotzdem.
So, und jetzt hast du die Möglichkeit zu sagen,
ich werde bei jedem Meeting 500 Mal sagen, wie scheiße Red Hat ist
und wie geil Demian ist und alles ist kacke und was soll das Scheiß und was soll das?
oder du sagst, jawohl, Red Hat Umstellung, wir sind voll dabei und sorgen dafür, dass das reibungslos läuft.
Das bringt dir letztendlich mehr.
Du kannst meckern, aber es bringt nichts, wenn du die ganze Zeit über Sachen, die schon entschieden sind, weiter meckerst.
Es ist okay zu sagen, ich finde das blöd aus den und den Gründen,
Aber wenn dann jemand sagt, nee, wir wollen das trotzdem, dann ist es so, weil die müssen den Scheiß ja letztendlich auch auslöffeln.
Wenn die dann trotzdem sagen, ey, ja, okay, wir wollen es trotz diesen negativen Aspekten, wollen wir das trotzdem weiter haben, dann würde ich mittlerweile sagen, okay, dann kriegt ihr das auch.
Ich hatte letzten Sommer sowas
Ähm, mit irgendwelchen
Wartungsarbeiten war das
Genau
Mein Chef hat gesagt
Er möchte
Und das, übrigens, das ist jetzt was, was ich tatsächlich auch sehr sinnvoll finde
Da habe ich, über die eigentliche Sache
Habe ich nicht gemeckert
Mein Chef hat gesagt, hier Jungs, guckt mal
Dass wir auch auf den verbleibenden Systemen
Wo es noch keine automatischen
Betriebssystem-Updates gibt
Also wir machen quasi ein Yam-Update einmal nächtlich auf den Red Hat Kisten.
Nicht nächtlich, einmal nächtlich, Blödsinn.
Einmal wöchentlich oder einmal monatlich machen wir quasi ein automatisches Yam-Update auf den Kisten.
Und da hat er gesagt, schaut mal das auf den Kisten, wo das noch nicht ist.
Ihr das auch einrichtet.
Weil mein Chef hat mich schon darauf angesprochen und wir wollen das Thema abhaken.
Das soll alles automatisiert sein.
Okay, ja, finde ich auch gut.
Das, ja, finde ich
schlecht. So.
Und da habe ich gesehen, okay, ein Service.
Ne, da musst du
aufpassen. Naja, gut, in gewisser Weise
musst du dich um Linux-Probleme kümmern.
Aber wichtig ist natürlich, sich sowas dann auch mal
festzuhalten, ja. Also gerade,
wenn deine Vorgesetzte dazu neigen, Sachen
öfters zu vergessen, dass sie besprochen wurden.
Da musst du das halt aufschreiben.
Zumindest ging es da dann drum, okay, ich habe hier
einen Service, wo die
Betriebssysteme noch nicht automatisch
aktualisiert werden, also
bin ich mal zu den Leuten hin,
virtuell, in Teams,
die für die Anwendung zuständig sind, die auf den
Servern laufen. Ich hab gesagt, hier Leute,
wir müssen uns mal ein
Wartungsfenster irgendwie ausdenken, einmal
die Woche, einmal im Monat,
wo wir die Server updaten können. Updaten
heißt im Zweifelsfall auch Kernel-Update und
Restart.
Da hab ich gesagt, hier, ich schlag vor, wir
machen das einfach irgendwo nachts unter
der Woche.
Ihr seid ja auch morgens schon da.
Gebraucht werden die Systeme erst
ab 8.30 Uhr.
Ihr seid meistens auch 7.30 Uhr, 8.00 Uhr
schon da.
Da könnt ihr morgens schon gucken.
Und wenn irgendwas
nicht geht, das fixen.
Beziehungsweise bei uns Bescheid
sagen. Dann meinen die,
das geht auf gar
keinen Fall. Unter der Woche
ist das nicht möglich.
wir wollen das Sonntag
um, was weiß ich,
4 Uhr oder sowas haben.
Und dann wollen wir auch, dass jemand
von euch zur Verfügung steht am Sonntag,
falls was kaputt ist, dass er das fixen kann.
Habe ich ihm versucht
zu erklären, weißt du was?
Es ist extrem unwahrscheinlich,
dass da was passiert.
Wir reden ja hier von
meiner OS-Updates, ja. Da wird
dann Version 3.4.4.5
auf
3.446 geupgradet.
So nach dem Motto,
ich mache das jetzt schon 20 Jahre
und
ich kann mich glaube ich nicht an einen Fall erinnern,
wo so ein meiner Red Hat Update
oder OS Update
sei es jetzt von Red Hat oder Debian
dafür gesorgt hat, dass dann die
Anwendung letztendlich nicht mehr funktioniert.
Zumal die Anwendung ja selbst
deployed wird mit einer eigenen Java Version,
die noch nicht mal was mit der vom Betriebssystem zu tun hat.
Also es ist sehr, sehr unwahrscheinlich, dass da was passiert.
Aus meiner Sicht können wir das trotzdem machen.
Und da meinte der, nee, nee, sie wollen das unbedingt haben.
Sie wollen das am Wochenende haben und sie wollen halt, dass auch einer verfügbar ist, rufbereitschaftsmäßig.
Und da habe ich mir so gedacht, okay, ihr wollt das unbedingt, dann könnt ihr das ja auch beantragen.
Ja, machen wir das, wir machen das, wir beantragen das.
Und jetzt haben die das beantragt und ich werde das auch machen.
Ich werde das auch machen, weil das ist easy money.
Ich weiß, dass zu 99,9% nie was passieren wird.
Und ich bekomme, also wenn schon, machen wir natürlich Rufbereitschaft dann von quasi Sonntag bis Montagmorgen.
Ja, also schon 24 Stunden.
und da kriege ich für einen Tag, keine Ahnung,
500 Euro
oder sowas, weil Sonntag
und die beantragen
das. Dann denke ich mir auch, ey, wisst ihr was?
Wenn ihr das wollt,
habe ich kein Problem mit.
Mache ich sofort.
Kein Ding. Wenn ihr das unbedingt haben wollt,
wie gesagt, ich halte es nicht für nötig, aber wenn
ihr das unbedingt haben wollt, macht es gut.
Was verdienst du brutto?
Kann ich dir sagen?
Ich hab letztens... Moment, Moment, ich hol mal kurz das Handy von der Arbeit.
Pass auf, dass du nicht zum persönlichen Service-Desk wirst.
Nee, nee, nee, Rufbereitschaft wird nur bei Ausfall angerufen oder bei ernsthaften Problemen.
Nicht hier von wegen, kannst du mir mal kurz ein PDF-Report generieren oder sowas.
Nee, nee, nee, nee.
So, weil das passt ganz gut. Ich habe letztens ein Gehaltserhöhungsschreiben bekommen. Ich muss mal kurz hier meine Personalakte öffnen. Das haben wir übrigens sehr schön gemacht bei meinem jetzigen Arbeitgeber.
Wir haben so eine App für alle möglichen Personalabteilungsdinger.
Dann hat man ein Postfach, wo die ganzen Bonuszahlungen und Gehaltserhöhungssachen und so drin stehen.
Darüber kann man seine Arbeitszeit buchen, wenn man im Homeoffice ist und sowas.
Also das ist wirklich ganz nice gemacht.
So, also Gehaltserhöhungsschreiben vom 1. Juni, Leute.
Top aktuell.
So.
Zack.
Guten Tag, Max.
Wir freuen uns, Ihre Gehaltsbezüge mit Wirkung zum 1. Juni neu festzusetzen.
Also das, was ich euch jetzt erzähle, gilt, wenn ich 100% arbeiten würde.
Was da noch drauf kommt ist
Der Bonus
Bonusanteil
Eine Zulage von knapp
300 Euro
Wegen Rufbereitschaft
Wegen
Manchmal schon Beginn um 37
Und manchmal erst Ende um 18 Uhr
Und
Die ganzen Rufbereitschaften
Also das macht auch nochmal eine ganze Ecke aus
Das ist ohne das alles
Ja, so.
Vergütungs-blablabla-Bonus-Re-
Hier, Gehalt.
100.675 Euro.
So, da kommt jetzt noch Bonus dabei.
Zulage für
für
frühe Anfangszeit und manchmal
späte Endzeit und
Rufbereitschaft. Rufbereitschaft
gibt pro Monat
schwer zu sagen, mal mehr, mal weniger.
An Ostern hatte ich massig viel Kohle,
weil da habe ich den ganzen Ostern, also im April
habe ich an Ostern Rufbereitschaft
gemacht. Also sagen wir mal so,
Rufbereitschaft gibt noch mal
so, sagen wir mal
15k.
Wenn man jetzt, wenn man es drauf anlegt, auch mehr
Wenn man jetzt sagt, ey
Na wobei
Ich habe ja noch Service, ich habe ja noch Wartungsarbeiten
Service-Wartungsarbeiten am Wochenende zusätzlich
Na sag mal
Ich weiß es gar nicht
Ich kann es euch gar nicht so genau sagen
Na sagen wir mal, tippen wir mal, sagen wir mal ungefähr 20k
Ungefähr Rufbereitschaft nochmal oben drauf
Ähm, und dann kommen nochmal
so ungefähr
so ungefähr 4000 Euro
obendrauf
für
die
frühe Anfangszeit, späte Endzeit.
Also sagen wir nochmal
sind wir
jetzt bei
126k
und dann kommt halt auch der Bonus drauf.
Den es einmal im Jahr gibt.
Und der Bonus, der Bonus, der ist nochmal ordentlich.
Also der Bonus kann durchaus auch nochmal 17k oder sowas sein.
Oder teilweise, manche haben sogar noch mehr.
Das ist nicht Tarifvertrag.
Also würde ich sagen...
So...
So 142k ungefähr.
Ich denke, das kommt ziemlich gut hin.
Wenn ich 100% arbeiten würde, wohlgemerkt.
Ich arbeite nicht 100%.
Und ich mache in letzter Zeit tatsächlich auch ein bisschen weniger Rufbereitschaft.
Also von meinem Kollege weiß ich es.
Mein Kollege hatte glaube ich 145k oder sowas letztes Jahr.
Und der hat die gleiche Stufe wie ich vom Gehalt her.
Und ich glaube 2000 Euro weniger oder so insgesamt.
Also es hält sich kaum einen Unterschied.
Ich hab Physi gelernt, ja
Ich hab keine Ahnung
Man kann nicht sagen mit anderen Worten
Du verdienst sehr gutes Geld
Ich hab keine Ahnung, warum ich überhaupt so viel Geld verdiene
Also ich hab da nichts dagegen
Das versteht mich jetzt halt falsch
Ich hab da überhaupt nichts dagegen
Es darf natürlich auch noch mehr sein
Ich nehm auch noch mehr
Aber ganz ehrlich
Ich kann es nicht so ganz nachvollziehen
Warum die mir so viel Geld bezahlen
Ich hab schon Ahnung von dem, was ich mach.
So ist es nicht.
Aber es ist schon krass viel Geld.
Und letztendlich...
Ich kann euch die unschöne Wahrheit sagen,
warum so viel Geld ist.
Ich kann euch sagen...
Esstiermitarbeiter.
Ich bin bestimmt kein Esstiermitarbeiter.
Ich kann euch die unschöne Wahrheit sagen,
warum so viel Geld ist.
Und zwar,
es ist so viel Geld,
weil Geld.
Es hat sich mal
wahrscheinlich jemand hingesetzt
von der
Führungsetage
und hat gesagt,
ich bin Senior
Site Reliability Engineer.
Warum auch immer.
Eingestellt wurde ich
als Senior Linux Engineer.
Es hat sich mal jemand hingesetzt von unserer Führungsetage und hat wahrscheinlich mal ausgerechnet, wenn System XY down ist, kostet uns das 10 Millionen.
Das heißt, hocken wir lieber jemand hin, permanent, der dafür sorgt, dass das System vielleicht nicht eine Stunde weg ist, sondern nur eine halbe Stunde.
Und wenn das nur alle paar Jahre einmal passiert, hat es sich schon gelohnt, da einen hinzusetzen.
Das hat sich mal jemand ausgerechnet und hat gesagt, okay, deswegen bezahlen wir auch Hofbereitschaft und alles so gut,
dass uns, wenn es halt mal der Fall ist, im Fall der Fälle, uns nicht so teuer wird.
Letztendlich kriegen wir alle dort die Kohle wegen der Kohle.
Ja, an Stellen, wo es um Menschenleben geht, da interessiert das die Leute weniger.
Ja, also wenn du dir guckst, die Nachtschicht im Altersheim, die wird wahrscheinlich deutlich weniger verdienen.
und wie gesagt, ich sage nicht, dass das gerechtfertigt oder gerecht oder fair ist oder sowas,
aber nur, dass sich das mal jemand überlegt hat.
Bei uns hat sich halt jemand überlegt, okay, eine Stunde Ausfall kostet uns 10 Millionen
und im Altersheim haben die sich halt überlegt, ey, wen juckt es, wenn der Opa in der Nachtschicht den Löffel abgibt.
Das hat sich halt mal jemand überlegt, dass da mehr Geld drin steckt und dementsprechend das besser bezahlt werden muss.
Und fair oder gerecht finde ich das auch nicht.
Ach so.
Ja gut, wenn du im Krankenhaus arbeitest, kriegst du auch ordentlich Kohle.
Aber halt bei weitem auch nicht jeder, ne?
Also aus meiner Sicht müsste das auch deutlich besser bezahlt werden.
Rufschaden, ja.
Ist auch ein ganz großes Ding.
Willst du sagen, dass ohne Führungsverantwortung
bei dir noch mehr möglich wäre?
Es wäre bei uns noch mehr möglich.
Wir haben drei Karrierewege bei uns auf der Arbeit.
Das ist ein nice
Emote, oder?
Können wir gleich
machen.
Also bei uns
auf der Arbeit gibt es
Gibt es drei Karrieremöglichkeiten
Aber weiß jemand wie das Rainbow CPU Widget
Das ist bei KDE
Individual Core Count
Kannst du einblenden
Das ist richtig nice
Das Widget
Guck mal, wenn ich ein bisschen Auslastung mache
Dann sieht das so aus.
Ich werde bald durch KI ersetzt.
Ja, bestimmt. Instant.
KI.
Aber das ist gut, dann streame ich mehr, wenn ich durch KI ersetzt werde.
Also bei uns auf der Arbeit
gibt es drei Karrieremöglichkeiten.
Du hast einmal die Möglichkeit,
quasi so
Führungskraft zu werden.
Ja, das heißt dann quasi,
du kannst Teamleiter werden,
Abteilungsleiter werden,
so, wie heißt das, so Ressortleiter werden quasi oder halt dann sonst was.
Ich weiß gar nicht, wie es genau ist.
Also du kannst diese Führungskräfteschiene gehen, gibt es bei uns die Möglichkeit.
Die zweite Möglichkeit ist Projektmanagement.
Ja, da kannst du dann, ich weiß auch da nicht, wie der Kram heißt.
Da kannst du dann quasi sowas wie Projektmanager, Seniorprojektmanagement, Supremeprojektmanager, Ultraprojektmanager werden oder sowas. Keine Ahnung, wie das ganze Zeug heißt.
oder du kannst
in der
fachlichen Laufbahn dich auch
weiterentwickeln, also du kannst sowas werden wie
äh, sagen wir mal
Server-Admin, dann wirst du Senior-Server-Admin
dann wirst du Experte
äh, und dann Senior-Experte
und dann irgendwann
Super-Fach-Experte oder sowas
das geht
das geht, das Ding ist nur
damit bekommst du
auch oft
zusätzliche Aufgaben,
die bei, sagen wir jetzt irgendwie, wenn du
jetzt irgendwie Senior-Experte oder sowas
bist,
da bist du wahrscheinlich deutlich weniger
noch selbst
am Handanlegen bei Systemen,
sondern
planst dann vielleicht eher, okay,
wie stellen wir dann zum Beispiel
unser Patch-Management für
alle 8000 Linux-Systeme auf und
sowas.
Ich habe aber, ihr kennt mich, ich habe wenig Ambitionen, was das angeht.
Weil der, wie soll ich sagen, der Arbeitseinsatz und Stresslevel zu Gehalt Ratio, finde ich, wird immer schlechter damit, je höher man kommt.
Also bei uns ist es so, mal angenommen, ich würde jetzt vom Senior Site Reliability Engineer zum, keine Ahnung, zum Expert Site Reliability Engineer, da würde ich gar nicht mehr Gehalt bekommen von dem, was ich euch gerade vorgelesen habe, sondern ich würde mehr Bonus bekommen.
Weil die Philosophie dahinter ist, was sie sagen, umso höher du quasi in dieser Hierarchieebene, Hierarchieebene kann man es ja nennen, so höher du quasi in dieser Fachspezifischen Stufe da aufsteigst, umso weniger Leute gibt es ja und umso mehr Einfluss hat man an der Position ja auch für das Wohlergehen des gesamten Unternehmens.
Deswegen steigt dein Gehalt nicht mehr, sondern es steigt nur der Bonus.
In der Laufbahn, genau.
Das heißt, Gehalt wird nicht mehr steigen, es steigt nur der Bonus.
Was natürlich unterm Strich trotzdem auch noch ordentlich mehr Kohle ausmachen kann.
Aber natürlich ist nicht mehr so extrem viel.
Weil Gehaltserhöhung fließt ja auch automatisch in den Bonus mit ein.
Und Bonuserhöhung fließt nur in den Bonus mit ein.
Und du hast halt auch viel mehr Stress.
und Stress ist eh Kacke für mich
und mehr Arbeit,
mehr Verantwortung, mehr Stress,
mehr Gemiete, mehr rumdiskutiere,
ist es mir da nicht wert
für das, was man mehr Geld kriegt.
Ja, man kriegt dann sicherlich nochmal
20, 25, vielleicht sogar
30k mehr.
Aber jetzt mal seriously.
Jetzt mal, wie hat der
Kabum früher gesagt? Hand aufs Herz.
Guck mal.
Was kann ich mir denn bitteschön mit, wenn man mal von 100% arbeiten ausgeht, was könnte ich mir denn mit 170k leisten, was ich mir nicht mit 140k leisten kann?
Es gibt doch da überhaupt keine Notwendigkeit wirklich dafür, das zu machen.
Es sei denn, man ist selbst so ein Hardcore-Karriere-Crinder.
Ja, wenn man jetzt einer ist, der das um das Karrieremachen Willens macht.
Ja klar, dann hier, let's go.
Aber so jemand bin ich nicht.
Ich kann mir RAM kaufen.
Ja, das stimmt.
Höhere Steuerklasse für mehr Geld im Staat können.
Top.
Ich glaube, so viel mehr höhere Steuerklasse geht doch gar nicht mehr, oder?
Bekomme ich nicht, Max Schallmann, bekomme ich nicht.
Würde ich bekommen, wenn ich 100% arbeiten würde mit Rufbereitschaft und Bonus und allem, das inkludiert schon.
Jetzt, ich bekomme eine ganze Ecke weniger
Aber Teilzeitbeste
So, so sieht's aus
Jetzt haben wir das Thema ausführlich besprochen
Ich glaube, das muss ich mir irgendwann mal clippen oder so
Das kann ich dann einfach verlinken
Wenn mal wieder einer fragt
Aber dachte mir, ist ganz gut jetzt mal Update
Weil es gerade Anfang des Monats eine Änderung gab
Du hast recht, Steuerklasse hat nichts mit dem Gehalt zu tun
Das Blödsinn, was ich erzählt habe
Aber die Prozente, die du bezahlen musst
Und ich glaube viel mehr
Ich meine, ich bin eh schon die höchste Steuerklasse
Keine Kinder, nicht verheiratet, sonst was
Und ich glaube, ich bezahle schon
Maximum, was geht
Ist das normal, Wochenendzuschlag zu bekommen?
Mein Arbeitgeber möchte teilweise, dass ich am Wochenende außerhalb des Server Patches Zuschlag bekomme.
Wir können halt die Überstunden, die wir gemacht haben, abfeuern.
Ja, das ist eine ziemlich reudige Regelung.
Also ganz ehrlich, Wochenende sollte es mehr geben, als einfach nur die normale Arbeitszeit.
Ja, was auch eine Möglichkeit ist, was ich auch schon gesehen habe, ist, dass die normale Arbeitszeit als Arbeitszeit verrechnet wird, aber es noch quasi obendrauf Bonussachen gibt.
Aber einfach nur am Wochenende Arbeitszeit gut geschrieben bekommen, das ist ziemlich ass, die Regelung.
Und ob das überhaupt erlaubt ist, weiß ich auch nicht.
aber damit kenne ich mich nicht wirklich aus
aber das auf jeden fall keine gute regelung also sie sollten euch mal
zumindest die arbeitszeit gut schreiben plus noch mal das was ihr da quasi
verdient noch mal als bonus obendrauf hauen so zumal zwei fände ich ganz
sie nicht.
Aber das, ja.
Nur weil ich das so sehe, müssen die das ja nicht
so sehen.
Weil ansonsten, ganz ehrlich, wenn die sagen, es hat kein...
Also, wenn du keine Anreize
hast, irgendwie am Wochenende zu arbeiten,
dann arbeite einfach nicht am Wochenende.
Du hast einfach
Besseres zu tun am Wochenende. Bist verabredet.
Kannst nicht.
Die müssen es dir schon
ein bisschen schmackhaft machen.
Arch-User.
Proc.
KI wird in Banken und in Versicherungen aus Datenschutz.
Die kommen doch.
Ich habe heute bei einer Versicherung.
Wir haben KI.
Wir haben einen eigenen Chat-GPT-Fork.
Also bei Azure.
Du kannst bei Microsoft Chat-GPT kaufen und die garantieren dir dann, dass die Daten nicht zum Training von Modellen benutzt werden und dass deine Daten in Europa bleiben.
Inwieweit das wirklich 100%ig so ist, das kann dir natürlich außer Microsoft keiner sagen.
Gemini haben wir auch
Google garantiert das gleiche
und Copilot haben wir neuerdings auch
aber das ist ja auch Microsoft, die garantieren das auch
Hast du mal ausgerechnet, wie viele Leute, die nicht arbeiten, du mit deinen Steuern finanzierst?
Ey, ganz ehrlich, über das Thema will ich mir gar keine Gedanken machen, weil da rege ich mich nur auf.
Ich will sehen, wie das teilweise alles den Bach runter geht und was für krasse Abgaben ich bezahlen muss.
Schon heftig.
Und es wird ja immer schlimmer noch in nächster Zeit.
Ah, das würde ich mir gar nicht überlegen.
Ich habe letztens einen älteren Spiegel-TV-Beitrag gesehen.
Da lebt einer mit seinen zwei Frauen und sechs Kindern in einem vom Arbeitsamt gestellten Haus.
Und sein Ziel ist halt, also gibt auch ordentlich Kohle im Monat überwiesen.
Und sein Ziel ist es halt, auch in Zukunft nicht arbeiten zu gehen.
Weil er will sich lieber um die Kinder kümmern.
The fuck, Alter.
Was ist da los? Warum ist das überhaupt ein Ding?
Das sind so Dinge, da kann ich mich schon drüber aufregen.
Aber es macht keinen Sinn, sich darüber aufzuregen
Weil sonst regst du dich den ganzen Tag auf
Muss er bis zur Rente aber noch paar mal neue Frauen suchen
Ja, sein Ziel ist
Das hat er auch in einem Interview bei Spiegel TV erzählt.
Sein Ziel ist es, seine dritte Frau noch nachzuholen nach Deutschland und bis zu 20 Kinder zu kriegen.
Das ist so sein Lebensziel.
Und halt nicht zu arbeiten, weil er sich um die Kinder kümmern will.
Das sind halt so Dinge, wo ich mir denke, Alter, das kann es jetzt ja nicht wirklich sein, dass wir das alles mitfinanzieren müssen.
Ja, er will insgesamt vier Frauen.
Ja, und diese 20 Kinder arbeiten später und bringen Kohle.
Ja, mal gucken, mal gucken.
Dass sie das gleiche Wahlrecht haben, ja, das ist vollkommen okay.
Bis du Staatsbürger darfst du wählen.
Was auch richtig ist.
Ja, das sind so Dinge, wo ich denke, muss das wirklich sein, Alter?
Siehst du Probleme mit der Jobsuche bei der IT?
Ähm, bei ITler.
Systemintegration.
Ja, ja, ey, das ist alles Kacke, ne?
Ja, ja. Wisst ihr, das ist sicherlich nicht die größte, also solche, sagen wir mal so, soziale Extremfälle oder wie auch immer man das nennen mag, das ist bestimmt nicht der größte Weg, wo Geld verschwendet wird.
Wenn man sich das mal anguckt, ich habe letztens so eine Statistik gesehen, also ich glaube das mit Abstand am meisten Geld geht raus, also von den Einnahmen, die wir in Deutschland so haben, geht raus an Pflege, also Altersvorsorge, Pflege, Krankenversicherung und sowas. Ich glaube das ist ein riesen Ding.
Ja, das ist sicherlich nicht das größte Problem, was wir haben.
Aber es wird aktuell, gerade von unserer aktuellen Regierung, ja, wird immer so erzählt,
ja, so nach dem Motto, wir müssen das jetzt mal hier alles ein bisschen strenger regeln
und die Leute müssen sich mehr anstrengen, 8-Stunde-Tag soll abgeschafft werden
und die Leute sollen mal hier richtig ranklotzen für Deutschland und alles und hin und her.
Und es ist halt echt schwierig, es ist halt echt schwierig, die, wie soll man das sagen, den, das halt überzeugend zu machen, ja.
wenn es dann auf der anderen Seite Leute gibt, die mit vier Frauen und 20 Kindern und einem bezahlten Haus nicht arbeiten gehen.
Schwer vermittelbar, genau das meine ich.
Das ist halt schwer vermittelbar.
Und ja, das sind sicherlich Einzelfälle, aber es macht es trotzdem schwer vermittelbar.
kommen ja auch so Dinger wie
die Grenze von 100.000 Euro Einkommen,
was die
Pflegekosten
für die Eltern angeht, soll abgeschafft werden.
Also sobald du,
jetzt ist es so, wenn du über 100.000 Euro verdienst,
musst du dich an den
Pflegekosten, Pflegeheimkosten
von deinen Eltern beteiligen,
sofern sie es nicht selbst bezahlen können.
Man kann sagen, ja, okay,
das ist eine ziemlich willkürliche Grenze,
aber ist wichtig, dass die Leute überhaupt mal ordentlich ein bisschen was Vermögen aufbauen können
und ein bisschen was für das Alter zurücklegen können, soll abgeschafft werden.
Und letztendlich läuft es dann irgendwie darauf raus,
wenn du wirklich arbeiten gehst, gut Kohle verdienst,
du musst ja wirklich alles bezahlen mittlerweile.
Und das wird immer noch mehr. Dann gibt es Diskussionen wie der 8-Stunden-Tag soll weg und solche Dinger. WTF?
Der Pflegeplatz kostet 3 bis 4k im Monat. Das meiste davon bezahlt die Pflegeversicherung ab dem 4. Jahr 75%. Nur das, was darüber rausgeht, musst du selbst bezahlen. Das können durchaus die einen oder anderen selbst bezahlen.
Ja, das kann es irgendwie nicht sein.
Ich habe so krasse Abgaben auf meinem Gehaltszettel draufstehen.
Und so ziemlich...
Vieles von dem, was mir persönlich wichtig ist, wird halt immer beschissener.
Guckt euch das mal an.
Wenn du gesetzlich krankenversichert bist, hast du im Zweifelsfall...
Nehmen wir doch mal das Beispiel.
Ja? Ich hatte das letzte Jahr über psychische Probleme.
Hab ich ja im Stream schon ein paar Mal erzählt.
Ich nehm ja auch Pillen und ich hab auch eine Therapie gemacht und blablabla.
Ohne Scheiß, Leute, hätte ich das nicht selbst bezahlt,
würde ich heute noch drauf warten, dass ich einen Therapieplatz krieg.
Das kannst du vergessen.
Oder Leute, die zum Hautarzt müssen, warten teilweise ein Dreivierteljahr.
Da ist den, da ist den, da haben die wahrscheinlich schon Hautkrebs nach der Zeit,
bis sie da mal wirklich einer drauf guckt also das fakt übertrieben ab dass
das so kacke ist infrastruktur grad öffentlicher nachverkehr auch die
straßen generell immer beschissener
bürokratie overhead es fack überall
Also ich sehe irgendwie nicht, dass da...
...das gut investiert wird.
Wäre das der Fall...
Jetzt wird das Hautkrebs-Screening...
Das ist auch wieder so ein Ding.
Wie dumm kann man sein, das Hautkrebs-Screening nicht mehr bezahlen zu wollen?
Das ist doch die Probleme wieder nur in die Zukunft verschieben, oder?
Wenn die Leute jetzt nicht zum Hautkrebs-Screening gehen, dann spart das jetzt erstmal Geld.
Aber dafür haben viel mehr Leute in 20 Jahren Hautkrebs.
Was dann viel, viel, viel mehr kostet, als jetzt die Vorsorge zu machen.
Damit löst man das Rentenproblem.
Okay, das ist die Logik dahinter.
Ja, das geht außerdem schnell.
Puzzlemeister, danke schön für den Sub.
Ah ja.
Schön zu sehen, dass wir da nicht die einzigen sind.
Was?
Ja, es ist auch sowas, genau, Infrastruktur generell muss man sagen, Infrastruktur, auch Versorgung von Schulen und sonst was,
Das ist alles irgendwie nicht so das, was ich mir vorstelle bei dem Land, was am viertmeisten, also was die viertgrößte Wirtschaft hat.
Werden wir wahrscheinlich auch nicht mal lange haben, aber aktuell haben wir es noch.
Ich finde das vom Ansatz her übrigens auch gut, das so zu sehen.
So rede ich mir das auch immer schön, dass ich mich nicht aufrege.
Da sage ich, ey, das ist statistisch gesehen so selten und das kommt nicht oft vor und man weiß, was die noch für Probleme haben, bla.
Weil sonst müsste ich mich drüber aufregen.
Aber trotzdem, es ist schwer vermittelbar, wenn es immer solche Sonderfälle rauskommen und auf der anderen Seite gesagt wird,
ihr müsst den Gürtel enger schnallen, mehr arbeiten, länger arbeiten und sonst was.
Das passt einfach nicht zusammen.
Wir sind sogar die drittgrößte Volkswirtschaft
Siehst du mal
Wir verschicken ja auch noch Faxe
Wir sind ja auch noch Faxweltmeister
Es ist ja sicherlich nicht nur
Das ist ja, es sind nicht viele
Ja, an der Summe, aber es ist sicherlich nicht nur einer
Backfly, danke schön für den Sub
werbung naja leute ausrufezeichen ukraine ausrufezeichen sie geld im chat kriegt
er den link wohl günstige ukraine nass ist und storage kaufen könnt oder ums mal mit
denen ihren worten zu sagen mehr speicher mehr sicherheit mit sie geld juli nass bandelt sicherst
du Daten, Fotos und Projekte zentral.
Bam.
Wann kommt das erste Faxgerät mit
KI-Assistent raus? Mich würde es nicht
wundern, wenn es das schon gibt. So, wir müssen jetzt aber
meine Stellenanzeigen weitermachen hier.
Was
ist denn das? Warte mal, das hier hatten wir noch gar
nicht fertig, oder? Also die Stellenanzeige
fand ich insgesamt gar nicht schlecht hier.
Die fand ich gar nicht so übel, die Echotel-Stellenanzeige.
Es war recht erfrischend geschrieben.
Nicht halbe IT-Abteilung in einem, sondern eher so ein bisschen umschrieben.
Ja, so ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ähm, wo steht's?
Ja, Automatisierung, Datensicherung, sollst ein bisschen Ahnung von Netzwerk haben,
sich mit Linux-Windows-Servern auskennen, das sind 4Ms, finde ich okay.
Gegen sowas habe ich gar nichts.
Ich finde es eher fragwürdig, wenn die dann halt sagen, wie in anderen Stellenanzeigen,
du verantwortest Windows Server, Active Directory, Linux Server, virtuelle Maschinen, Firewall, Storage, Netzwerk, VMware, Azure Sachen, AWS Sachen.
Das finde ich immer bescheuert.
Aber sowas, das passt ja eigentlich ganz gut zu einem Systemadministrator.
Ich fand die Stellenanzeige hier gar nicht übel.
So, was haben wir hier als nächstes?
Fachinformatiker für Systemintegration.
Das ist eine Ausbildungsstelle, oder?
Nee.
65 K... Moment.
Die suchen einen Fachinformatiker für Systemintegration.
Also das ist wirklich selten, dass sowas gesucht wird.
service desk spezialist omg das wird bestimmt schlimm
fachinformatiker ist immer etwas saß ja man sieht auf jeden fall nicht so oft ja das stimmt
Was?
Okay, also.
Literale En... Was?
Das sind Medikamente, die das Zellwachstum hemmen.
Sie wären Chemotherapie, okay.
Augenheilmittel.
Ernährung ohne Magen-Darm-Trakt.
Aha.
Moment, man kann sich ohne Magen und Darm ernähren?
Muss man sich das dann direkt spritzen, oder was?
Ich wusste gar nicht, dass man überleben kann ohne Magen und Darm.
Was es nicht alles gibt.
Also was suchen sie denn?
Sie suchen ein Fachinformatiker für Systemintegration.
Deine Aufgaben.
Virtualisierung von Serverumgebung.
Da fände ich es immer sinnvoll, wenn tatsächlich die eingesetzte Technologie dabei steht.
Weil das doch schon immer sehr tiefe Gewässer sind.
Das ist immer sehr spezifisch.
Jemand, der gut VMware kann, der ist vielleicht jetzt nicht so geil mit Hyper-V.
Betreuung und Wartung von Windows und Linux-Servern?
Ja, ist immer ein schwieriger Kombo.
Weil Leute, die sich richtig gut mit Linux-Servern auskennen, haben keinen Bock auf Windows.
Verständlicherweise.
Einrichten von Netzwerkinfrastrukturen, Internetanbindung sowie Konfiguration von Druckern und Firewalls.
Alter, übertreibt zwar wieder, ey.
Warum sind dann alle Stellenanzeigen Bullshit?
Weil wissen wir noch gar nicht, ob die Bullshit ist.
Es fängt vielleicht jetzt nicht ganz so toll an.
Ja, letztendlich, der Chat ist schuld.
Das kommt drauf an, was der Chat mir schickt.
Die anderen aber auch schon echt gut.
Wieso? Das stimmt doch gar nicht.
Die letzte Stellenanzeige war überhaupt nicht shit.
Die letzte Stellenanzeige war doch ganz okay.
Leon, schick nochmal, falls ich übersehen habe.
Also, das ist natürlich schon ein bisschen cringe wieder.
Also, das hier geht ja noch klar.
Aber das dann...
Konfiguration von Druckern.
Ja, jawohl.
Klein-PCs und mobile Endgeräte sowie deren Peripherie installieren.
Installation von Festnetz und Mobiltelefonie.
Moment, ich glaube die Playlist ist...
Support von Office 365, Koordination extra, Software-Verteilungssysteme.
Technische Hotline, selbstständiges Arbeiten von Anforderungen aus.
Support der Warenwirtschaftssysteme, First- und Second-Level-Support.
eigenständige Plan... WTF, Alter,
wer schreibt denn diese Stellenanzeigen
wieder ab?
Ist es... Sag mal, ist es so
schwer?
Das ist auch wieder eine komplette IT-Abteilung
in einem. Guck mal, ich meine, das hier
geht ja noch klar. Wenn es auch relativ schwierig ist,
jemanden zu finden, der sich gut mit Linux und Windows
auskennt, aber okay.
Dass man noch sagen kann, okay,
Netzwerkinfrastruktur, Internetanbindung,
das ist ja auch noch irgendwie, kann man sagen,
wenn es eine kleine Klitsche ist.
Okay.
Dass du dich dann noch um Drucker und Firewalls
kümmern musst.
Da wird es schon schwierig.
Aber dann kleinen PCs
und mobile Endgeräte.
Wie willst du das eigentlich
an einem Tag alles machen?
Wie willst du das eigentlich an einem Tag alles machen?
Willst du
Willst du morgens mal kurz ein paar Logfiles aufräumen, weil irgendwelche Sachen nachts zugespampt wurden?
Dann klonst du nochmal schnell ein paar VMs.
In der Zeit, wo die VMs klonen, rennst du rüber, schließt einen Drucker an.
Dann trittst du mal gegen das DSL-Modem, dass die Internetverbindung wieder funktioniert.
Nebenbei packst du einen neuen Switch aus.
Richtest ein, dass in der Firewall einfach alle Ports weitergeleitet werden.
stellst noch ein paar neue Desktop-PCs auf,
richtest das iPhone vom Chef ein,
bringst noch kurz ein Festnetztelefon hoch,
kümmerst dich drum, dass neue Software-Updates in die Software-Verteilung kommen,
dann guckst du dir an, warum Teams wieder rumspackt,
rufst einen externen Dienstleister dafür an,
bekommst nebenbei noch Anrufe,
warum der PC noch nicht funktioniert, den du vorhin aufgebaut hast.
Wie soll das funktionieren?
Eigenständige Planung und Umsetzung von Projekten
Ja, ist klar
Ist klar, natürlich, was sonst
Das machst du auch noch
Während du telefonierst mit zwei
Zwei Hörern
Gleichzeitig
Und das hier oben alles machst
Planst du noch eigene Projekte und setzt die um
Was wollen die zahlen wahrscheinlich nicht so viel wie du dir jetzt vorstellst
65k na ja
Ich meine immerhin noch besser als das professoren netzwerk die 49k bezahlen wollten
Microsoft server active directory office
vorteilhaft vor allem wer secure point
ist das das von HP gewesen?
Oder von Dell?
Nee, oder?
Nee, nee. Okay, wieder was ganz...
HP, Aruba, Switche,
Enphone, das habe ich schon mal gehört.
Das habe ich schon mal gehört.
Habe ich noch nie was mitgemacht, das habe ich schon mal gehört.
Securepoint ist eine Firewall,
sagt der Chat.
Ich kenne Checkpoint.
Checkpoint.
Ich zeige ja immer gerne,
das hier, weil
die jungen Hüpfer
hier im Chat
das gar nicht mehr kennen.
Chat, Checkpoint UI.
Checkpoint UI.
Wer kennt es noch, Leute?
Checkpoint GUI.
Toll, oder?
Du kennst es leider.
Für die damalige Zeit war das gar nicht so mies.
Da ging das klar.
Ja, so sah das aus.
Genauso.
Also den Checkpoint VPN-Client, den kenne ich nicht.
Checkpoint.
Der sieht bestimmt auch so hässlich aus, oder?
Okay, der sieht hässlich aus.
Sieht der immer noch genauso hässlich aus?
Sag mal.
So, also analytische Denkweise, Kommunikationsfähigkeit und Teamfähigkeit, sehr gutes technisches Verständnis.
Führerschein sowie Reise, Alter, auch noch.
Reisebereitschaft.
Und du hast permanent zwei Telefone am Ohr und musst Desktop-Rechner aufstellen.
Wie willst du denn da noch Auto fahren dabei?
Ein breites Spektrum interessanter Aufgaben.
Ein breites Spektrum, so kann man das auch nennen, ja.
Also die Stellenanzeige hat mich jetzt nicht überzeugt.
Das ist wieder
Ganze IT-Abteilung und mehr
In einer Person
Ne, das ist nix
Das ist wirklich nix
Wie gesagt, wir wissen nicht, wie gut das wirklich ist
Vielleicht ist das die beste Firma ever
Aber anhand der Stellenanzeige
Ich persönlich würde mich da nicht bewerben drauf
Semu, und danach musst du wahrscheinlich noch zum Chef heimfahren und das iPhone einrichten.
Am Sonntag.
Was haben wir hier?
Bei der Polizei.
Landesamt für zentrale polizeiliche Dienste.
das chat ich wollte sagen ist ein kai bild nein es ist kein kai bild ist es in
adobe stock foto it service desk spezialist spezialistin spezialistin
spezialist alarm
da kann ich jetzt schon gleich sagen wenn ich diesen titel sie definitiv
wäre das selbst wenn ich versuchen würde garantiert nichts für mich service desk
würde ich wahrscheinlich ein tag durchhalten und danach müsste ich erst
mal in die psychiatrie wieder
sie sind die erste anlaufstelle für it fragen und finden für jedes problem die
passende lösung
stimmt ich könnte einfach ein team der psychiatrie machen
das ist eigentlich die idee
Das ist next level, die Idee.
Dann werden sie Teil unseres Teams als IT-Service Desk Spezialisten.
Freuen sie ab.
Abwechslungsreiche Aufgaben.
Gibt es da auch Corporate Benefits?
40 jahre gibt es dann gibt es jeden tag eine packung sehr traurigen umsonst
man kann nur machen wenn man nicht patient ist naja dadurch
Wieso ist doch Top-Life-Work-Life-Balance dann?
Du weißt gar nicht, was davon Life und was davon Work ist.
So, aber gucken wir mal, was bei der Polizei hier so abgeht.
Bravo, Mike, du hast das auch mal genommen?
Wie viel hast du denn genommen?
Also ich nehme das auch, by the way.
Und ich habe so gut wie keine Nebenwirkungen.
gar nichts.
Außer, dass es mir besser geht.
Es ist vor allem
am Anfang ist es halt scheiße.
Wahrscheinlich war es bei dir auch die ersten paar Wochen
nur so.
Viele brechen ja sowas auch nach 1-2 Wochen
ab, weil es ihnen zu eklig ist mit den Nebenwirkungen.
Aber gerade so die ersten paar Wochen
sind halt bei so Pillen immer kacke.
Ein Beruf ist mehr als nur Geld verdient.
Das stimmt, aber ich glaube für die meisten ist es schon mal hauptsächlich Geld verdienen.
Die innere Sicherheit in unserem Land.
Okay.
Bei der Service- und Technikbehörde.
Alter, viel deutscher kann was nicht mehr klingen, oder?
unser angebot schauen wir mal suchen die dann überhaupt also service desk
Ja, das ist natürlich kacke, wenn die da so drauf sind.
Okay, 150 Milligramm ist auch ordentlich.
Ich nehme die Hälfte davon.
Würdest du dich verbeamten für eine solche Stelle?
Klar, wenn die Kohle stimmt.
Ja, Seemo, es ist wichtig, wo man hingeht.
Was meint ihr mit Milligramm?
Mg ist Milligramm.
Unser Angebot. Ja, okay, was genau wollen sie denn jetzt eigentlich? Ach, hier unten sind ihre Aufgaben.
Okay, einen sicheren und sinnstiftenden Arbeitsplatz, auch in Krisenzeiten.
Mobiles Arbeiten, eine optimale Work-Life-Balance.
Kooperation mit Familienservice-Einrichtungen.
Was soll das heißen? Die haben Kindergarten oder was?
Zahlreiche Forderungen, Entwicklungsvielfältige Sport- und Gesundheitsangebote, Betriebsrente, Jahres-Sonderzahl, vermögenswirksame Leistungen.
Also so krass war es bei mir nicht, dass mich der Wagen da abholen musste.
Aber klar, falls du Panikattacken oder sonst was hast in der Richtung,
da kann es natürlich schon sein, dass man denkt, man kratzt jetzt ab und ruft den Notarzt.
Das ist zum Glück bei mir anders gelagert.
Ja, das ist... Das kenne ich.
Das habe ich aber nicht genommen. Das ist auch relativ alt. Das wird heute eigentlich gar nicht mehr so viel verschrieben.
Also heute werden eher neuere...
Wie heißen die Dinger?
S, S, R, I? Kann das sein?
Also heute werden eher neuere Medikamente dieser...
...Art verschrieben.
Das habe ich auch schon tatsächlich mal mit meinem Hausarzt, mit meiner Hausärztin besprochen.
Wo wir auch gesagt haben, okay, könnte man vielleicht auch mal ausprobieren.
Aber bei mir hilft das der Traline ganz gut.
Und ich hoffe ja, dass ich die Sachen, die ich jetzt aktuell noch abends nehme, gar nicht mehr wirklich lange nehmen muss.
Ja, ich nehme ja manchmal nur noch ein Viertel abends.
Ich soll ja eigentlich
eine ganze abends nehmen. Also nicht
Sertralin, sondern was anderes noch.
Soll ich eigentlich eine ganze abends nehmen,
aber ich nehme schon lange keine ganze mehr, sondern nur noch
eine halbe und jetzt teilweise nur noch ein Viertel abends
und kann trotzdem gut pennen.
Ja, es hat jeder
so ein bisschen andere...
Wirkt alles bei jedem ein bisschen anders.
Ja.
Ne, ne, ne.
Aber das hatten wir auch schon mal.
Falls ich abends noch mal was anderes kriege zum Beruhigen, Beschlafen, dann ist das hier wahrscheinlich das.
Tja.
Aber wisst ihr, was daran schön zu sehen ist?
Also schön in Anführungszeichen.
Schön zu sehen ist hier, was wir gerade wieder im Chat hatten.
Man sieht, dass auch wenn man das gerne denkt, man ist mit solchen Problemen nicht der Einzige.
Man ist mit so Problemen nicht der Einzige.
Und gerade Angststörung und Depression, das sind die häufigsten psychischen Erkrankungen.
Ich glaube, die machen 50% aller psychischen Erkrankungen aus.
was der Vorteil davon ist
dass man sich ganz gut damit auskennt
und ganz gut Bescheid weiß
was man da machen kann
und man kann beides gut behandeln
man sollte sich da auch nicht
entmutigen lassen, wenn es mal ein bisschen länger dauert
es ist halt bei psychischen Sachen
oftmals nicht so, dass man
zwei Wochen irgendwelche Tabletten nimmt
und es ist alles wieder weg, das dauert ein bisschen länger
aber das lässt mit der Zeit nach
kann ich euch aus eigener Erfahrung sagen
also man denkt auch
das wird jetzt immer so bleiben und bleibt ganz
furchtbar schlimm und wird immer schlimmer
aber das lässt mit der Zeit nach
Gut.
Aber genug.
Jetzt gucken wir uns endlich mal die Schnellanzeige von der Polizei an.
Vielleicht soll ich noch mal was anderes sagen.
Darfst du nicht kiffen oder sonst hast du direkt ein Problem.
Noch mehr als sonst schon.
Ja.
Auf die Idee wäre ich jetzt auch nicht gekommen.
Was für Wartezeiten?
Was meinst du?
Ne, ne.
Also generell, wenn man
so Medikamente
nimmt, die so psychisch
wirken, dann
würde ich weder
kiffen noch rauchen.
Wobei rauchen wahrscheinlich noch am ehesten geht,
wenn es unbedingt sein muss. Und vor allem auch
kein Alkohol dazu trinken.
Das ist schlecht
in Kombination.
Ne, habe ich nichts.
Wenn ich schlafe, schlafe ich super.
Und die letzten Zeiten habe ich überhaupt keine Probleme mehr mit Schlafen.
Deswegen sage ich ja, es wird mit der Zeit alles besser.
Dauert nur ein bisschen.
Auch ein bisschen Arbeit, ja.
Aber man kriegt die Sachen in den Griff.
So.
Also, was sagt denn hier noch?
So, die Polizei ist aber nicht... Ihre Aufgaben!
So, was haben wir denn hier sonst noch?
Ach nee, was ich noch sagen wollte jetzt.
WTF. Alter.
Was...
Hast du eigentlich... Ja, habe ich mitbekommen, dass das geben soll.
Also eine Sache, was bei mir wirklich hilft, ist Bewegung.
Also wenn ich die...
Wenn ich das mal vergleichen dürfte, ja.
Ich könnte mir morgens quasi...
wenn ich aufgeregt bin, ja, wenn ich
wieder irgendwie so ein bisschen Zeug zusammenspinne,
dann könnte ich mir morgens
eine von meinen Pillen
einschmeißen, die ich eigentlich nur abends
nehme. Das sind so die Pillen für akute
Sachen. Oder aber,
ich gehe 45 Minuten
mich ordentlich draußen bewegen,
dann hilft das eigentlich
besser als die Pille.
Also bewegen,
gerade was so Angststörungen
und Depressionen angeht,
bringt enorm viel das bringt richtig viel
dass das baut richtig viel stresshormone und alles ab also bewegen macht extrem
viel aus wirklich
So.
Max muss sich jetzt einfach mal fragen, was soll ich mir alles genau kaufen, um ein Homelab für die Ausbildung mit aufzubauen?
Will mit 30 jetzt...
Das ist wahrscheinlich auch nicht verkehrt.
Also ich weiß halt nicht, ob das bei dir jeden Morgen klappt
Aber kannst du auch machen
Aber trotzdem, so 45 Minuten ordentlich anstrengend draußen eine Runde rennen, Fahrrad fahren, irgendwas reicht schon
Und es geht einem den ganzen Tag besser
Also was du genau kaufen sollst für eine Homelab-Ausbildung
Wenn mir 30 so gut wie möglich mich anstrengen
Die Ausbildung diese auch gut abzutrieben
Dann schaue ich dazu ein YouTube-Tutorial
Ja gut, YouTube-Tutorials musst du dir erstmal angucken
In welchem Bereich
Ja, es kommt halt ein bisschen drauf an, was du lernen willst
Was du machen willst
Willst du dich mit Linux beschäftigen?
willst du ein bisschen basteln, dann ist ein Raspberry Pi immer noch nicht verkehrt oder
ein günstiger Mini-PC, wo du Linux drauf installieren kannst. Du musst aber nicht zwangsläufig
Linux auf einer extra Kiste installieren. Du kannst auch in der VM installieren, um
da dran ein bisschen rumzubasteln. Und der beste Weg, Linux zu lernen, ist meiner Meinung
nach eh weniger ein Homelab, sondern mehr ein Linux-Desktop, den man täglich zum Arbeiten
verwendet. Kann übrigens auch in der VM sein.
Das ist viel besser, weil dann, wenn du deine tägliche Arbeit mit Linux erledigst,
dann kriegst du einfach sehr viel, so, wie nennt man so schön, Muscle Memory.
Also so, hier Sachen, guck mal, ich kann blind sowas hier tippen zum Beispiel.
Und das sind einfach Sachen, die man sich merkt.
Also das bringt wirklich was.
Wenn du Linux täglich verwendest,
du willst dich außerhalb der arbeit weiterbilden und lernen wie gesagt linux
zu können in der heutigen zeit ist nie verkehrt linux ist überall
dazu brauchst du aber nicht unbedingt raspberry pi oder irgendeine linux mini pc du kannst das
auch in der vm machen wenn du allerdings dir was bauen möchtest daheim was 24 7
läuft zum beispiel wenn du dich ein bisschen mit heim automatisierung
beschäftigen willst oder wenn du was haben denn die leute so standardmäßig
bei sich laufen im im home lab wie gesagt ich habe bei mir hauptsächlich
home assistant laufen und paar kleinen sachen aber es hält sich den grenzen
wenn du nicht laut laufen lassen willst bei hole
netzwerk storage
wenn du was willst du hast 24 7 läuft da musste mal gucken je nachdem was du machen willst weil
dafür ist ein raspberry pi gar nicht mal so geil raspberry pi ist nicht ist es ist kein gutes
Netzwerk-Storage zum Beispiel.
Paperless und sowas
in der Richtung. Also wenn du einfach
wenn du ein Homelab haben willst, wo du ein bisschen
mit rumbasteln kannst. Weißt du, was du dann kaufst?
Da gehst du
auf meinen Link.
Da gehst du auf meinen Link.
Und
Naja, du brauchst ja wahrscheinlich erstmal keine Festplatten.
Sowas ist zum Beispiel nicht verkehrt.
Wenn du jetzt nicht ultra viel Rechenleistung brauchst, ist so ein Ding hier gar nicht verkehrt.
Da kannst du Festplatten reinstöpseln, SSDs reinstöpseln.
Hast eine 2,5 Gig Netzwerkkarte.
Bekommst CPU und RAM, ist schon dabei.
Also zum Homelab-Einstieg finde ich sowas perfekt.
Oder aber, was ich hier daheim habe.
Ich habe das Ding hier daheim. Das ist auch ein super Einstiegsnass.
Ist wahrscheinlich aber schon ein bisschen Oversize, wenn du einfach nur ein bisschen rumspielen willst.
Welches OS empfiehlst du für das UK NAS?
Ja, kommt drauf an, was du machen willst.
Ich hab Proxmox drauf.
Ansonsten ist Unraid nicht verkehrt.
Hab ich ja auch noch am Start auf dem alten HP Microserver.
Unraid ist nicht verkehrt.
Und ansonsten, ich weiß, es finden ganz viele Leute TrueNAS toll.
Ich hab TrueNAS letztens ausprobiert, mir hat's immer noch überhaupt nicht gefallen.
Nee, nee, nee, nee, mach kein Dualboot.
Mach kein Dualboot.
Stopp Galaxy Force, kein Dualboot.
Was du machen kannst ist,
installiere doch Linux einfach mal.
Hattest du nicht eben noch eine Frage?
Was war da mal hier?
Angenommen, ich installiere mir Linux,
beziehungsweise es ist nun installiert,
was soll ich dann am besten machen, um zu lernen?
Installiere dir den Linux in AVM
und benutze es zum täglichen Arbeiten.
Das ist das Einfachste, was du machen kannst.
Du wirst früher oder später eh dann auf Ideen kommen, was du gerne daheim machen würdest.
Also solange du keinen wirklichen Einsatzzweck hast für ein Homelab,
wenn du nicht sagst, ich will mir ein Kubernetes-Cluster mal vom Scratch aufbauen,
was ich übrigens nicht empfehlen kann, oder ich will das und jenes haben,
dann macht es keinen Sinn, im Vorfeld schon mal was zu kaufen.
Ich finde es viel sinnvoller, installiere dir in Linux,
entweder auf dem mini pc auf dem mini pc installierte linux darauf oder oder installierte
vor allem der workstation und installierte linux in der form linux in der form ist auch vollkommen
kommen fein wenn du nicht gerade spiele drin spielen willst oder oder gpu
decodete videos abspielen willst oder sowas installieren linux in der vm und
dann benutzt das einfach ein bisschen anzumachen
ein bisschen schicker weil du dann hatte ich auch ein bisschen mit hardware und
sowas beschäftigen muss ist ein mini pc und es gibt es gibt jede menge mini pcs
Jetzt muss ich übrigens mal ein bisschen hier
mal zu... Hallo?
Mal zumachen, weil ansonsten blicke ich nicht mehr durch,
wenn ich so viel Kram offen habe.
Kauf dir Mini-PC. Also ich
habe zum Beispiel hier einen.
Den würde ich aber nicht mehr kaufen.
So einen habe ich hier.
Wobei, die haben doch... Warte mal.
Wie link? Ja, da hier.
Gibt's nicht mehr.
Guck mal mal, was Beelink hat.
Ich nehme jetzt mal einfach irgendeinen.
Mini-PC.
Open Claw Pre-Install.
What the fuck, Alter.
Was wollen die hier?
Suchst du dir irgendeinen günstigen Mini-PC hier raus?
Sofern es da noch irgendwas
günstiges überhaupt gibt.
Die Preise sind mittlerweile schon gesalzen.
Naja, das hier geht doch noch eigentlich klar.
Guck mal, was haben wir denn hier Schönes?
Das da, ne?
Das sieht doch gar nicht übel aus.
Alter, guck mal, hier kriegst du...
Hier kriegst du noch 16 Gigramm.
Wobei ich ehrlich gesagt eher eine AMD-Kiste mit AMD-GPU nehmen würde.
Also wahrscheinlich sowas hier.
Ja, kauf dir irgendeinen günstigen Mini-PC.
Es muss nicht der sein, weil ich habe keine Ahnung, ob der gut ist, ja.
Such dir einen guten Mini-PC raus und installiere Linux da drauf.
Weil von Dualboot halte ich nichts.
Du kannst dir auch bei Ebay eine alte Office-Kiste kaufen, ja.
Also, aber wie gesagt, ich würde dir eher empfehlen, anstatt dass, bevor du dir eine NAS holst,
ein Raspberry Pi holst oder sonst was, installiere dir Linux auf irgendeinem Mini-PC,
auf dem alten Office-PC von eBay in der VM,
benutzt täglich
für deine tägliche Arbeit
oder für das, was du täglich am PC machst,
benutzt einfach Linux.
Und du wirst permanent über irgendwelche
Sachen stolpern,
die du noch nicht kennst
und dich damit beschäftigen musst.
Und dann, wenn du ein bisschen
einfach als tägliche
Arbeits-PC verwenden, schnell genug sind
die Dinger ja,
einfach für deine
tägliche arbeit verwenden was du so am pc hat machst du wirst du dann auch gleich feststellen
ok manche software gibt es vielleicht nicht unter die lukse gerne hättest oder du stellst
fest ist ja viel geiler unter linux genau so wie so würde ich das machen und wenn du dich
damit beschäftigt dann wirst du ja früher oder später auch ideen haben für für software die du
bei dir laufen lassen möchtest ja du kannst du sie auf dem linux mini pc testweise schon
installieren ja war was ich paypal es nextcloud bei hole was auch immer kann mir also auf dem
linux mini pc auch schon installieren und bisschen rum gucken und irgendwann sagst du dann ey das
sind die anwendungen die würde ich mal gerne bei mir 24 7 laufen lassen weil ich weil ich für mich
um arbeitserleichterung bringen und dann kauft sie dir das passende passende gerät für welche
distro würdest du vorschlagen zum wechsel ja linux mit ist eigentlich so der safe default
choice kann man eigentlich nichts mit verkehrt machen ich persönlich würde ja sogar sagen wenn
man wirklich sich mit linux im detail beschäftigen will warum nicht cash ios cash ios hat einen
ordentlich das ist das hier ja cash us hat einen ordentlichen installer ist art space und hat ein
ganz gut vor konfiguriert das kde inklusive snapshots wenn man es kaputt macht man wieder
zurückrollen kann also ich würde cash us installieren wenn ich wirklich vor hätte mich
mit linux tiefer auseinander zu setzen nur barak geht sicherlich auch ja besser oder besserheit
geht wahrscheinlich auch. Ich würde wahrscheinlich
CacheOS installieren. Wenn man wirklich
Linux lernen will, dann ArchManual installieren.
Nee, nicht als erster Kontakt
mit Linux. CacheOS plus
Gnome auch okay. Wahrscheinlich, aber
Gnome suckt halt.
So, wir haben immer noch nicht geguckt,
was die Polizei jetzt eigentlich hier will.
WTF, wir haben uns etwas sidetracken
lassen.
Und wenn du da deine Linux Journey gestartet hast, sag mal im Stream Bescheid.
Oder wenn du irgendwas wissen willst, wir haben ja ordentlich High IQ Linux Leute hier im Chat.
Also die können dir schon helfen.
Was übrigens auch der weitere Vorteil ist, wenn du es nicht dual bootest oder irgendwie so komische Dinger machst,
und eine extra PC hast, du machst dir halt nichts kaputt.
Du kannst immer noch sagen, Mist, ich brauche jetzt mal was, was funktioniert,
und du switchst halt wieder auf deine Windows-Kiste.
So.
Also, was wollen sie denn jetzt überhaupt haben hier?
Ihre Aufgaben.
Helfen sie dabei, die staatliche Handlungsfähigkeit
durch eine funktionsfähige Informationstechnik sicherzustellen.
Okay, bla bla bla.
Die Aufgaben unserer IT-Leitstelle,
einem 24-Stunden-IT-Service
für die Polizei NRW
an 365 Tagen im Jahr. Okay.
Heißt auch Schichtarbeit mit
Nachtschicht und allem möglichen.
Umfasst als First Point
of Contact.
Also quasi ein
Spock.
Ein Single Point of Contact.
Das wird bestimmt Spock abgekürzt.
Das ist eine gute Abkürzung.
Unter anderem die Annahme von
Störungsmeldungen, konkret auch, okay, bla bla bla bla,
die sofortige ursache in abhängigkeit der persönlichen kenntnisse bezüglich
so ist der einsatz neben parallel dem allgemeinen first level polk den
schwerpunkt polizeiliche vorgangsbearbeitung oder mobilität
möglich
Überwachung, also du guckst den ganzen Tag auf irgendeine Wand mit Monitoring-Sachen drauf.
Also ich finde, das klingt jetzt nicht so prickelnd irgendwie.
Ich meine, es ist halt Support, da hätte ich eh keinen Bock drauf.
Aber wenn man, also war mal so, wenn man sowas gerne machen will, vielleicht gerne zur Polizei möchte, oder da arbeiten, warum nicht?
Ich meine, das liest sich jetzt nicht schlecht oder so, das liest sich halt wie ein First-Level-Job und auf den hätte ich halt keinen Bock.
Aber an sich liest sich, also wenn man da Bock drauf hat, liest sich das nicht schlecht.
Ihr Profil, Sie verfügen über einen Abgeschlaucht-Keyblade, oder, okay, Sie verfügen über Erfolg, Denkvermögen, Office-Produkte,
ein Problem. Da haben wir nicht wirklich viel
Anforderungen.
Was mich interessieren würde, ist
jetzt noch, was es für Kohle
gibt. Oder besser
gesagt, welche
Stufe man kriegt.
Das wäre natürlich nicht ganz unerheblich dafür,
ob es da Leute gibt, die sich da drauf
bewerben und sich das vorstellen können oder nicht.
Übrigens, lustige
Story zum Thema Monitoring.
Ihr wisst doch, ich habe
Beim alten Arbeitgeber, beim letzten Arbeitgeber, habe ich im gleichen Büro gesessen, wie auch unser Spock.
Wie auch unser Support.
Beziehungsweise unser Operation Center.
Und ich habe da so ein paar Sachen mitgekriegt.
Und die hatten auch eine ganz große Monitorwand vorne, wo Monitoring drauf war.
Da war Zabbix drauf, da war Kafana drauf, da war so ein internes Log-Monitoring-Tool drauf.
Ist man dann eigentlich ein Beamter als Support?
Ich weiß nicht. Wahrscheinlich nicht.
wissen tue ich nicht muss man da nicht ein sporttest bestehen ich glaube als
it support mitarbeiter musste kein sporttest bestehen
so genau also lustig lustig sagt zum thema monitor hatten da auch eine
monitor wand und da war dann wie gesagt war war internet log tool kafana zabbix
und so drauf.
Und
wer
Monitore im Enterprise-Business-Umfeld
kennt, weiß,
es ist nie alles grün.
Es gibt so die üblichen
Zabbix, nicht
Zabex, was auch immer Zabex sein soll.
Zabbix.
Äh.
Ich habe gerade nachgeguckt.
Zabix ist anscheinend ein deutscher YouTube-Stelzer.
Sag mal.
Zabix.
Das meine ich hier.
Zabix ist unnötig kompliziert.
Das stimmt.
aber ich finde so im klassischen monitoring bereich so host basiert und
sowas ist es das beste was es gibt
die webseite ist halt mal wieder richtig dumm so sieht das aus genauso und
topics dashboard
genau und was
ich jetzt eigentlich sagen wollte
und wer so ein Business Enterprise Monitoring
kennt, der weiß, es ist nie alles grün
Checkmk ist
ich kenne Checkmk, ich mag Checkmk
nicht, Checkmk
und die hatten, und das stimmt jetzt
also das stimmt wirklich, was ich jetzt sage
das kann man bei dem Forum nachlesen
Checkmk
hatte bis vor, glaube zwei Jahren
oder drei Jahre mittlerweile
keinen UI-Designer.
Und genau so sieht CheckMK
auch aus. CheckMK sieht einfach aus wie
eine Monitoring-Software, die
seit 15 Jahren entwickelt wird, aber keinen UI-Designer
hatte.
Was ist denn mit Prometheus? Prometheus ist ja kein
klassisches, so hostbasiertes
Monitoring wie Zabbix. Prometheus ist so
Matrix-Collecting.
I'm serious.
Dafür ist Prometheus das Beste, was es gibt.
PRTG ist schon mal aus dem Grund Schrott
Ich weiß nicht, ob es Schrott ist
Aber für mich ist es aus einem Grund schon mal Schrott
Windows Only
Mir kommt keine Windows
Also mir kommt keine Windows Only Software in die Tüte
Wo ich den Windows Server für betreiben müsste
An sich soll PRTG gar nicht so schlecht sein
So, zumindest, wie gesagt
Um jetzt erstmal abzulesen
Wer Business Enterprise Monitoring kennt
Der weiß, es ist nie alles grün
Es gibt da immer so die üblichen paar Verdächtigen von, angeblich ist es ein Warning, aber eigentlich ist das Warning doch okay.
Ja, gibt es immer mal wieder. Mir fällt jetzt gerade kein gutes Beispiel für ein.
Ja, zum Beispiel irgendjemand hat mal einen Filter angelegt, sobald Error in einem Log auftaucht, ist es ein Warning.
So, und das Problem ist, dass Anwendung XY halt ein Error lockt, wenn eine Websocket-Verbindung abbricht.
Ja, wenn eine Websocket-Verbindung abbricht, ist es scheißegal, aber es taucht als Warning auf, solche Dinger.
Oder genau, Switch-Temperaturen, wobei das ist vielleicht...
Je nachdem, sollte man da schon mal drauf gucken.
Also ich habe einmal einen Rechenzentrumsbrand erlebt, Leute.
Einmal.
Also auf Temperaturen sollte man vielleicht doch mal gucken.
Genau, so.
So, und das war dann so, da gab es so die üblichen Warnings, die immer offen waren.
So, und die waren auch vorne auf der Monitoring-Wand.
Das war auch schon alles eskaliert, soweit ich das mitgekriegt habe.
Und das waren halt so typische Warnings, wo die Leute, die sich um den Server kümmern mussten, es nicht interessiert hat.
Und irgendwann, wie gesagt, ich habe ja im gleichen Großraumbüro gehockt.
und irgendwann kam dann der Chef
von diesem Support-Team,
die halt sich das Monitoring den ganzen Tag
angeguckt haben, kam da zu denen und hat gesagt,
Leute, gleich kommt
einer vom Vorstand vorbei,
sorgt mal dafür, dass alles
grün ist.
Und da sind die halt einfach hingegangen
und haben den Filter angepasst,
so nach dem Motto,
alles was
ähm
älter als drei Tage
ist, wird rausgefiltert
und dann war die komplette Monitoring-Wand
leer. Und es sah dann halt
geil aus.
Letztendlich hat es mit der Realität nichts zu tun gehabt,
aber hat sich gut gemacht.
Ja, genau sowas, ja.
Max, hast du heute Bereitschaft?
Nicht, dass ich wüsste.
Ich habe aber auch mein Handy von der Arbeit hier liegen, also...
Wenn mich einer versuchen würde, ans...
Oh.
Leute, mich hat...
Mich hat heute um 0.16 jemand angerufen.
Und auf Voicemail gesprochen.
Moment, ich muss da mal kurz reingucken.
Ach.
Das ist wieder auch so eine...
Das ist auch wieder so eine unsinnige Monitoring-Meldung gewesen.
Ne, ne, ich hab keine Bereitschaft.
unser Monitoring-System
hat mir versucht, eine Nachricht zu schicken,
hat es nicht auf die Reihe gekriegt und hat mich deswegen angerufen.
Hä?
Ich habe noch eine Voice-Nachricht und die sagt, guten Morgen, wir haben ein Alert, bei dem ich eine Plausibilisierung benötige.
Vielleicht können Sie sich bei Gelegenheit wieder zurückmelden.
Vom 23. Februar, ich habe mich nie zurückgemeldet.
Dann schreibt halt mal was anderes, als irgendwann mitten in der Nacht anzurufen.
Ich glaube, das ist jetzt...
Hat sich ausplausibilisiert, wenn es vom 23. Februar war.
Wahrscheinlich...
Das Ticket ist noch offen.
Da wartet immer noch auf die Antwort.
Ach, ich weiß, was das war.
Jetzt fällt es mir wieder ein.
Ich weiß, was das war.
Doch, das habe ich schon.
Das haben wir schon plausibilisiert.
Mit dem habe ich telefoniert.
Das war, ich habe ein paar Ansible Jobs gestartet.
Am Wochenende war das.
Oder war da 23? Warte mal.
Oder, äh, äh, weiß nicht.
Was war da 23. Februar für ein Tag?
Dienstag.
Okay. Ja, das wird es aber gewesen sein.
Ich habe ein paar Ansible Jobs gestartet.
Die Ansible Jobs haben
Updates gemacht, inklusive Reboot.
Leider ist der Ansible Job
ein bisschen
optimistisch.
wie schnell die Server neu starten und versucht sich immer wieder einzuloggen,
aber der Server ist noch gar nicht da.
Dementsprechend gibt es ganz viele fehlgeschlagene Login-Versuche vom Ansible
und ab einer gewissen Anzahl von fehlgeschlagenen Login-Versuchen
taucht das in irgendeinem Log auf und unser 24-7-Support ruft da an und sagt,
oh, böse Hackermans sind da vielleicht am Start.
Wir fragen da mal nach bei der Handynummer, die bei diesem User hinterlegt ist.
Jaja, das ist es.
Das habe ich schon geklärt.
Ne, ne, passt alles.
Check MK.
Ich mag Check MK nicht.
Guck mal hier.
Guck doch hier.
Check MK Web Interface.
Das sieht so eklig aus.
Ja, das hier geht jetzt sogar noch.
Aber,
wenn du halt Settings
hier sowas.
Ey, das sieht so eklig aus.
Guckt euch das an.
Machst du auch Kubernetes Terraform?
Ja, fast jeden Tag.
Das ist eigentlich das Hauptsächliche, was ich mache.
Sowas hier, Alter.
Diese Oberfläche, wie TF.
Da musst du schon einiges machen,
dass das so aussieht.
Ne, das ist nicht.
Also wie gesagt, ich kann CheckMK nicht leiden.
Ich kann SubX aber auch nicht
leiden. Ja, guck mal.
Das sind die Settings.
So stellst du Settings ein.
Also, die...
Das ist komplett, ohne dass
das jemals ein UI-Designer gesehen hat,
hier dieses Ding.
Was ist das? Was ist das für ein GUI, Alter?
Und es geht ja noch drei Seiten
weiter was ist das für ein gui kann man kuba näht es oder auch so nebenher
machen und es ist ein folger das hängt davon ab wie viele sachen darauf laufen
wie viel klasse ihr habt und sowas das kann man auch nebenbei machen aber es
macht es hat einen vorteil wenn man sich da sagen wir eine weile vollzeit mit
beschäftigt weil kuba net ist ein kuba net ist an sich ist nicht das problem
das ökosystem drumherum was ist da alles gibt ja irgendwann kommt dann noch ist
video für service mesh und alles mögliche dabei weil lehrer für
irgendwelche backup geschichten das ist ein fass ohne boden jetzt kommt
neuerdings gateway api dabei weil ingress nicht mehr angesagt ist also das
ist wirklich ist check mk ui das ist aber es kein wunder die hatten bis vor
drei jahre kein ui designer weiß nicht ob ich den eintrag im forum noch finde
hier weg
zumindest haben sie im offiziellen forum geschrieben dass sie jetzt einen ui
designer haben oder ein front end designer oder irgendwie sowas
ja check mk higher dedicated ui ux designer
Die Software ist halt 20 Jahre alt und hatte 20 Jahre lang oder 18 Jahre lang keinen UI-Designer.
Und so sieht das Webinterface von CheckMK halt auch aus.
Ist halt nicht so nice.
So, was haben wir hier als nächstes?
Chat.
Ich muss mir mal kurz was zu trinken holen.
Wobei.
Oh, bye.
So lang bin ich auch noch mal da.
Was haben wir denn hier jetzt zu bieten?
IT-Systemadministrator,
Schwerpunkt
Data Center bei
Yin...
Yin-Chorus, oder wie spricht man das aus?
Y-Yin-Chorus?
Äh...
Yin-Chorus?
Okay, ich hab absolut keinen Ahnung, wie man die ausspricht.
Gehaltsspannung,
65k bis 85k.
Checkmk sieht zumindest besser aus als Raw Nagios.
Das stimmt.
Raw Nagios ist aber auch sehr oldschool.
Was war der schlimmste Fehler, der dir mal unterlaufen ist und was hatte das für Konsequenzen?
Hm.
Was war der schlimmste Fehler?
Also das nervigste, was ich mal aus Versehen gemacht habe, ist, als ich noch Linux auf meinem Notebook hatte, habe ich mal aus Versehen mein Heimatverzeichnis gelöscht.
RM-RF, ne? Mit, mit, mit, äh, nicht aufgepasst.
Und ich war Remote eingeloggt auf die Kiste.
Das war sehr unvorteilhaft, weil ich mein Heimatverzeichnis gelöscht habe.
Das war so einmal eines der mit unangenehmsten Sachen, aber das ist jetzt, da ist jetzt nichts Schlimmes passiert.
Ich überlege gerade mal, was...
Ich habe bestimmt schon Sachen kaputt gemacht,
aber mir fällt jetzt gerade nicht viel ein.
Habe ich mal wirklich irgendwie größer was kaputt gemacht,
was große Probleme gemacht hat?
Ich bin mal bei der nächtlichen Rechenzentrumswartung,
bin ich mal mit meiner Jacke an nem
SFP Plus Modul hängen geblieben und
hab's aus dem Switch rausgezogen.
Ich hab das einfach wieder
reingesteckt und gehofft, es merkt nie einer was.
Und ich hab nie wieder was von gehört.
Samuel, danke schön für den
Sub. Pogsubscription.
Ähm.
Aber, also was hab ich
schon Schlimmes mal angestellt? Ich weiß nicht.
Mir fällt jetzt...
Mir fällt da jetzt nicht so viel ein, was jetzt
wirklich große Probleme gemacht hat.
Also wie ich Azubi war, haben sie uns mal versucht
einen Ausfall in die Schuhe zu schieben, das habe ich ja schon mal erzählt
Das zählt ja aber nicht
Ich habe keine Ahnung. Mir fällt gerade nichts Gutes ein.
Was jetzt irgendwie so richtig große Ausfälle mit viel Kohle verbunden verursacht hätte.
Das wisst ihr wahrscheinlich sogar besser,
weil wenn es da was gab, habe ich es bestimmt schon mal im Stream
erzählt, aber mir fällt gerade nichts ein.
Nö, keine Ahnung.
Also ich war bei vielen Fails dabei.
Aber da, wo ich es
mal groß verkackt hätte, dass dann
das richtig in die Kohle gegangen wäre.
Richtig Geld
gekostet hätte. Kann ich mich
jetzt gerade so nicht dran erinnern.
Viel gegeben wird es ja da nicht haben, sonst würde es
wahrscheinlich gleich einfallen.
Wenn das so problematisch
gewesen wäre.
Ich meine, Kleinigkeiten
gab es natürlich immer.
Dass ich mal irgendwie außerdem das falsche Reboot
etab oder sowas.
Ach, das hier.
Wo ich den Server nicht runtergefahren hab.
Oh, da kann ich mich schon gar nicht mehr
richtig dran erinnern.
Aber das war nix Schlimmes.
Das war nix Schlimmes.
Da hab ich bei Google
irgendeine fette Kiste nicht runtergefahren.
Das hat halt ein bisschen Geld gekostet.
Aber das, das...
Das sind alles...
Das ist zwar nicht schön,
aber das ist jetzt nichts, wo es irgendwie groß Ärger gibt
beziehungsweise Millionen umgegen oder so.
Nee,
fällt mir nichts zu ein. Muss ich mir mal Gedanken
zu machen.
Also, was will denn Jinkoris?
Wurde schon mal verrückte Sachen
in Frankfurt angeboten. Ja,
Ah, ja, ja.
Manchmal, was ganz weird ist,
wenn du am Hauptbahnhof vorbeiläufst
und du läufst relativ langsam
und du guckst ein bisschen nach links und rechts
und läufst relativ entspannt herum,
da denken manche Dealer,
du bist auf der Suche nach Drogen und folgen dir dann.
Weil die denken, du willst quasi nicht so offensichtlich
am Hauptbahnhof stehen bleiben.
Und das hatte ich jetzt schon ein paar Mal,
dass ich, ich hatte einfach Zeit, ja.
Ich habe gedacht, okay, bevor ich da 10 Minuten rumstehe, läufst du langsam.
Da bin ich halt langsam am Hauptbahnhof,
oder beziehungsweise an den Nebenstraßen
vorbeigelaufen, langsam.
Hab ein bisschen links und rechts geguckt.
Und da sind mir schon ein paar Mal
irgendwelche Leute gefolgt.
Und ich wette mit euch,
das waren irgendwelche Dealer,
die gedacht haben, ich gehe jetzt in eine dunkle Ecke
und frage, hast du was?
Habe ich natürlich nicht gemacht.
Ich habe selbst genug Pillen,
die ich nehmen muss, da muss ich nicht zum Hauptbahnhof.
Ja.
Okay, schauen wir mal.
Was gibt es denn bei Jinkoris?
Jinkoris oder...
Ich frage mich immer nur, wie man das ausspricht.
Sie möchten nicht einfach irgendwo arbeiten.
Nee, ich will vor allem da arbeiten, wo es ordentlich Kohle gibt.
Sondern mit ihrer Expertise wirklich etwas bewegen.
Ja, das ist mir nicht so wichtig.
wichtig ist, dass ich viel Kohle kriege.
Das darf man natürlich mal so einem
Vorstellungsgrin... Wisst ihr eigentlich, wie
wie
wie soll man sagen, so verlogen
das Zeug eigentlich ist? Das wollen die
ja nicht hören, ne?
Wenn dich einer fragt, warum wollen sie unbedingt
zu uns? Und du sagst ja, damit ich nicht
unter der Brücke schlafen muss.
Das finden die als Antwort bestimmt doof.
Die wollen dann hören, ja,
weil ich schon immer bei so einem tollen,
modernen, innovativen Unternehmen
arbeiten wollte oder sowas. Wenn du sagst,
Ja, ich brauche Geld. Ich will nicht unter der Brücke schlafen.
Das finden die wahrscheinlich nicht witzig.
Bei einem führenden Unternehmen natürlich.
50-köpfiges IT-Team.
Okay, das ist schon ein bisschen größerer Laden.
Wir suchen sie einen IT-Profi.
MWD.
Administrator.
Mit Fokus auf Data Center Technologien.
Okay, also was machen sie denn?
Sie übernehmen die Verantwortung für die Data Center Infrastruktur, muss man ja dann sagen,
unseres Chemieparks vom klassischen Storage bis zur modernen Cloud-Architektur Azure.
Okay.
Dazu gehören Aufgaben wie die Wiederherstellung von Systemen und Daten, die Betreuung der Server- und Storage-Strukturen und die Betreuung der Lifecycle-Managements im Datacenter.
Okay, ja gut, passt, macht Sinn.
Mit Weitblick handeln. Sie erkennen Optimierungspotenziale, setzen Ideen um und entwickeln bestehende Systeme eigenverantwortlich weiter.
Okay, blablabla. Das ist irgendwie so eine...
Klingt gut, bringt dir aber nichts weiter jetzt, dass du das gelesen hast.
Sie entwickeln und setzen Lösungen und Konzepte für die im Verantwortungsbereich befindlichen Systeme um.
Ja, was denn sonst?
Cloud und Co. Sie begleiten und gestalten Migration in die Cloud mit dem Blick für Sicherheit, Verfügbarkeit und Performance.
Okay. Zusammenarbeiten
in enger Abstimmung mit
Experten
aus anderen Bereichen sowie externen Partnern.
Haupt...
Mit externen Partnern.
WMD. Ja, was denn sonst?
Ey, man kann's doch
übertreiben.
Außerdem, außerdem
muss das nicht
mittlerweile noch
deutlich mehr Geschlechter
enthalten.
Damit das politisch korrekt
ist.
Treiben Sie innovative Lösungen voran.
Okay.
Massive Innovative.
Alles im Blick.
Sie erstellen, aktualisieren, überwachen,
Dokumentation, Chat, die sind
einfach nicht oft genug bei uns im Stream.
Die kennen einfach noch nicht
Error-Free-Programming
und
Tail-less
Administration.
Die wissen einfach nicht Bescheid.
Die denken noch, sie brauchen Dokumentation
und Anleitung und sowas. Das ist ja falsch.
Wenn die Sachen einfach
First Try immer funktionieren
und keine Fehler haben,
dann brauchst du keine Dokumentation
Du brauchst keine Kommentare.
Du brauchst keinen Support.
Brauchst gar nichts.
Kannst dir alles sparen.
Einfach fehlerfrei arbeiten.
Wozu brauchst du wieder Anlaufpläne, wenn es fehlerfrei ist?
Weil wenn es fehlerfrei ist, dann stürzt es nicht ab.
Und wenn es nicht abstürzt, musst du es auch nicht wieder anlaufen lassen.
Ist doch logisch.
Die haben einfach nicht aufgepasst hier.
Sicherheit mitdenken.
Sie sorgen für einen stabilen und sicheren IT-Betrieb und des Chemieparks Knapsack.
Der Chemiepark Knapsack.
Okay, was wollen sie haben?
Drei Jahre Berufserfahrung, Administration, VMWare.
VM, das ist so Backup-Gedöns.
Storage-Systeme sowie...
Storage-Systemen finde ich das immer wichtig,
dass sie dabei schreiben sollten,
welche Storage-Systeme.
Weil es gibt ja die unterschiedlichsten Hersteller.
Du kriegst von Dell was, du kriegst von IBM was,
du kriegst von, oder Lenovo was,
du kriegst von
Hitachi
was, NetApp.
Es gibt ja die zehn Unterschiede. Und ganz
ehrlich, das ist auch wieder so ein Ding.
Nur weil sich einer super gut in dem
Ökosystem von, sagen wir, IBM-Haus kennt,
heißt nicht, dass er super Durchblick hat bei
was anderem. Aber er kommt wahrscheinlich einfacher rein.
Ja.
Vorzugsweise Linux und Azure
Cloud Computing.
Vergütung nach
Chemietarif.
Das ist ja an sich
nicht verkehrt.
welche stufe denn gibt es ja bestimmt auch unterschiedliche stufen sicher in
die zukunft altersvorsorge gesundheit mitgliedschaft im urban sports club
leistungsprämen zuschuss betriebsrestaurant also zu ja
subventionierte kantine quasi das finde ich ganz nah ist haben wir auch kam aber
Kann ich nur empfehlen, sowas.
Und viele mehr.
Ja, außer, dass überall MWD dahinter steht.
Da sind sie, guck mal her.
Kann ich das nicht irgendwie muten?
Da laufen Leute durch den Park.
Okay.
Was genau hat das jetzt
mit IT und so
zu tun?
Die laufen da auf dem... Ach, das ist das Sommerfest
2023.
Naja.
So viel erkennt man da jetzt vom Unternehmen
aber nicht, dass die da im Sommerfest eine Hüpfburg
haben.
Okay, das soll
gute Stimmung vermitteln, ja.
so nach dem Motto, wir sind hier eine große Familie
und alle ziehen am gleichen Strang und sowas.
Okay, die Stellenanzeige ist nicht schlecht.
Die geht klar.
Bisschen wenig Infos, was
jetzt eigentlich wirklich machst ist drinnen, finde ich.
Die geht schon klar.
Also das ist sicherlich nicht die beste Stellenanzeige,
die ich je gesehen habe, das ist aber auch weit davon entfernt,
eine von den schlechteren zu sein.
Das ist so eine
Durchschnitts ganz gute
Gel-Anzeige.
Ist okay.
Wenn ich quasi aus der Nähe kommen würde
und unbedingt auf der Suche nach einem Job wäre,
würde ich mich da bewerben.
Ist jetzt aber nicht so, dass ich sagen würde,
Alter,
das spricht mich so
an, dass ich dahin umziehe
oder so.
Und wenn ich einen guten Job habe, mich da trotzdem bewerbe oder so.
Ich habe auch weniger Urlaubstage, weil ich einen Tag die Woche weniger arbeite.
Aktuelle Stellenangebote...
Ich sollte manchmal langsam machen mit Lesen.
Ich habe es zum Glück gerade noch abgebrochen, weil ich sagen wollte.
Aktuelle Stellenangebote bei Lang & Schwarz.
Times New Roman Font.
Okay, also was suchen die denn überhaupt?
Mobiles Arbeiten, Erholungsurlaub, Kultur, ergonomische Arbeitsplätze, Sachbezug, Kader, Verpflegung.
Ah.
Ein Korb mit frischem Obst steht ebenso bereit.
Ja, endlich der Obstkorb. Den hatten wir heute ja noch gar nicht.
Deutschland-Ticket, Paketlieferung, Fitness.
Schon wieder der Urban Sports Club.
Hatten wir das gerade schon mal eben.
defop systemadministrator linux windows suchen sie
ach so muss man das scrollen okay die webseite ist paintchamp alter
Die Web...
Ey, ohne Scheiß, die Webseite sackt richtig
Wenn das Bild das Büro ist
Wo gibt es hier ein Bild? Ich sehe überhaupt kein Bild
Bild?
Das hier hinten, oder was?
Das ist bestimmt nicht das Büro
Ach, das da, meinst du?
Das hier.
Na, das ist eher der First Level Support hier, oder?
Mit so einer Monitorwand.
Oder was ist das? Was bin ich hier sehend überhaupt?
Außerdem, wo ist der Obstkorb?
KI-Bild.
Jetzt lass uns mal gucken hier.
Also, was suchen sie denn?
Du bist gemeinsam mit deinen
Kolleginnen und Kollegen zuständig
für den Betrieb, Modernisierung und bei Bedarf
auch die Instandsetzung der
IT-Infrastruktur von Lang und Schwarz.
Dazu gehören insbesondere die Überwachung
der Verfügbarkeit.
Was machen die eigentlich?
Trade Center.
Ah.
Das sind Handelsarbeitsplätze, oder?
Kann das sein?
Handelsstelz?
Ja, dann verstehe ich, dass sie so viele Monitore haben.
Stimmt, der Footer ist oben. Warum das denn?
Überwachung der Verfügbarkeit von Server und Diensten, die Kontrolle von automatischen Datenverarbeitungsprozessen sowie Annahme, Wahl und Nachfolge von Stör- und Fehlermeldungen der Anwender.
Der Anwender. Ja, es sind immer Anwenderfehler, ne? Das ist wie beim Fiat Champ.
Alles Anwenderfehler.
Deine Arbeit leistest du in Zusammenarbeit mit einem professionellen und eingespielten Team, das dir jederzeit fachlichen Rückhalt bietet.
Nach der Einarbeitungsphase bietet sich die möglichst eigene, fahrende und selbstständige Arbeitsweise.
Im Fokus stehen besonders die folgenden Tätigkeiten.
Wartung, Installation, Modernisierung von Servernsystemen.
Okay, das ist super breit, das kann alles sein.
Selbstständiges Incident- und Problemmanagement für Linux- und Windows-Server.
Ihhh, Windows-Server.
Wartung und Entwicklung von skriptbasierten Datenverarbeitungsprozeduren.
Alter, das ist ja...
Skriptbasierten Datenverarbeitungsprozeduren.
Das könnte was von mir auf der Arbeit sein.
Die stehen auch auf so besonders deutsche Begriffe.
Ausbau der Dokumentationen so System.
Siehst du? Die haben auch bei mir im Stream nicht aufgepasst wieder.
Das bringst du mit.
Linux-Betriebssysteme.
Debian, Red Hat, CentOS.
Ich glaube nicht, dass die noch wirklich CentOS meinen.
Weil CentOS ist nicht mehr das CentOS, was es früher war.
Das müsste jetzt eher sowas wie Rocky-Linux oder Alma-Linux oder so sein.
Vernetzte Umgebung, Netzwerkprotokolle.
Okay.
Das ist auch sehr, sehr
breit geschrieben.
Skriptprogrammierung
mit Bash und Python.
Okay. Ja.
Abfrage von Datenbanken
mit einfachen SQL-Skripten.
Okay, das sollte auch noch jeder auf die Reihe kriegen.
Außerdem sollten Kenntnisse in den
Folgen Technologien vorhanden sein.
Linux, Samba, IMAP,
SMTP.
SMTP? Wirklich?
Die wollen doch keinen Mail-Server
selbst betreiben, oder?
Ich hoffe nicht.
Ich hoffe nicht, dass die das wollen.
Oder meinen die einfach nur
vom Server E-Mails verschicken
an irgendeine zentrale Stelle.
DNS, DHCP. Okay.
Das wirkt ein bisschen random, aber...
Okay, warum nicht?
MS, 2016
Serversysteme?
Was ist denn das aktuelle
Windows-Server?
Bestimmt nicht
2016, oder?
2024?
2025? Und das davor?
Was war das davor?
22.
Und davor war dann,
vor 22 war 16, oder?
Oder kam da noch was
dazwischen, zwischen 16 und 22?
19!
Okay, das heißt,
hier sind vier Windows-Server-Versionen
hintendran.
Gibt's da überhaupt noch Support für?
Extended Support oder Extra Support?
Okay.
Der Support ist seit 2022 zu Ende.
Und Extended Support ist in einem halben Jahr zu Ende.
Viel Spaß.
Windows 10 Desktop.
Kann das sein, dass die einfach ihre Stellenanzeige
schon eine ganze Weile nicht mehr aktualisiert haben?
Dass die Stellenanzeige
irgendwie 7, 8 Jahre alt ist?
Windows 10 Desktop Clients.
Das haben die aber bestimmt keine Windows 10 Desktop Clients mehr.
Benutzerverwaltung mit Active Directory.
Das ist halt so ein Ding.
Leute, die richtig Ahnung von Linux haben,
sind das nicht unbedingt die besten Active Directory
Admins.
Also ich will nicht sagen, dass ich
richtig geiler Linux-Admin bin, aber ich hab schon
ein bisschen Ahnung von Linux.
Und ich hab null Ahnung.
Absolut null Ahnung.
Und auch überhaupt kein Bock,
Ahnung zu haben von Active Directory.
Allgemeine, mindestens
fünfjährige Berufserfahrung nach der Ausbildung.
Soziale Kompetenz.
Oh, jetzt geht's los, Leute.
Analytische und lösungsorientierte
Arbeitsbedingungen. Selbstständige und eigenverantwortliche
Arbeitsweise. Teamfähigkeit, Konfliktfähigkeit
und Kommunikationsfähigkeit.
Hohe Serviceorientierung und Hilfsbereitschaft.
Verbindliches und höfliches Auftreten.
Ah, ja.
Bereitschaft zu regeln und teilen.
Frühschicht, Spätschicht.
Aha.
Aha, aha.
Ausgleich von gegebenenfalls anfallenden Überstunden und Wochenendarbeiten durch Freizeit.
Wait a minute, das ist ein Benefit?
Ist das nicht mal das Mindeste, dass man Überstunden und Wochenendarbeit ausgeglichen bekommt?
Ich glaube, das ist sogar gesetzlich erforderlich.
Eine im IT-Budget verbindlich erhaltene Position für Weiterbildung und Qualifizierung.
Okay.
Ein heise Academy Account.
Das klingt mir ehrlich gesagt so ein bisschen, auch wenn es nicht da steht,
schon so ein bisschen nach Support?
Auch wenn es nicht da steht.
Also nee, Support ist das falsche Wort.
Halt als
On-Call-Geschichte.
Was ist das da?
Keine Ahnung.
Ist aber okay.
Wenn man das will.
Wie sieht das mit
rufbereitschaft und nachts und nachts dann aus also quasi von 23 uhr bis 7 uhr sondern nix
also die website ist wirklich will kommen wir gucken uns die webseite mal ohne dark
reader an ehrlich gesagt ist die webseite ohne dark wieder auch nicht viel besser
aber man kriegt wenigstens wenn man blindet wenigstens nicht
Da ist die Börse geschlossen. Achso.
Also bei uns ist es so, dass Systeme, die für Börsenhandel, und ja, das gibt es auch bei einer Versicherung, die machen da auch komische Dinger, frag mich nicht,
die für Börsenhandel wichtig sind, 24-7-Systeme sind,
weil die gleich morgens wenn es losgeht um keine ahnung 37 oder so zur verfügung stehen
müssen also bei uns steht auch jemand auf wenn eines der systeme die für den handel
notwendig sind nachts um drei ausfällt außerdem gibt es da auch systeme die
die irgendwelche Reports und Sachen generieren,
was auch noch sein...
Unsere Systeme, die was mit Handel zu tun haben,
sind 24-7, müssen die verfügbar sein.
Wartungsarbeiten sind dort auch prinzipiell
immer an handelsfreien Tagen.
Ah ja.
Also, was...
Chat, was halten wir von der Stellenanzeige?
Sagt mal, was ihr davon haltet.
Also, die ist sehr...
Wie sagt man heute? Ist sehr mit?
Sagt man das nicht so?
Ist mit?
Mittelmäßig, genau.
Ist sehr mittelmäßig, finde ich.
Ja, Gehalt fände ich auch interessant.
Gibt's leider nix.
Also ich finde das...
Also das hier geht ja noch alles klar.
Das ist okay.
Also das ist jetzt nicht sowas, wo wir eine ganze IT-Abteilung gesucht haben.
Das ist ja noch okay.
Das hier unten wirkt halt ziemlich...
...random und outdated.
Es gibt ja jetzt zwei Varianten.
Entweder ist das wirklich alles so alt und outdated.
und du wirst damit noch sehr viel Spaß haben.
Oder die haben einfach seit sieben Jahren ihre Stellenanzeige nicht aktualisiert,
wie sie sowas ausschreiben. Das kann natürlich auch sein.
Excellent.
Ja gut, wenn es CentOS 7 ist, dann ist es ja auch noch das echte CentOS.
CentOS 7 ist ja glaube ich das letzte richtig echte CentOS gewesen.
Oder CentOS 8?
Was war das letzte?
Ich glaube 7, gell?
Ist EOL. Ja, Red Hat 7 ist auch EOL.
Wir haben auf der Arbeit noch ein paar Red Hat 7 Systeme.
Die sind aber nicht am Netzwerk.
Weil da läuft irgendwas drauf, was glaube ich nur für Red Dead 7 zertifiziert ist oder so.
Keine Ahnung.
Wir haben übrigens noch auf der Arbeit, wisst ihr was?
Wir haben noch Solaris-Systeme, Leute.
Die laufen aber in irgendeinem speziellen Solaris-Emulator.
Das sind keine echten Server mehr.
Ne, das sind keine echten Server.
Das ist irgendein Solaris-Emulator.
War ich noch nie drauf eingeloggt.
Moment.
Und da lief nicht
1000 China-Chinesen-Sachen drauf schon?
Nett.
Da haben die aber Glück gehabt.
wenn wir gerade dabei sind eine runde noch mal sehr laut hier ihr könnt mal bei mir im profil
vorbeigucken auf twitch gibt es einen raff link zu alternates wenn ihr den anklickt ihr könnt
übrigens aus bezeichnen die geld ausrufezeichen ukraine im chat machen wenn er den anklickt kommt
ihr in einem speziellen shop bei alternate raus mit sehr günstigen storage und ukraine
nasspreisen die ist nur über meinen link gibt und nachdem jeder aktuell storage braucht zu
erschwingbaren preisen let's go
daher da der da
war es sicherlich auch noch nie in einer wüste oder
das verstehen jetzt bloß die leute das video auf youtube damals gesehen
wenn ich youtube videos mache demnächst chat ich weiß auch nicht genau was demnächst bedeutet
da muss ich da bestimmt auch wieder irgendeinen leisten sellout einbauen
Aber ich werde keinen Sellout in meinem ersten Video einbauen.
Weil das wirkt dann echt irgendwie ziemlich kacke, oder?
Ich habe seit zweieinhalb Jahren kein Video gemacht.
Das erste Video, was ich hochlade, ist Sellout.
Das ist nix.
Das erste Video mache ich kein Sellout.
Ja, Chat.
Ich will sagen, wir sind für heute fertig.
4 Stunden 20.
Nee, nee, hat mit der Arbeit nicht wirklich was zu tun.
Hatte vielleicht das...
Also hatte das erste Jahr
was mit der Arbeit zu tun, ne?
mit Einarbeitung und alles war schon anstrengend.
Aber das letzte Jahr
lag es an was anderem.
Ein Kott-Video?
Nee.
Ich habe mir die letzten nicht mehr gekauft.
Sehe ich auch nicht ein.
Kann es sein, dass wir uns von den alten
Stellenanzeigen immer noch keine angeguckt haben?
Ja, geil.
Na gut, da muss ich nichts Neues bookmarken,
Keckweight, Alter.
Sorry, falls irgendjemand seit dem letzten Stream immer noch drauf wartet, Chat.
Ich hoffe, das ist nicht der Fall.
Oder wartet seit dem letzten Stream irgendjemand drauf, dass ich mir's anguck?
Das wär echt sad, gell?
Black Ops 1 und 2 kommen jetzt auf der PS4, PS5.
Ja, wirklich?
in irgendeiner Art und Weise
remastered oder wie?
Oder einfach nur ein bisschen upscaled?
Nur geportet, ja.
Naja, gut.
Ich hab zwar eine PS4,
die steht im Wohnzimmer,
Ich habe Fernseh.
Also, nein, nein, nein.
Erste Generation PS4.
Aber ich habe ewig keine Konsole mehr gespielt.
Wenn ich jetzt
Shooter spielen müsste mit dem Controller.
Ich meine, ich bin schon...
Ich habe schon immer zwei linke Hände gehabt mit dem PS3-Controller.
Also mit dem Playstation-Controller.
Also für mich war ja
Peak-Controller-Design der Xbox 360-Controller.
Beste.
den neuen xbox controller mag ich auch nicht so sehr ich mir hat die anordnung gefallen
dass sie nicht ganz symmetrisch war die zwei sticks an dem an dem xbox controller
So, Chat.
4.20.
Waren wir online.
Ich merke schon im Hals, ich habe zu viel gelabert.
Okay.
Noch kein Linux auf der Playstation?
Nee, ich hab so eine alte Playstation.
Es könnte durchaus sein, dass das funktioniert.
Ich hab übrigens noch eine Switch, die modbar ist.
Switch 1.
Ich hab ja zum Release eine Switch 1 gekauft.
Die könnte ich theoretisch modden mit Custom-Firmware.
Aber ich wüsste nicht, wozu.
Hast du eigentlich immer noch die Hightech-Toilette?
Ja, die habe ich noch. Das war eines der besten
Käufe, die ich je getätigt habe.
Mein Hightech-Klo.
Beste.
Aber so Hightech ist die nicht mehr, weil die ist jetzt ja auch schon
13 Jahre alt.
Aber die ist immer noch nice.
Also Chat, wir sehen uns
Morgen früh
Nächster Stream
So wie üblich
So zwischen 8.30 Uhr und 9.30 Uhr
Bin ich am Start
Irgendwie so
Wahrscheinlich eher 9 Uhr
Als 8.30 Uhr
Wir sehen uns, Leute.
Bis dann, macht's gut.
See you.